Es war in den späten Nuller Jahren, so erzählt die Legende, als in Zeiten der aufkommenden Smartphones ein Podcast er tönte. Ein Podcast wie Donahal. Der All jenen, so erzählte die Legende weiter, die ihnen diesen Augenblick zum ersten Mal hörten, den Finger auf den Abonnieren-Knopf führen ließ. Niemand konnte damals ahnen, dass er Zeuge eines historischen Moments geworden ist. Noch heute, ein Jahrzehnt danach, im scheinbar bedrohteren Neuland, erschallt er laut aus dem Podcatcher. Wie damals, als der Gründergeist der frühen Podcaster ins Unermessliche stieg. Eine Legende nahm ihren Lauf, ein Mythos begann zu leben. Und er wird niemals, niemals deabonniert, die Freak Show. Zehn Jahre ist es her, da kriegen sie on Air. 215 Folgen später bringen sie noch mehr. Gestern, heute, morgen für später Lebende. Der Qualitätspodcast auf der Metaebene. Sind Jahre meine Güte, wo ist die Zeit nur geblieben? Alles schneller, größer, bunter und trotzdem nie zufrieden. Yahoo, Google Wave, USB-Sticks mit einem Gigabyte, das war alles Technik, nach der heute niemand schreibt. Der Upload der Folgen zwang die Leitungen in die Knie. Na ja, manche Dinge ändern sich nie. Obwohl woanders klappt's, zum Beispiel in Schweden. Huch, Themenwechsel.
Ich hab mich mal mit Oliver Rohrbeck unterhalten an der Bar. Also ich wusste, dass er das ist, weil ich war jetzt der Sprecher von Justus Jonas von den drei Fragezeichen. Und das war einfach super, super merkwürdig, weil das ist halt auch so ein Kindheits-Ding von mir gewesen, diese ganzen Kassetten gehört. Und dann stehst du da an der Bar und unterhältst dich mit ihm über, weiß ich nicht, es ging irgendwie um seine Kinder und die Ehe und dass die mal bei ihm sind und hier und Hamburg und Berlin und so. Und das war eigentlich super strange.
Das haben wir ja nun nicht. Wir haben ja nur trotz aller Versuchungen, die es da vielleicht mal gegeben hat, der nur bisher strikt darauf verzichtet, hier Videos zu machen oder sonst was. Das heißt, die Leute haben, vielleicht gucken sie mal auf die Webseite. Dann gibt es aber natürlich da keine richtigen, wirklich brauchbaren Bilder von uns, oder? Oder hast du aktuell da brauchen?
Na ja, aber es gibt ein paar Live-Aufnahmen.
Ja, aber da hat trotzdem keiner ein Bild rausgeschnitten oder sonst was. Also es gibt relativ wenig Leute, die mich sozusagen vom Bild her erkennen. Das ist wenn, dann eher so die Stimme oder eben mein Name. Also was häufiger vorkommt, ist, dass welche Leute, die uns zuhören, bei irgendwelchen Firmen irgendwas machen, wo ich jetzt auch irgendwie Consulting oder irgendwelche anderen Geschichten mache. Und die dann sozusagen dahinter kommen, ja, da gibt es jetzt hier noch den und den. Also mein Bild zum Beispiel, das ist halt eine uralte Aufnahme, die Tim übrigens auch geklaut hat.
Klar, ich habe keine Ahnung von dir.
Die schwirrt irgendwo im Netz rum.
Kannst auch mal was Frixures machen. Mein Bild ist auch nicht mehr das aktuellste. Und vor allen Dingen, meine Berufsbezeichnung ist auch nicht mehr das aktuellste. Also Mac OS X mach ich schon lange.
Ja, Sendtiff.
Wie dem auch sei.
Und mein Github fehlt auch.
Wir sind halt nicht so video-mäßig drauf.
Was noch ein bisschen komisch ist, wenn ich Leute treffe, die glaube ich selber gar nicht so richtig Freak Show hören und denen ich irgendwas erzählen will. Und die sagen dann, ja, wissen sie schon, weil sie haben ja einen Kumpel, der ja Freak Show hört und von dem haben sie das, dass ich ja Folgendes gemacht habe. Also so über drei Ecken rum. Und dann kommst du so ein bisschen durcheinander. Dann willst du eigentlich eine Neuigkeit erzählen, dann wissen das alle irgendwie schon.
Das hätte mir aber auch schon mal passiert, dass Leute mich mainsplayen wollten mit dem, was ich hier in der Sendung gemainsplayen habe.
Ja, am Anfang hatte ich das auch. Inzwischen halte ich mich da sehr zurück, irgendwelchen Leuten irgendwas zu erzählen. Sondern ich frag die dann meistens aus, wenn die sich zu erkennen geben als Hörer. Weil, doch du mir neuern? Dann lässt du die doch mal erzählen. Was sind das so für Leute?
Ja, da wird es dann wirklich auch schwierig in der sozialen Interaktion, wenn man schon alles erzählt hat. Also bei der Freak Show hält sich das ja noch in Grenzen. Aber so zu Zeiten von NSFW, ging das dann schon so in meinem Umfeld so weit, dass ich fast gar nichts mehr Neues zu erzählen hatte. Weil das hab ich alles schon in der letzten Sendung ausgepackt.
Und die haben es alle gehört.
Und dann standst du immer ganz allein in der Ecke und keiner hat sich mit dir unterhalten.
Nee, aber es ist schwierig, dann sozusagen nochmal neue Aspekte hervorzukramen. Aber ich sag ja immer, wer im Podcasting erfolgreich sein will, muss ein interessantes Leben führen.
Was wir ja auch gemerkt haben, ist, wenn wir uns mal so ein bisschen vorbereitet haben in dieser Sendung, was heißt vorbereitet, aber bevor die Sendung losging und sie unterhalten haben, was wir dann gleich so erzählen wollen, dann ging das auch immer so ein bisschen schief, weil man kann später während der Sendung im Gehirn nicht mehr rausfinden, hast du das jetzt schon erzählt oder war das vor der Sendung? Man kann die Zeit von etwas nicht gut einschätzen, weil es anders war.
Deswegen will ich auch nicht, dass wir vor der Sendung über die Themen reden.
Vielleicht sollten wir einfach gar nicht miteinander reden und immer nur, wenn die Mikros an sind.
Wir können ja miteinander slacken.
Über die Themen an sich schon, aber über die Feinheiten halt eben nicht.
Oder wir machen einfach den Stream an, sobald die ersten Leute hier eintreffen und wenn wir dann fertig sind mit Pizza essen, spielen wir einfach das Intro und machen weiter.
Aber wir können jetzt mal weitermachen, weil ich...
Nee, das ist aber auch blöd, weil das kann man ja durchaus mal sagen. Wir haben ja alle unterschiedliche lustige Berufe oder geschäftliche Sachen, die wir so machen in unserem anderen Leben. Und das sind manchmal schon Sachen, die man sich hier gegenseitig erzählt, die man aber nicht in die Öffentlichkeit hinausblasen muss.
Das sind fast nur so Sachen, ja.
Eben. Deswegen ist mir die geheime Pre-Show schon ganz lieb.
Solange Timme das Mikrofon nicht offen lässt.
Da wir ja alle wissen, wie lange er braucht, um es überhaupt mal aufzumachen, ist die Chance dafür relativ gering. Naja, das werden wir jetzt reminisieren, kann man ja auch mal überlegen. Wir sind jetzt bei Sendung 215, obwohl wir hatten jetzt einen relativ smoothen Start heute. Bis auf die Tatsache, dass die Mikrofone natürlich erstmal alle aus waren am Anfang. Da es schon halb neun war. Aber ein bisschen entwickelt sich Genossenbauern. Also es wird das Podcast-Wesen.
Wenn die Telekom jetzt auffährt, mir alle paar Wochen meinen DSL-Anschluss mitten in der Sendung abzuschalten.
Da druckelt sich alles ein.
Ja, demnächst mache ich hier irgendwie LTE-Fallback und dann...
Jetzt geht die Griechenzeit los, es ist eh Frühling, ne? Wenn wir gerade von LTE, Telekom und DSL reden...
Moment, wir sind jetzt bei Rückblick auf 10 Jahre im Freak Show.
Aber das ist doch jetzt Ende. Wir drattest es voll und es ist schon beendet.
Als nächstes wollten wir die Fragen an die Freak Show machen. Du willst einen kleinen Einwurf.
Schreibst du ja auf, schreib ins Workflow.
Ja, okay, das war doch ein schöner Rückblick. Vielleicht kann man ja mal auf... Wir hatten ja letztes Mal gefragt, ob jemand Fragen hat. Und Leute hatten Fragen. Und die sind hier in dem Chat-Kanal aufgeschlagen. Mit dem Kopf. Mit dem was? Ich hab mich ja nicht vorbereitet. Von daher lese ich die jetzt auch eigentlich das erste Mal. Wir können ja mal kurz gucken hier. Kleine subjektive Historie haben wir gemacht. Ja.
Genau.
Live-Schalte zu, Macs haben wir nicht.
Die interne Pre-Show. Ja, wir essen Pizza, erzählen uns schlimme Dinge.
Haben wir ja auch schon drüber geredet.
Aber wir schreiben es nicht ins Pad. Wir benutzen ein School namens Workflow.
Aus guten Gründen ist die intern.
Aus guten Gründen ist die intern. Wenn ich so zurück erinnere, hier sind schon ganz heiße Sachen diskutiert worden.
Da redet man nicht drüber.
Falls unangemessen.
Wer hat das geile Logo entworfen, haben wir auch schon gesagt. Wieso gibt es keine Merchandise-Artikel? Ein T-Shirt wäre doch mal nett. Ja.
Macht doch welche.
Nee.
Ist schon lange hier auf der Liste. Viele andere Dinge.
Das Thema hat der Tim schon durch.
Also ich weiß, welchen Aufwand das so macht. Andererseits habe ich auch keinen Bock, jetzt irgendwie nur so düsselige Spreadshirt-Geschichten in so minderwertiger Qualität in den Folgen zu schmeißen.
Wir könnten was bei QWERTY einwerfen und dann allen sagen, sie sollen es hochvoten. Sagt der QWERTY nichts? Das ist auch so ein T-Shirt-Ding. Die machen aber die T-Shirts richtig und du kannst halt Designs vorschlagen. Die werden dann quasi in so eine Art Public Voting gegeben.
Was heißt T-Shirts richtig?
Ja, ordentliche T-Shirts.
Also ordentlicher Druck. Siebdruck, nicht irgendwie einfach nur so eine Pelle draufkleben. Und wie gesagt, du kannst halt dort Designs einreichen und dann werden die quasi irgendwie gevotet und vielleicht kommt man damit durch.
Willst du mal so beantworten? Ich denke, wir werden da irgendwie noch was im Angebot haben. Kommt Zeit.
Bis zur 20-Jährigen sind es ja noch zehn Jahre.
Ich hab das ja schon mal gemacht.
Schon haben wir ein Sendungstitel für heute. Das ist auch die Frage, woher unsere Sendungstitel kommen.
So, dann, das ist hier keine, okay, das ist...
Das machen wir nicht in dieser Sendung.
Das kann man vielleicht später machen, wenn wir zum Technik kommen. Jetzt machen wir erstmal die ganzen Metakramen hier. Was sollte man als Neuling im CCC mitbringen und in welchen Bereichen habt ihr angefangen, euch zu engagieren und wieso?
Am besten kein Windows.
Vor allem Laptop, damit dem nicht langweilig ist, weil die Leute reden dann nicht mit einem. Am Anfang dauert immer eine Weile.
Man wird nur doof angeguckt.
Man muss jetzt erstmal...
Eine Frage, ob ich immer noch in Bitcoins gehuckt wäre.
Moment, ich wollte da auch noch was zu sagen.
Die ist eigentlich da drüber gewesen.
Die Frage ist ja so ein bisschen unspezifisch. Was heißt denn das Neuling im CCC? Ist damit jetzt irgendwie ein lokaler Club gemeint? Oder ist das hier so eine Frage mit ich bin jetzt in CCC e.V. Mitglied geworden. Was muss ich jetzt tun? Es gibt ja da verschiedene Ebenen.
Also wenn er physikalisches Mitbringen meint, meint er wohl so einen lokalen Club. Würde ich mal denken. Oder wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen, dann würde ich sagen, er soll einen Laptop mitbringen und ein bisschen Geduld und ein paar Mal öfter kommen, bis er so drin ist.
Ich würde das jetzt mitbringen, was man unter dem Arm trägt. Ich würde interpretieren, das eher als Mitbringen, was sollte man sozusagen im Kopf tragen.
Hab ich ja gerade gesagt, wenn er das Physikalische meint, dann wäre das die Antwort. Wenn er das andere meint, wir können das ja beides beantworten, weil wir wissen ja nicht, was er meint. Dann kann man einfach beides beantworten. Und das eine wäre jetzt beantwortet, das andere kannst du jetzt übernehmen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das gut beantworten soll. Also ich finde erstmal, man sollte vor allem sich selbst mitbringen. Also das ist ja eigentlich das Wichtigste, dass man...
Ja, und vor allen Dingen keine vorgefertigten Meinungen. Gewisse Offenheit mitbringen.
Ja, naja, also...
Keine Ahnung, ich kann eigentlich gar nicht mitreden. Ich bin ja kein Mitglied.
Ja, ich würde jetzt auch gar nicht so sagen, dass man irgendwelchen Anforderungen genügen muss oder so. Also ich fand eigentlich immer die Leute am interessantesten, die vor allem sie selbst waren. Und alle Leute, die irgendwie irgendwas meinen, erfüllen zu müssen oder irgendeinem Bild entsprechen zu wollen.
Oder dieses Showing-off, oder wie nennt man das?
Ja, und dann auch die Angeber ganz furchtbar. Also das ist irgendwie alles albern. Und welchen Bereichen habt ihr angefangen euch zu engagieren? Ja eben, also in meinem Club gibt es ja auch viele Leute, die sich jetzt nicht unbedingt für was engagieren.
Oder außerhalb des Clubs für irgendwas engagieren, was jetzt nichts direkt mit dem Club zu tun hat.
Ja, es gibt natürlich Leute, die in den Club kommen, um sich in etwas zu engagieren. Es gibt auch Leute, die extra nicht in den Club gehen, um sich für irgendwas zu engagieren, weil sie nicht unbedingt den Eindruck haben, dass das der beste Ort dafür ist. Das ist ja auch alles okay. An dem Tag, als mir so offenbart wurde, dass ich offensichtlich ja wohl irgendwie zum Club gehören würde, was mir zu dem Zeitpunkt selber noch nicht klar war, habe ich mich einfach auf das gestürzt, was mich selbst am meisten interessiert hat. Weil ich denke, dass man in dem Bereich, was einen selbst am meisten interessiert, einfach auch am meisten beitragen kann. Ganz einfach.
Und doch am besten, das war, weil man ja eigene Interessen hat.
Genau, und so kann man das eigentlich nur beantworten.
So, nächste Frage. Was war das hier?
Genau, ist Dennis eigentlich noch hooked bezüglich Bitcoins? Oder ist ihm das zu viel geworden? Zu viel?
Sind es dir zu viel Bitcoins geworden?
Diese Last.
Wenn du noch zu viel hast, Dennis, ich gebe dir gerne etwas ab von der Last.
Also ich finde Bitcoin weiterhin interessant, auch wenn es halt, von mir aus Skalierungsprobleme hat, Stromverbrauchsprobleme, wie auch immer. Aber die Entwicklung, die jetzt da so stattfindet, in Richtung mehr Privacy, dass man nicht so richtig sehen kann, wer von wo nach wo schiebt und so Sachen, finde ich, und die da kommen werden demnächst, finde ich schon interessant. Und ich finde das weiterhin, auch wenn es in der Zukunft nicht Bitcoin ist, sondern irgendeine andere Währung, aber Kryptowährung an sich, wo halt nicht irgendwie der Staat Geld nachdrucken kann oder wer auch immer, oder einem das abspenst, wie sagt man, einem die wegnehmen kann, sondern wo sozusagen ich per Passwort. In meinem Kopf mein Schatz forten kann, das finde ich schon irgendwie gut. Und wenn wir den unter uns hin und her tauschen können, ohne dass ein Dritter was dagegen tun kann, dann finde ich das irgendwie eine gute Sache.
Ich glaube, wir müssen dann nochmal einen kleinen Bitcoinex-Kurs machen, weil ich da nochmal eine Frage an Dennis habe.
Ich habe da ja, muss ja sagen, das ist eigentlich auch genau der Aspekt, der mich auch so ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, ein bisschen beunruhigt.
Welcher von denen?
Der Letzte. Der Staat kann mir nichts wegnehmen. Weil erstmal ist es ja nicht unbedingt so, dass einem der Staat, dass der Staat jetzt einem besonders viel Geld wegnehmen würde.
Nee, gerade zurzeit nicht, aber wenn da so eine Krise kommt, ist das wie in Griechenland. Zum Beispiel, wie war das? Welche Konten, alle Konten, die mehr als 20.000 Euro hatten, wurden...
Ja, in Griechenland.
Meinst du, die haben das ein Jahr vorher oder zwei Jahre vorher gewusst? Ich bin jetzt kein Verschwörungstheoretiker und ich bin nicht der Meinung, dass das jetzt demnächst jede Minute kommen könnte und so weiter. Aber eigentlich vom Gefühl zu wissen, egal ob der Euro gerade zusammenbrechen könnte oder was auch immer passiert, meine Bitcoins sind meine. Die können auf anderen Gründen zusammenbrechen. Das ist schon richtig.
Die haben ja aber keinen inherenten Wert.
Der Euro auch nicht.
Doch, der Euro hat einen inherenten Wert, weil er wird repräsentiert von der Wirtschaftskraft des Geltungs- und Ausgabelandes.
Der Wert des Euros ist, dass das Finanzamt sein Geld darin bezahlt hat. Die wollen halt in Euro bezahlt werden. Das ist der Wert des Euros.
Ja, und ich meine, mein Gott, in Bitcoin, niemand zahlt Dinge in Bitcoin, außer so ein paar Volldunis, die wahrscheinlich irgendwie alle anderen Konten schon längst gekündigt bekommen haben. So, aber niemand benutzt das als Zahlungsmittel. Davon muss man sich mal trennen. Bitcoin ist kein Zahlungsmittel. Und die allermeisten...
Vorher in Euro getauscht und dann wird bezahlt.
Nein, kein allgemeines Zahlungsmittel.
Aber wie willst du, bei den Transaktionskosten kannst du ein Kino-Ticket kaufen, wenn du mit 50 Euro Transaktionskosten hast.
Ja, das sind zum Beispiel Informationen, die sind schon wieder drei Monate alt, die sind inzwischen wieder verschwunden, diese Transaktionsgebühren. Die sind einfach nicht mehr da. Es hat sich wieder beruhigt. Die Blöcke sind nicht mehr voll, Transaktionen sind wieder ultra billig, alles wieder im grünen Bereich. Man weiß nicht, wer... Die Blöcke waren voll, weil da sehr viele Transaktionen waren. Im Dezember war halt nur mal der Hype, weil alle Bitcoins geschoben haben wie doof. Dann war der Block voll und die Gebühren gestiegen. Eine andere Idee oder Vermutung ist auch, und ich würde da schon auch ein bisschen dazu tendieren, dass es sogenannte Spammer gab, die das künstlich voll gemacht haben, weil dadurch die Gebühren steigen. Denen sagt man, die hätten ja was davon, wenn die Gebühren hoch sind und dass die das eventuell waren, dass die künstlich die Blöcke gefüllt haben. Das hat im Februar mehr oder weniger plötzlich aufgehört. Also man kann sich die Grafen oder die Statistiken angucken, wie das so aussieht. Da gibt es, hat ich ja auch schon mal gepostet, so eine schicke Seite, wenn man bei Google oder bei einer Suchmaschine nach Mempool und Bitcoin eintippt. Da gibt es dann eine Seite, die heißt, jetzt kommt die natürlich bei mir direkt, jochenhönicke.de. Die hatten wir schon mal, da sieht man schöne Grafiken. Und da kann man sehen, dass die Blöcke, dass die nicht mehr voll sind und dass die im Dezember und Mitte letzten Jahres mal sehr, sehr voll waren. Und das ist aber alles Geschichte, das ist seit Anfang Februar ist das vorbei. Zoom noch mal ein bisschen raus da so. Das ist einfach nicht mehr. Genau, so sah das so Dezember aus. Da waren da irgendwie 250.000 Transaktionen in dem sogenannten Mempool. Also die Transaktionen, die noch gerne in so einen Block rein wollten, aber warten mussten, weil voll war. Und die Zahl ist inzwischen, wenn man jetzt mir auf hier den 2-Stunden-Durchschnitt geht, jetzt sind irgendwie 3-4.000 Transaktionen, die da warten und die dann auch immer relativ schnell abgearbeitet werden. Also und die Gebühren sind fast weg.
Das erklärt, warum neulich auch mal wieder eine Bitcoinspende durchkam.
Vielleicht. Das hat mich schon richtig überrascht.
Oh, es benutzt mal wieder jemand. Bitcoin.
Ich hab lang nicht geguckt, aber kann natürlich sein.
Okay, gut, aber trotz alledem, das Problem bleibt, Bitcoin ist derzeit halt, also ich sehe es derzeit etwas subjektive Sicht der Dinge. Für mich ist es so ein bisschen das Gold der Verheißung Kryptowährung an sich. Man hält zu Bitcoin, weil der Wert in Bitcoin ist kein realer, wirtschaftsgebundener Wert. Das ist nicht, dass du davon irgendeinen wirtschaftlichen Vorteil hast, dass du Bitcoin hast. Es ist der Glaube an Kryptowährung an sich. Und das kollektive Cryptocurrency-Community würde kollektiv Bitcoin jetzt nicht fallen lassen. Durch Massenverkäufer etc. Weil es halt in gewisser Hinsicht auch den Wert dieser ganzen Bewegung widerspiegelt.
Die richtigen Bitcoiner haben es halt eben nicht, um zu zocken, weil das sind die Leute, die im Dezember alle gekommen sind. Und die haben auch alle entweder gut Gewinn gemacht oder aber auch zu spät eingestiegen und haben jetzt geblutet, weil es ja wieder abgesackt ist ein bisschen. Sondern die richtigen Bitcoiner, so wie der Besitzer von Room77, die sind halt überzeugt von den Features und von den Eigenschaften von Bitcoin oder auch teilweise von anderen Kryptowährungen, also Monero, die dann halt das mit dem Privacy ein bisschen noch...
Genau.
Und was ich vorhin sage, was mich stört, oder wo ich meine Bedenken habe, meine generellen Bedenken habe, ist, dass du eben, wenn du dir auch gerade so Bitcoin-Konferenzen und so was, Cryptocurrency-Konferenzen anschaut, was da so für Vögel irgendwie auf der Bühne stehen.
Ja, ist das fürchterlich.
Also abgesehen, dass du halt so die üblichen Anteil Labertaschen und so weiter hast, du hast halt aber auch wirklich so gnadenlose, so libertäre, staatsfeindliche, ja, also was einem in den USA schon so richtig einen kalten Schaubahnrücken jagen lässt teilweise. Und es gibt da halt auch so eine globale Bewegung, die so, ja, wir koppeln uns jetzt hier irgendwie aus allen Systemen ab. Und wir wollen damit nichts zu tun haben.
Ja, aber eigentlich, seitdem der Hype war, so im Dezember, sind die ja so ein bisschen in den Hintergrund geraten. Da sind eher so die Finanzzocker gekommen. Die sind jetzt auch nicht besser, aber es ist noch mal wieder eine andere Liga. Aber inzwischen, finde ich, jetzt wo der Kurs wieder so runtergeht, ist das auch alles wieder ausgedünnt. Und die Meetings dort im Room Service Heaven sind auch wieder viel entspannter.
Ja gut, aber das ändert ja nichts, auch an diesem politischen Gehalt, den das ganz hat. Weil diese Aussage mit irgendwie der, also dieses, der Staat hat da nichts, kann mir nichts wegnehmen, heißt ja so viel auch, ich muss mich einer Gesellschaft nicht beteiligen.
So würde ich das nicht sehen.
Naja, aber es ist ein bisschen bei vielen Leuten, die so denken.
Ich meine nicht, ob jemand Steuern betrügt oder nicht, hat da mit Bitcoins erstmal nichts zu tun. Was ich meine ist, dass die, ne, wenn man keine Steuern zahlen will, dann kann man das mit Bitcoins nicht machen, man kann es aber auch mit Euros nicht machen. Ich finde, das ist mir egal, ob er mit Bitcoins oder mit Euro keine Steuern bezahlen will. Was aber bei Bitcoin, was ich schon gut finde, ist, dass halt die halt, die, die können keine Bitcoins nachdrucken, sowie Euros nachgedruckt werden zum Beispiel. Wenn zum Beispiel die Bankenkrise kommt, ja, und die brauchen viel Geld für die Bankenkrise, dann drucken die halt nach, was eigentlich aber insgesamt eine größere Inflation darstellt und so weiter. Das mag alles sein, dass das vielleicht, uns geht es jetzt ja auch wirklich nicht schlecht, dass wir sagen können, ja, das hältst du jetzt in deinem Leben auch noch aus, das ist alles nicht so schlimm. Das ist halt vielleicht auch mehr ein Gefühl, aber ich bin da, das weiß einfach meine Bitcoins, sind genau so meine Bitcoins. Mag sein, dass sich der Wert des Bitcoins an sich ändert, aber ich hab diese Menge und ich kann die von hier nach da zu dir schieben und du wieder zurück und da kann halt niemand was dagegen tun. Das ist eher so das Ding, das ist so ein bisschen mehr Kontrolle über meinen...
Ich seh dich schon in der verglühten Wüste nach dem Atomschlag, aber ich hab Bitcoins. Und es ist auch voll billig, die zu mineen, weil es gibt ja kaum noch funktionierter Computer.
Die Last Week Tonight Sendung von John Oliver zum Thema kann ich jedem ans Herz legen. Sehr schön, besonders diesen einen Vogel, den er da irgendwie zitiert, also als Video zeigt, der da so auf der Bühne völlig ausrastet, ist großartig.
Ich hab da irgendwas gehört von dem Ding, aber ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, über wen er da ausrastet, aber wahrscheinlich ist es...
Das war so ein echter Vogel, also der... Der war super. Aber ich finde, John Oliver kann man ja jede Sendung gucken.
Gab es den zu sehen, den Typen, über den er da ausrastet?
Das ist ja in diesem YouTube-Clip komplett drin. Er spielt ja dieses Video von dem Typen, wie der da auf der...
Kannst du mal kurz nur das Bild sein? Ich brauch nur die Optik von den Menschen, damit ich kurz sehe, wer das ist.
Was ist das, ein langer Beitrag?
Oder Roddy kann das ja vielleicht hier so neben mir machen.
Das machen wir dann wahrscheinlich eher zum Ende hin, oder?
Ist ja auch egal.
Vermutlich, das ist immer... Ah ja, das ist wahrscheinlich diesen Vogel hier, ne? Bild.
Äh, war das der? Kann sein, er hatte mehrere Vögel. Und der eine, der... Warte mal, noch mal ein Stück zurück, wo mehr auf der Bühne standen.
Der ist ja egal.
Den Vogel hier vielleicht.
Frage ist beantwortet, würde ich sagen.
Aber wenn wir kurz... Ihr habt ja auch ein bisschen ausgeschweift das ganze Thema und hier kam das halt auch grad im Chat hoch. Ähm, es gab ja jetzt noch mal diese Geschichte, dass halt Kinderpornografie in der Blockchain gespeichert wurde. Was ich nicht an der Stelle verstehe, ist, warum an einer Währung die Transaktion von Geld eigentlich scheinbar nur sein soll, die Möglichkeit gibt, jeden Bullshit reinzuspeichern. Das ist der Punkt, den ich irgendwie nicht ganz verstehe, warum man das von vornherein erlaubt.
Na, es gibt eigentlich die Überweisung innerhalb von der Blockchain sind ja so kleine Skripte, mit denen halt Münzen oder Coins oder Bitcoins, wie auch immer, von A nach B geschoben werden. Aber es gibt auch einen so einen Art Datentyp, könnte man mal sagen. Da kannst du halt wirklich Text oder Hexwerte speichern. Metadaten. Metadaten. Und das haben die absichtlich irgendwann mal sich entschieden, dass sie das machen wollen, dass man halt da auch so eine Art Kommentare an seine Transaktion ran kleben kann. Also da kann ich sozusagen, wenn ich dir was überweise, noch zusätzlich mit rein kleben, was mich dann auch extra Geld kostet, weil bezahlt werden die Gebühren ja nach Größe der Transaktion. Das heißt, es kostet mich dann extra, wenn ich das tue. Da habe ich dann irgendwie eine gewisse Größe, keine Ahnung, ob das festgelegt ist, wie viel das ist, aber sagen wir mal, was ich schon gesehen habe, sind so 100, 200 Bites an Hexwerten, die ich dann an die Transaktion klebe, dass ich weiß, ich habe dir das für Folgendes überwiesen, zum Beispiel. Deswegen haben sie das erlaubt. Und Leute haben das halt missbraucht, um da halt viele Transaktionen irgendwie reinzukleben, wo diese 100 oder 200, 300 Bites, wie viel auch immer, das ist insgesamt alles zusammenhalten, Kinderpornos, Zeugs oder Links oder irgendwie so. Aber du brauchst schon auch spezielle Tools, um das da rauszuholen. Deswegen ist jetzt noch keiner losgegangen und hat gesagt, wenn du die Blockchain auf deinem Rechner hast, hast du Kinderpornos auf deinem Rechner.
Dass man Text abspeichern kann, um dem Ganzen einen Namen zu geben, das ist ja irgendwie was, das irgendwie sinnvoll ist. Aber ja, dann restriktiere ich das aber auf Text.
Ja, aber ist ja Text. Text sind mal Daten und dann kannst du ja alles einpacken.
Es gibt schon Leute, die haben Informationen in der Blockchain hinterlegt, indem sie halt die Transaktion, also die Werte, also die Zahl, die man überweist, ist ja halt 0,0000, Tralala, Satoshi und so weiter. Und die haben das als Bitmuster genommen und so viele Überweisungen gemacht, dass wenn du das Bitmuster sozusagen ausgezählt hast, dann war das auch Hexwerte, Text, oder dann kam da wieder was raus. Man muss halt aber das richtige Tool haben, was halt dann auch alles genauso wieder zusammenklebt. Das sind ja so Spielereien, was die Leute halt so machen.
Der Blockchain wird jetzt auch nicht gesurft.
Aber ich frage mich quasi, was da die Motivation dahinter ist, quasi alles zu erlauben. Ich hätte zum Beispiel nicht unbedingt gedacht, dass du das so offen halten kannst, dass du alles da rein bauen kannst.
Die Blockchain ist ja zunächst einmal eine generische Technologie, die halt in dem Fall für Cryptocurrencies benutzt wird, aber ja im Prinzip auch alle anderen Dinge beweist.
Ja, ja, schon. Aber ich meine, wenn ich weiß, dass ich ein generisches System für nur als Currency, nur als Bezahlsystem nehme, könnte man ja auch sagen, derjenige, der das erfunden hat, sagt einfach, theoretisch geht das mit dem allen, aber ich mach mir davon eine Spezialisierung, die etwas restriktiert zum Beispiel.
Der hat das ja auch so gemacht, dieses OP-Return heißt das, dieses Extra-Feld kam ja auch erst ein bisschen später und da haben sie sich halt überlegt, dass sie das haben wollen, weil sie halt Metadaten in einer Transaktion zulassen wollten.
Okay.
Aber ob das jetzt so schlau war oder nicht, weiß ich nicht.
Es ist nur die Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe, weil ich wusste jetzt auch nicht, dass das zum Beispiel nur Text sein kann. Das hört sich jetzt halt immer so an, als würde man beliebig alles reinschmeißen können.
Es ist ja beliebig alles eigentlich, nur dass es halt sind Bits, genau.
Race 64, there you go.
Ja, also das natürlich hat so eine Datenstruktur, die so unlöschbar ist. Nochmal ganz andere Implikationen. Und das sind die Dinge, die wir halt jetzt im Rahmen von Bitcoin lernen.
So, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich da draußen geworden? Gehen da jetzt ein paar Leute rum und kassieren Leute ein, die Blockchain auf dem Rechner haben. Also eine Kopie wegen Child Porns. Child Porn, Child Porn. Garantiert mindestens in Deutschland irgendein dummer Staatsanwalt.
Ja, vielleicht war das ja die Intention.
Ja, klar, sicher.
Wir verbieten jetzt mal jede Blockchain, weil da Sachen, so Hakenkreuze in Ethereum, oh, alle festnehmen.
Ja, hat nicht funktioniert anscheinend bisher. Also die Tool, das rauszuholen, sind halt zu speziell. Also dann wird er das Tool verboten.
Natürlich hat jeder Typ, der irgendwie Child Pwn auf seinem Rechner nicht als normale JPEG vorliegen in offenen Beiden.
Aber da sind ja auch keine JPEGs in dieser Blockchain, sondern Links auf Webseiten. Dann macht er die Webseite zu und dann ist es eben.
Was haltet ihr von Swift? Also wer die Sendung schon länger hört, sollte die Frage eigentlich stellen müssen. Soll ich trotzdem irgendwas dazu sagen?
Ich glaube, es ist eine Sprache für Theoretiker im Praktischen.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es sich um die Sprache handelt und nicht um den Object Store, der diese S3, diese Open Source Variante von Amazon S3, weil dazu kann ich nichts sagen.
Die heißt Swift.
Die heißt auch Swift, ja. Die Sprache, naja gut, also ich bin da seit Anfang an dabei, finde, dass Swift sehr, sehr viele Sachen richtig macht. Da fehlen immer noch Sachen, die das Swift-Team weiß um die Lücken in dieser Sprache. Aber ich würde es momentan jeder anderen Sprache vorziehen.
Ich glaube, in letzter Zeit höre ich auch, oder was heißt hören, lese ich Tweets von unserem bekannten Monkeydome hier. Der ja da auch bearbeitet, ist ja bekannt, genau, schreibt er auch. Und da kommen auch eine Menge nicht so positive Tweets manchmal. Also das halt in Swift. Deswegen habe ich das Gefühl, dass es eher so eine Sprache ist, von Theoretikern, die diese perfekte, typisierte Sprache haben wollen und so weiter, wo alles irgendwie sauber und clean ist. Aber das ist halt auch nicht mehr so schön dann.
Es gibt immer wieder Leute, die natürlich extrem Beispiele von Code posten, nur um dann zu sagen, das ist hässlich. Aber ich meine, was ist denn die Alternative? Ruby, Python, JavaScript?
Na die Frage ist doch eher, wofür du es benutzt. Und wenn es halt Swift ist, weil du iOS entwickelst, natürlich benutzt du dann Swift, weil es wird irgendwie für dieses Gerät entwickelt wahrscheinlich. Und ich finde, da ist halt eher so der Punkt, der mich manchmal so stutzig macht, warum man unbedingt mit JavaScript auch auf dem iPhone entwickeln will, wo du vielleicht aber Performance-Einbuße hast oder so eine Sache. Also ich finde halt, Programmiersprachen haben ja eh meistens so genau ihren Anwendungsfall, für den man ihn nutzen soll und danach möglicherweise eher die Finger davon lassen sollte.
Na ja gut, es gibt ja diese Swift auf dem Server-Initiative, wo Apple hat jetzt diese, wie heißt das, Netty von Java, so eine asynchrone Netzwerkbibliothek nach Swift portiert, damit man tatsächlich auch Server-Anwendungen schreiben kann, die sehr viele Connections halten kann und mit sehr vielen Clients gleichzeitig reden kann und so weiter. Also da passiert relativ viel. Swift 4 ist halt nicht mehr da, wo Swift 1 mal irgendwie angefangen hat zu humpeln. Also keine Ahnung. Für mich hat sich das halt super entwickelt. Wenn du dir anguckst, die Leute, die Java machen, also Java gibt es halt jetzt auch schon seit 25 Jahren. Und das merkst du Java halt auch an. Und deswegen gibt es halt jetzt Kotlin, was quasi so der Nachfolger von Java ist, der halt, wenn du dir Kotlin anguckst, dann musst du dreimal hingucken, um zu sehen, dass es nicht Swift ist, sondern Kotlin. Weil die Sprache extrem viele gleiche Konzepte hat. Und teilweise auch sehr gleiche Syntax.
Darauf könnte dann auch nur Google kommen, ne?
Nein, Google hat die Sprache nicht so genannt, sondern die Sprache, JetBrains haben diese Sprache so genannt. Kotlin, ja, das sind Russen, meine Güte. Nein, sind Russen. Nee, nee, nee, sind Russen. Die machen ja dieses IntelliJ. Du, dass die Sprache so heißt, meine Güte. Also ich meine, ähm. Nächstes Thema, oder was soll das jetzt heißen?
Kotlin, so heißt eine Insel.
Du, äh, keine Ahnung, wie sie auf diesen Namen gekommen sind oder ob sie sich bei dem Namen überhaupt was gedacht haben.
Das ist eine russische Insel.
Na dann, ist es eine schöne Insel? Wo ist die denn?
Keine Ahnung, die ist irgendwo im finnischen Meer busen.
Du hast angefangen. Ja, was hat die... Also ich halte sehr viel von Swift, auch wenn Swift noch ein paar Kilometer zu gehen hat. Ansonsten kann es ja jeder Scheiße finden. Aber gerade als Nachfolger zu Objective-C ist es irgendwie eine Diskussion, die eigentlich nicht mehr großgeführt wird. Meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, dass es das übernehmen wird, ist schon irgendwie klar. Man hat dann mehr Freiheiten, Objective-C. Die haben natürlich auch nachteilige Freiheiten, was ich weiß.
Also du hast halt entweder eine starke Typisierung oder du hast sie nicht. Oder du hast halt überhaupt gar kein Typ-System wie in Erlang. Dann hast du halt nur typ-lose Objekte. Das kannst du auch machen. Nee, aber Swift geht halt die Richtung starke Typisierung. Und Sinn der Sache ist ja, dass der Compiler dir hilft. Deswegen musst du in manchen Grenzsituationen halt durch ein paar Ringe springen, damit es ordentlich wird. Aber dafür hast du in der Regel den Vorteil, dass wenn der Compiler es erstmal schluckt, dann hast du halt ganze Klassen von Fehlern nicht, die du bei einer schwach typisierten Sprache hast. Also so Laufzeitverhalten ist halt relativ überschaubar, weil die Sprache nicht zur Laufzeit Objekte irgendwie uminterpretiert. Und das ist die Philosophie hinter Swift. Wenn man keine stark typisierte Sprache mag, dann ist es nichts für einen. Aber dann wird man auch mit Kotlin nicht wirklich.
Na ich mag stark typisieren schon, habe ich in Objective-C auch immer gemacht, weil man sich seinen, seinen Typ mal selber schön festnagelt, weil der Compiler dann halt genau sagen kann, wenn man irgendwie vom Weg abgekommen ist, wo man eigentlich nicht abkommen wollte. Aber so ganz fest genagelt, also ich hätte schon gerne auch die Freiheiten, wenn ich sie halt mal haben will, wenn ich gerade mal nur schnell da prototypen will und so ein bisschen, ein bisschen rum experimentiere, dann brauch ich dieses festgenageln nicht, dann will ich alles locker easy und und fuschen können. Weißt, ich will fuschen können, genau. Ab und zu will man fuschen können.
Das einzige, wo diese starke Typisierung bei Swift einem wirklich einen Strich durch die Rechnung macht, ist beim Unit-Testing, wenn du Mock-Objekte bauen willst, weil du hast halt keine Möglichkeit zur Laufzeit zu sagen, ich leite jetzt diese Klasse ab. Weil dein Framework halt einfach sagt, hier, mach mir von dem Objekt ein Mock-Objekt und fertig. Das geht halt nicht, weil das ist halt alles fertig zusammenkompiliert. Angeblich ist das etwas, was irgendwo auf der Roadmap ist, dass sie halt auch dynamische Typisierung machen. Aber das ist noch weiter draußen, was man so liest. Keine Ahnung. Meiner Meinung nach sind die ganzen Lebenläufigkeitsthemen, die bei Swift immer noch fehlen, aber deutlich wichtiger. Als jetzt eine dynamische Typisierung zur Laufzeit. Aber das ist noch meine Meinung, vielleicht. Nee, also gerade wenn man halt einmal Swift gemacht hat, dann gehen einem diese ganzen unnötigen Klammern und Semikolons und so weiter anderer Sprachen so dermaßen auf den Keks. Und diese ganzen Typen, die eigentlich der Compiler halt auch entfernen kann, was soll das? Also gerade Semikolons ist so das Unnützeste der Welt.
Ich finde ja gerade bei, weil ich sehr sehr viel Python in letzter Zeit mache, ist es so irgendwie nett, auch gar keine Klammern mehr so zu haben, diese geschweiften Klammern, sondern über einen Rücken zu gehen, das finde ich gerade ganz schlimm. Ja, das ist gefährlich, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber das, das finde ich halt an Python so schlimm. Ich möchte hinschreiben, was ich meine, und dann habe ich ein Tool, das mir meinen Code formatiert. Und nicht, ich will meinen Code formatieren, damit das Tool weiß, was ich meine. Das ist einfach, das ist, nee, das geht nicht.
Die Einrückung ist Teil des Subtaks sozusagen, das geht gar nicht. Find ich. Also ich finde Python gar nicht so schlecht, das macht Spaß.
Ich schreib das hin, drück einmal auf die Taste, dann wird der Code formatiert.
Genau, das kannst du aber bei Python ja machen.
Ja, aber schmeißt doch mal irgendwo oder füg eine If-Ebene ein oder nimm ein Else irgendwo raus. Das ist, also Python...
Oder du drückst, du änderst deinen Editor und der rückt ja aus dem Sehen Taps an Such Spaces ein. Oder du wechselst da gerade oder irgendwer anders hat das gemacht. Dann ist gleich, dann ist alles im Arsch und du siehst es noch nicht mal. Also dann hast du so ein Go-To-Fail wie bei Apple und du kannst es nicht mal sehen, weil du müsstest dann dir die Taps oder Spaces darstellen lassen.
Am geilsten, am geilsten finde ich bei Python, du schreibst, wenn du mehr als einen File benutzt, dann geht der Python-Interpreter über das neue File, das er noch nicht kennt, das erste Mal dann rüber, wenn du eine Funktion aus diesem neuen File aufrufst. Und wenn dann die Syntax nicht stimmt, bekommst du von deinem Funktionsaufruf in dieses File eine Exception, dass er das File nicht parsen konnte. Super geil, oder? Zur Laufzeit, genau. Du denkst so, Leute, was macht ihr da? Das ist doch nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Gut, dabei ist halt auch eine Sprache für andere Anwendungen.
Da kannst du schön prototypen und rumrotzen.
Ja, eben nicht.
Dir geht ja die ganze Zeit dieses Eingerücke auf den Sack.
Na gut, aber das löst dir halt deinen Editor. Dafür hab ich halt irgendwie einen Package bei Sublime drin, der mir das dann ordentlich formatiert.
Also ich muss sagen, ich hab Anfang 2000, irgendwann 2001, angefangen mit Objective-C, hatte keine Ahnung von nix. Und die Sprache, die war einfach... Ich bin da so schnell reingefallen und die hat gleich von Anfang an irgendwie Spaß gemacht. Das fand ich schon cool. Als ich mal irgendwas dachte, jetzt machst du mal so ein bisschen Swift, kann ja nicht so schwer sein, hab's ja mit Objective-C auch geschafft. Und die hat nicht sofort Spaß gemacht. Die hat mir gleich gesagt, hier musst du aber so machen und da musst du aber so machen. Und das war irgendwie, weiß ich nicht. Bei Objective-C war es schicker.
Na ja, gut, da war ich, glaube ich, zu lange in dem Teil der Tränen Objective-C drin. Klar, wenn du das jahrelang gemacht hast, hast du große Apps geschrieben und dann gibt es halt so Sachen, die du da machen kannst, das findest du halt nicht, weil erst zur Laufzeit passieren da Dinge, die du einfach nicht erwartest. So was wie Key-Value-Observing. Das ist so ein Trick bei Objective-C. Du kannst quasi der Runtime sagen, ach übrigens, dieses Objekt, wenn da jemand diese Funktion auf dem Objekt aufruft, dann sag mir mal Bescheid, da möchte ich auch noch was machen. Das findest du im Code nicht. Das ist komplett nicht offensichtlich.
Dieses Binding auch mit dem Code und so, hab ich auch nie benutzt, fand das immer scary.
Zur Laufzeit passiert irgendwas und du hast keine Ahnung, wo es herkommt. Du findest es nicht. Das hat mich so wahnsinnig gemacht.
Das war aber auch so ein Interface-Bilder-Ding mit diesen Bindings, oder meinst du das?
Ja, es gibt auch Leute, die haben das per Hand gemacht.
Das ist ja noch schlimmer. Nee, das mochte ich irgendwie nicht, weil das war nicht sichtbar. Ich mag nicht Sachen, die nicht sichtbar sind. So wie man die Tabs und Spaces bei der Eindrückung von Python nicht sehen kann, das ist, weiß ich nicht, das fällt mir nicht.
Deswegen hab ich aber auch in der Tat in meinem Editor alles Besonderzeichnis einanzeigen.
Das sieht immer so hässlich aus auf dem Schirm. Ich brauch so eine gewisse Ästhetik in meinem Code.
Ja, ist aber richtig.
Ich wurde mal gelobt für die Optik von meinem Code. Da war ich sehr stolz, weil der Programmierer war eigentlich auch ein ganz guter.
Also...
Ich würde sagen, die Frage ist ausreichend beantwortet worden.
Ja, wie immer, aber es wird ausreichend. Wir geben uns Mühe. Man sieht, das kommt ja von innen.
Wenn es nicht reicht, könnt ihr mich nochmal persönlich ansprechen.
Nochmal 10 Jahre Freak Show, mal einen Blick in die Zukunft. Was glaubt ihr, sind in 10 Jahren die bestimmten Themen für die Freak Show, Oveya?
Na, welche Segen wir benutzen für die Bearbeitung unseres Holzes.
Genau, weil wir doch alle auf Garten machen.
Alle, was mit Holz und kleinen Tieren tun, bis dahin. In 10 Jahren.
10 Jahre.
In 10 Jahren? Das ist echt schwer zu sagen. Also ich meine...
Die Frage ist, was gibt es in 10 Jahren noch für Geräte, über die man dann reden wird? Ich glaube, der Desktop ist dann wahrscheinlich wirklich verschwunden. Größtenteils.
Mal anders gesagt, zum Anfang der Freak Show oder Mobile-Macs, hättet ihr euch, war ja noch nicht dabei, euch vorstellen können, über die Themen zu reden, über die wir jetzt reden?
Ja, im Großen und Ganzen hat sich ja nichts geändert. Wenn man mal ehrlich ist, sind es weiter Telefone, Laptops, Programme, die uns interessieren. Es ist jetzt Swifter zugekommen, aber so richtig.
Twitter, Bitcoin.
Ja, Kryptocurrency ist ja gut, aber ich finde...
Es gibt schon ein paar Sachen, die sind heute da. Die waren damals nicht da. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob wir die so in dem Maße gesehen haben. Also Trends.
Elektroautos.
Na, ich sag mal Cloud.
Nicht in diesem Hype-Status, wie sie jetzt ist. Klar, gab es mal irgendwelche Leute, die verhetzen eine Server.
Man könnte sagen, Cloud ist auch nur eine Menge von Servern. Und Server gab es damals schon. Aber das vereinfacht es jetzt vielleicht unzureichend zuletzt.
Cloud ist ja nicht Server, sondern Cloud ist ja ein Konzept. Es ist sozusagen, dass das Internet mehr oder weniger so für sich lebt. Und du halt viele Dinge, die man bis dahin eigentlich auf seinem Computer gemacht hat, irgendwo anders machen.
Also Apple hat mit iCloud 2011 angefangen, steht hier.
Ja gut, aber Cloud gab es auch schon.
Ja, aber es gab doch dort Mac vorher schon.
Apple war ja ein bisschen late to the game.
Ja, sehr.
Na eben, also gab es das ja schon vorher. Also brauchte es ja gar nicht sehen, es war schon da.
Ja, nee, so Cloud an sich gab es als Begriff vorher nicht. Ich weiß nicht, wann der aufkam, aber das war schon nicht vor zehn Jahren, sondern danach. Und was sicherlich auch in dem Maße so, also was unter Garantie so keine Rolle gespielt hat, diese App-World, also diese absolut schockierende Präsenz von Apps. Ich meine...
Diese Überpräsenz, diese für jeden Scheiß, die man für eine Webseite hatte, die nur einen Spruch angezeigt hat, wie ist Jens Spahn schon zurückgetreten oder sowas, da gibt es heutzutage Apps für.
Na ja, Webseite ist der Punkt. Damals gab es nicht in dem Maße Apps, die das Internet als reine Leitung zu einem Service verwendet haben und die du als Frontend zu einem Service benutzt hast. Gab es in dem ein bisschen Chat, ein bisschen E-Mail. Aber so, dass du eigentlich einen Service, für den du sonst eine Webseite hattest, jetzt so aufsetzt, dass du tatsächlich eine App als Frontend für diesen Service hast, das gab es damals nicht. Ich glaube, das ist auch eine neue Qualität. Zumindest in dem Umfang, wie in dem es jetzt betrieben wird.
Absolut. Und es ist natürlich sehr umstritten gewesen. Und man kennt ja auch immer wieder diese ganzen Debatten mit, oh ja, man hätte HTML nie verlassen dürfen. Und nur das offene Web ist irgendwie sozusagen die reine Leere. Und die Apps sind ja böse.
Solange nicht alle Webseiten auf allen Browsern funktionieren...
Naja, und das werden sie halt so nie tun. Der Aufwand, der in einem Webbrowser getrieben wird, um irgendwie dieselbe Erscheinungsbild vergleichbar zu einer App zu haben, der ist immens. Also was da an Performance vernichtet wird, dieser ganze Framework-Runterlade, Wahnsinn.
Ja, vor allen Dingen was da an Developer-Cycles verbrannt wird.
Die armen GUI-Designer, da tut mir ja mal leid dann.
Wo ich dich nicht sagen will, dass es nicht für bestimmte Aufgaben funktionieren Webseiten auch besser. Also es gibt viele Sachen, da sind Webseiten sinnvoll, weil ihre eigentliche Bedienung überschaubar ist. Also die Interaktion selber ist jetzt nicht so immens. So bestimmte Dinge kannst du halt mit dem Browser sehr gut machen, weil es eigentlich mehr um die Logik dahinter geht. Die Frage ist halt letztlich, was ist dein Interface? Und ich finde die Idee, dedizierte Apps zu haben, insofern ganz gut, als dass du eben das optimale User-Interface bauen kannst. Also was mir schon immer an Webseiten stört, ist, klar, kannst du da jetzt Dreck und Drop und Pipapo machen und so. Aber wir wissen alle, dann klickst du irgendwo mal an die falsche Stelle und drückst die Maus und ziehst sie irgendwie nach rechts. Und dann ist irgendwie so ein Eratscher Dreiviertel-Teil ist dann selektiert.
Selektion im Browser ist etwas, was sie immer noch nicht gelöst haben.
Ich verstehe das auch nicht.
Warum du nicht ordentlich in einem Browser selektieren kannst.
Ja, was denn selektieren?
Text oder irgendwas. Du fängst an zu selektieren. Und dann wird irgendwo rechts daneben noch ein bisschen was selektiert. Und links unten wird noch was selektiert. Und du denkst, nein, das gehört nicht zusammen.
Vor allem in iOS, wo du dann rumfingerst, wenn du denkst, der link fährt nach einem linker Buchstein. Du schiebst den Ding nach links und plötzlich selektiert er die ganze Seite.
Das Problem ist eigentlich gar nicht, diese Ordnung der Seite, sondern das Problem ist das Konzept selektieren an sich. Weil das ist ja eigentlich Quatsch. Weil du ja auf der einen Seite hast du ein Verständnis von, was wird mir da jetzt gerade präsentiert und wie ist aufgebaut. Und A, ein Teil davon ist Text. Da kann ich ja meine lokalen Betriebssystem-spezifischen Textselektionsmechanismen machen. Obwohl ja eigentlich selektieren heißt, ich mache eine User-Interaktion, um meinem Programm zu sagen, was es dann highlighten soll. So, wie das ja lokal auch funktioniert. Und genau das findet ja im Web so nur begrenzt statt. Beziehungsweise es mischt sich. Teilweise macht der Browser eine Selektion. Teilweise übernimmt das JavaScript diese Befehle und selektiert dann für dich. Du kennst das, du selektierst auf der einen Webseite, da ist es alles in deiner Highlight-Color. Du selektierst, du machst einfach Copy, alles fertig. Und vielleicht ist es genau das, was du haben willst. Aber dann gehst du dann zum Medium, dann tauchen da irgendwelche Twitter-Balken auf oder irgendwelche Querverweis-Programs und so weiter.
Dein Einwand ist komplett berechtigt.
Diese Verschrobenheit von zwei Betriebssystemen in einem, die wird halt beim Browser-Konzept einfach nicht los. Das ist ein inhärentes Problem. Trotz alledem hat das Web seine Bedeutung, aber ich finde eben auch, dass es an sich eine sehr gute Entwicklung ist, dass man eben Apps hat und dass die Kommunikation in die Cloud quasi über APIs läuft. Dass die Schnittstelle, die über das Netz ist, ist nicht so ein verlängerter Arm des Web-Servers mit ja, ich würde dir gerne was anzeigen, aber ich übernehme einen Teil davon und hier habe ich eine bekloppte Auszeichnungssprache, die total schwierig zu parsen ist, mit irgendwie einem noch komplizierteren Formatierungs-Zweitsprachsystem, nämlich CSS, und das rennest du jetzt da mal irgendwie rein. Und ach, übrigens, hier habe ich noch eine komplette Programmiersprache, die darfst du jetzt mal parsen und irgendwie in 8 Optimierungsstufen compilen, damit sie noch schnell genug läuft, damit du irgendwie auch in der Lage bist, die Hintergrundfarbe richtig anzuzeigen. Das ist schon wirklich einfach ein unfassbarer Aufwand.
Genau, dann scrollt es nicht mehr ohne zu ruckeln.
Und dann scrollt es nicht mehr ohne zu ruckeln, und es ist alles irgendwie broken und schlimm und so, obwohl eigentlich hätte ja vollkommen gereicht mit, hier ist die Liste von Dingen, die du anzeigen möchtest, lass deinen User scrollen und mach es so, wie es auf deiner Plattform am besten ist.
Du hast eins der wichtigsten Dinge meiner Meinung nach nicht erwähnt. Die wird auch gerne sträflich vernachlässigt von allen Leuten, die Apps schreiben und ich nehme mich da auch nicht aus. Das ist einfach, dass du bei einer App ein Programm auf einem lokalen Rechner läuft, der einen lokalen Datenstore hat, der nicht notwendigerweise eine Internetverbindung braucht. Was so viel heißt, wie du kannst im Prinzip, wenn du es richtig baust mit Synchronisierung und Caching und so weiter, relativ unabhängig davon agieren, ob du eine Netzwerkverbindung hast oder nicht. Oder zumindest du hast die Chance, so etwas zu bauen. Ich sage nicht, dass es einfach geht. Aber du hast die Möglichkeit, das zu tun. In verschiedenen großen Ausprägungsstufen. Also wenn du eine typische Chat-App, zum Beispiel, nehmen wir einen Apple Messages oder einen WhatsApp, ist so, du kannst da eine Message rein, also du kannst das Ding starten, kannst eine Message tippen, kannst absenden, schicken. Und er versucht, sie zu senden. Und wenn er kein Netz hat, dann bleibt die da hängen, bis er wieder Netz hat, oder weiß ich nicht. Irgendwann kriegst du einen roten Ding, dass es halt nicht ging.
Bei Messages ist auch schon nicht der Fall. Der sendet die und sagt, nee, es ging nicht.
Wenn du so einen Slack hast, dann kommt das Programm noch nicht mal richtig hoch. Du hast auch das Programm, weil irgendwie die Hälfte davon irgendwelchen Webserven sitzt und er nicht mehr in der Lage ist, das Programm zu starten.
Also ich finde da gerade, dass Tremer den geilsten Ansatz fährt mit deinem Balken, den du oben hast, dass du siehst, ob du verbunden bist oder nicht. Und du kannst das schon mal als Draft schreiben, du kannst es nur nicht senden.
Du kannst aber auch nichts anderes schreiben, das ganze Ding ist blockiert. Du kannst jetzt nicht ein Draft schreiben, du kannst nur an einen Vogel gerade tippen.
An einen Vogel eine Nachricht, aber an anderen noch eine.
Dann musst du es ja wieder rauslöschen.
Okay, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein Beispiel.
Aber es ist auch fast eher so ein Workaround, es ist nicht so richtig absichtlich. Ich weiß nicht, ob das... Ich weiß, ich habe kein Netz denn immer später, das kann man eben nicht beibringen, sondern du bist schon eher in so einem Fehlermodus und du nutzt so einen Trick.
Ja, die Frage ist, ich finde, so wie es Apple löst mit, ich lasse dich das Ding schicken und ich bekomme dann nicht wirklich eine Notification, dass es noch immer nicht geschickt wurde nach einer halben Stunde, finde ich viel unbefriediger, weil da habe ich schon längst wieder vergessen, dass ich irgendeine E-Mail geschrieben habe oder irgendwas anderes getippt habe. Wo hingehend bei dem weiß ich...
Geschenkt, das ist nicht jeder so implementiert, wie man es eigentlich tun sollte. Geschenkt, aber du hast zumindest die Chance, das zu tun. Also du könntest eine geniale Art machen, so nach der Art, ich konnte das jetzt nicht senden, ich werde es aber senden, sobald ich wieder Netz hab, oder weiß ich nicht was. Also die Möglichkeiten sind vielfältig. Versuch das mal im Browser zu machen.
Ja, was halt auch so ein bisschen der Vorteil an Apps ist, ist, dass du wirklich dich für eine, für eine Mobil-App, du kannst es wirklich halt auf deinen Bildschirm zuschneiden. Und du hast dann eben, ich finde es ist dann ein bisschen leichter, als unbedingt diesen Web-Gedöns zu machen, wo du eben noch nicht weißt, was da für eine Größe und so weiter ankommt. Also es ist ein bisschen...
Ich fände mich mit Web nicht aus. Es ist aber für eine App auch nicht trivial.
Okay, aber ich habe immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl, so in der Webseite kannst du sozusagen alles in komplett kompakt irgendwie reinbauen. Und du reduzierst dann irgendwie im Nachhinein über, wer kommt gerade auf welchem Screen an. Wohingegen du bei einer App wirklich vielleicht eher sagen kannst, okay, es ist eine iPhone-App und die kann von dem Zehner bis zum SE, aber immer so minimal das anzeigen, also dass du ein bisschen besser planen kannst, was du halt beim Web vielleicht nicht kannst.
Ja, wir hatten heute wieder so einen Test, wo wir alle um den Tisch standen und App getestet haben. Und da kamen halt auch so ein paar Sachen. Ja, hier fehlt noch ein Pixel und da noch und so weiter. Und dann ging so der Webview auf und dann so, oh Gott. Ja, nee, das muss ein anderes Team fixen, wieder zumachen. Das ist so, weißt du, dann hier stimmen die Abstände nicht, dann ist hier und da und so weiter. Und das verhält sich alles komisch.
Ja, Timme, willst du wieder mal den Moderator spielen und unser Thema mal ein bisschen wieder zurückziehen? Wir waren bei, wie man wollte wissen, was passiert in zehn Jahren.
Ich dachte, wir wären bei Swift gewesen.
Ja, waren wir auch mal. Meine eigentliche Frage war ja, vor zehn Jahren hätten wir uns vorstellen können, worüber wir jetzt sprechen. Heißt so viel, war ja meine implizierte Antwort, war ja nein. Was so viel heißt, können wir über das reden, was in zehn Jahren ist? Ja, von dem Kram, den wir heute schon kennen, Rechner, keine Ahnung, ob es noch Klapprechner gibt in zehn Jahren, wahrscheinlich schon.
Wie gesagt, ich bin ja der Meinung, so richtig, richtig viel passiert ist nicht.
Na ja, Smartphones haben sich schon durchgesetzt.
Klar, Details hier und da, aber wir werden, wir würden in zehn Jahren auch nicht so doll anders hier sitzen und über den aktuellen Scheiß reden.
Na ja, also ich würde sagen, vor zehn Jahren war der Klapprechner, der Laptop war das Hauptgerät. Und das Smartphone als solches, gerade von Apple erfunden, sag ich mal, war halt so, oh, Gaukel, neue Sache. Nicht so ganz klar, wie es sich entwickeln würde. Heute ist es so, dass für viele Leute halt das Smartphone ist halt das Hauptgerät und ja, man hat auch den Rechner. Aber der Rechner ist nicht mehr das Nummer-1-Communication-Device, was es vielleicht sowieso nie so ganz gewesen ist. Ja, bei dir ist es anders, Tim. Ich sag ja, bei den Leuten da draußen. Die Leute da draußen, die Hörer, bei den Hörern. Unsere Hörer sind auch eher nochmal eine speziellere Gruppe. Aber guck dir mal in der U-Bahn an, die Leute, die jetzt ihr Facebook, Facebook vielleicht nicht, aber ihre Messenger oder so weiter. Wer von denen weiß denn, dass es für WhatsApp auch eine Desktop-Klient gibt? Gibt's nicht doch für WhatsApp. Mac App doch.
Das sind alles so Desktop-Companion-Apps, die dann eigentlich mit dem Mobile-Ding irgendwie, weil es gibt keine wirklich richtigen Clients, und das ist ja irgendwie alles bekloppt.
Ja, aber das zeigt halt auch, wie sehr das in der Desktop-Rechne in die zweite Reihe geraten ist. Der Desktop-Rechner, auch wenn man ihn zuklappen und mitnehmen kann, ist doch das Festnetz-Phone geworden. Also das Ding steht auf dem Tisch, hängt am Strom, am Netz, Festnetzstrom, und benötigt irgendwie auch Internet von irgendwoher, hat das nicht selber an Bord. Aber du hast das Smartphone halt immer dabei, und das ist immer online.
Na, das könnte ja in zehn Jahren vielleicht mal dann soweit sein, dass die MacBooks auch mal LTE haben.
Das ist in den letzten 15 Jahren nicht passiert. Das wird auch in den nächsten 15 Jahren nicht passieren.
Doch, das wird passieren.
Ich wette eine Flasche Shampoos. In zehn Jahren immer noch.
Bin ich dabei.
Spätestens mit 5G.
Also auf welcher Seite?
Also ich würde auch sagen, in zehn Jahren haben die Laptops LTE mit drin.
Also die zweit am meisten hinter der Zeit hinterhersehende Nation schafft es jetzt langsam in Richtung Flatrates zu marschieren, nämlich Deutschland. Das heißt, dass die ganz hinten ist, USA, dass die das nächsten fünf Jahren auch schaffen werden.
Wie Flatrates? Es gibt Flatrates? Wo jetzt?
Bei Telekom.
Nicht bei O2.
Ach die für die 70 Euro?
Wir werden das dieses Jahr erleben, dass alle Mobilfunkanbieter in Deutschland so was haben. Es wird sich sicherlich irgendwo so im Bereich zwischen 50 und 80 Euro einpendeln. Erstmal, und das geht dann auch relativ schnell, dass wir da irgendwie gar nicht mehr drüber reden.
Das ist wie mit all diesen Entwicklungen. Der Damm ist jetzt gebrochen. Die haben alle die Pläne, das ist ein bisschen so, wie nennt man dieses Spiel, wo einer zuerst wackelt, so Mikado oder sowas, die haben alle diese Dinger in der Tasche. Ich hab ja lange Zeit für diese Industrie gearbeitet und ich weiß, wie lange die sonst brauchen, um sowas vorlaufen zu lassen. Die haben alle die Pläne dafür, auch für ihre Billingsysteme und für Kundeneinformationssysteme und lalala und so. Die haben die alle in der Tasche. Da wird halt drauf gewackelt, wer zuerst wird geguckt, wer zuerst von denen wackelt. Deswegen hat die Telekom jetzt auch nicht gesagt, wir machen jetzt Flatrate für 30 Euro, weil dann hätten die anderen echt Schiss in der Hose, inklusive der Telekom selber, sondern die Telekom geht erstmal so ran und sagt, wir testen mal, wir testen das mal an, legen das mal für 80 Euro auf den Tisch, mal sehen, wer es so kauft. Klar, die anderen werden jetzt nachziehen mit 78,95 Euro oder so in der Richtung. Und der O2 vielleicht irgendwie für 69 oder so was. Und dann ist eh ein Nähländer.
Die Frage ist wahrscheinlich nicht, wer das so kauft, sondern die Leute, die es kaufen, wie viel sie denn auch wirklich davon benutzen, sodass die Telekom sagt, hier bricht jetzt nicht gleich alles zusammen.
Es wird alles nicht zusammenbrechen.
Nein, ich hab da ganz anderes daraus gehört.
Das einzige Problem ist, dass sie Schiss vor dieser Roaming-Nummer haben. Deswegen spielen sie ja mit diesen komischen Regelungen und gucken, ob sie dafür auf die Schnauze gehauen kriegen und so was.
Komischerweise kriegen die anderen Länder das ja auch hin.
Nee, die haben auch das selber Problem. Die sind dann aber auch frech. Die gehen dann halt einfach hin, drehen denen den Saft ab, sagen, na klagt doch. Weil die Spanier genau wissen, dass wenn man bei deren Regulierungsbehörde anruft, dann legen die einfach auf. Ja, da sind nicht so viele davon. Die sind auch nicht so auf diesem Deutsch-Trip im Allgemeinen. Hab ich doch bezahlt. So diese Typen, die sich in den Zug setzen und sich da irgendwie ins WLAN einklicken, einen Film laufen lassen und dabei einpennen. Gibt so diese komische, ich hab das ja bezahlt, also lasst mich jetzt kauten.
Kann ja nicht anders, jeder ran und drückt dann die Pause-Taste.
Nee, klappt nicht. Aber nee, wirklich, das ist ja das Problem. In der Tat, man muss den Provider nicht mal lassen. Das ist ein verdammter Kostenfalle. Weil selbst wenn sie das jetzt hier im Land alles schön Flatrate machen, der Typ, der muss ja nicht mal rübergehen über die Grenze, muss ja nur in der Nähe der Grenze sein. Der Telefon bucht sich drüben ein und der lässt die ganze Nacht seinen Bit-Torrent laufen. Über sein Ding. Das kannst du ja alles machen, aber da wird auch eine Telekom nicht dran pleite gehen. Aber wenn die das wieder machen, dann wird das echt böse.
Selbst ohne so eine richtige, reine, totale Flatrate einzurichten, könnte man noch sooo viel verbessern. Allein dieses Ding, so dein Kontingent wird dann jeden Kalendermonat wieder auf verschwindet einfach. Dann hast du es gar nicht benutzt und dann darfst du es aber auch nicht im nächsten Monat benutzen und man fragt sich warum.
Das ist einer der ärgerlichsten Punkte, gerade für mich als Telekom-Kunde, dass sie alle nicht behaupten könnten, sie wissen nicht, wie man ein Problem löst. Weil man kann einfach die Telekom-Netze in den Nachbarländern oder Telekom in den USA angucken, da gibt es also was. Telekom USA, kannst du dein Ding...
Worauf ich hinaus wollte ist, es ist absehbar, das Ding ist in fünf Jahren vom Tisch. Leute werden sich nicht mehr über oh Gott, der Monat ist noch nicht zu Ende und ich habe keine Daten mehr und jetzt funktioniert mein Telefon nicht mehr. Das Problem wird weggehen. Einerseits durch extrem hohe Datenvolumen, die du hast in beschränkten Tarifen, teilweise durch solche reinen Flatrates, teilweise einfach durch Volumina-Verträge, die einfach ein bisschen sinnvoller sind. Nach dem Motto, du kriegst ja irgendwie deine Terabyte im Jahr und fertig ist die Laube.
Dementsprechend finde ich es ja auch umso affiger und umso dämlicher, dass jetzt sozusagen, wo gerade die Tür zufällt, die öffentliche Hand in Deutschland entdeckt, dass man ja freie WLANs irgendwo aufbaut. Und zwar so richtig im Feld. Jetzt nicht, dass sie sagen, wir haben ein Rathauskeller, da geht das LTE nicht, da hängt dir mal ein WLAN-Accesspoint hin. Jetzt fangen sie an, mitten auf die Straße WLAN-Accesspoints zu hängen mit obskursten Portalen und allmöchen Dreck daran und denkt mir jedes Mal so, ey, dieses Jahr sind die LTE-Flatträts rum, dann wartet mit deinem Accesspoint, außer für Besucher aus Nordkorea oder so. Aber das ist irgendwie so, hä, was soll das?
Ich hab noch nie so an Public WLAN geglaubt, im ehrlich zu sein.
Und das macht auch technisch keinen Sinn.
Es ist nicht dafür gebaut. So, worauf wollte ich eigentlich hinaus? Ich wollte darauf hinaus, dass in einer mobile Daten sind überall Nummer. Natürlich auch dieser Scare vor Oh Gott, mein Laptop frisst zu viel Daten, weil ich hab den jetzt aufgeklappt und dann fängt er an Backup zu machen und sich zu Sünden und so weiter.
Nee, du hast ihn aufgeklappt, vergiss es. Die sind ja auch schon online, wenn du sie nicht aufklappst.
Wie soll er online sein ohne LTE?
Nee, das noch nicht, aber der ist auch an, wenn du ihn zuklappst. Also das heißt, wenn die mal LTE haben, dann sind die auch im Netz, wenn der zu ist, dann ist nichts mit, ich hab jetzt meinen Rechner offen gelassen, sondern der ist sowieso an und drin und online.
Ja, umso besser. So, dann kann man das Ding, wenn er geklaut ist, auch mal schon fressen.
So wie Telefon würde dann sein, es geht nicht mehr schlafen, sondern der Laptop wird einfach dauer an sein. Das können wir mal schon mal festhalten. Die Laptops werden sich so verhalten wie Telefone, die sind einfach immer an. Deckel zu heißt nur Display ausmeeren.
Ja, aber sowas gibt es schon, nennt sich iPad. Also ich glaube nicht, dass Apple versuchen wird, die Laptops näher an die iPads und die iPhones ranzuführen.
Machen sie doch schon.
Was meinst du mit näher ran?
Weil du jetzt da diesen Touch, diese Touch...
Nee, auch wenn das Laptop zu ist und wenn du es nicht explizit abgewählt hast, glaube ich, dann holt der schon Mails, wenn der Deckel zu ist. Er macht schon Backups, wenn der Deckel zu ist.
Wenn er am Strom ist.
Ja, wenn er zumindest nicht leer ist, ja. Oder eine gewisse Füllmenge hat, glaube ich.
Also wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es Apple machen wird. Man hat ja sowieso nicht das Gefühl, dass sie sich jetzt noch groß für einen Mac interessieren, obwohl dieser eine Artikel, den du ja auch in die Liste geschrieben hattest zum Thema Mac Pro, so ein bisschen suggeriert, dass sie jetzt die große Offensive für den neuen Mac Pro starten und versuchen irgendwie zu verstehen, wofür die einen Mac Pro brauchen. Na dieser Artikel über den Mac Pro aus dem, was war denn das? Das war doch ein Workflow, hattest du doch.
Artikel?
Na Apple hat das gesagt.
Ja, das war.
Das ist eine Feststellung von Apple, dass der Mac Pro nicht dieses Jahr kommt.
Dass er nicht dieses Jahr kommt, aber auch, dass sie da irgendwie jetzt so eine Abteilung haben, die sich ganz genau anguckt, was die Pro-User denn mit ihren Macs machen.
Ach so, diese Workflow-Truppe. Dann kann ich hoffen, dass sie so eine Truppe haben, die mal guckt, was die Leute mit ihren Computern machen. Das wird ja Marseille.
Leider sind es die falschen Leute, auf die sie gucken, glaube ich.
Ja, mir fiel der Ausdruck eGPU, also auch zu oft. Und da würde ich nur sagen, okay, wenn ihr den Compiler auf die GPU portiert, dann soll es mir recht sein. Aber ich will einfach auch noch einen Rechner haben, der CPU hat, damit er auch normale Sachen machen kann.
Sollen wir jetzt noch bei zehn Jahre nach vorne gucken oder was?
So ein bisschen, ja, die Frage war ja, wo geht's hin? Worüber werden wir uns in zehn Jahren unterhalten? Meine These war ja über Laptops wahrscheinlich noch so ein bisschen, aber nicht mehr so sehr viel. Die Frage, was kommt nach dem Smartphone, habe ich keine Antwort drauf.
Die Leute halten sich ja schon jetzt Tablets ans Ohr.
Na, was kommt nach dem Smartphone? Nach dem Smartphone ist ja schon was gekommen.
Was denn?
Die Frage ist ja eher, wenn es keine oder wenig Liebe für MacBooks und so weiter gibt, wie wird man in Zukunft entwickeln, willst du ja anfangen auf so einem Tablet eine Entwicklungsumgebung drauf zu bauen und hundert Sachen anzusetzen?
Ich kann dir sagen, wie das kommt. Du gehst mit deinem Telefon zur Arbeit oder mit deinem Arbeitstelefon, legst das neben dein Display und dann geht das Display an und du legst los mit der Tastatur und dann deine CPUs in deinem Telefon zum Beispiel. Das ist vielleicht zehn Jahre noch ein bisschen wenig.
Ja und dann haben wir dann immer noch dieselben Betriebssystemtrennungen, dass du iOS hast.
Ist doch egal eigentlich.
Na vom Workflow finde ich das halt nicht egal.
Na ja, du hast, du hast, also iOS und Mac OS trennen ja zwei Dinge. Das erste ist, dass Mac OS halt in Anführungszeichen ein richtiges Betriebssystem ist, also mit quasi Gerätetreibern und mit einem offenen File-System, das du benutzen kannst und solchen Sachen einerseits, aber andererseits halt auch eine Mauszeiger-Oberfläche hat. Also ich schiebe einen Mauszeiger irgendwo hin und klicke. Das ist was anderes als ich gucke hin und tappe mit dem Finger drauf. Das sind ja zwei komplett unterschiedliche Sachen. Die Microsoft-Leute haben es nicht wahrhaben wollen und die Linux-Leute haben es auch nicht wahrhaben wollen. Aber es ist einfach so, du kannst nicht das gleiche Interface benutzen, je nachdem, ob du eine Maus hast oder ob du mit dem Finger tappst.
Genau, deswegen frage ich halt auch, weil ich finde, das ist eine Zumutung als Entwickler auf einer Touch-basierten Oberfläche arbeiten zu müssen, wo du keine aktiven Ecken und keine Ahnung so eine Sache einfach hast.
Stell dir vor, dein Telefon, was du in zehn Jahren neben dein Display mit der Tastatur hinlegst, schaltet dann einfach auf Mausbetrieb um. Also man kann ja beides können.
Also ich sage mal, von der Technologie her ist Apple da eigentlich gut aufgestellt, weil sich iOS und Mac OS intern so wenig voneinander unterscheiden, dass sie durchaus in der Lage wären, einem Developer alle Tools an die Hand zu geben, um so eine, sage ich mal, Twitter App zu schreiben, die sich auf einem Desktop wie ein Desktop verhält und auf einem Mobilgerät wie eine Tab App, also das wäre, glaube ich, gar nicht so schwierig. Das würden die hinkriegen. Ob es so kommen wird, kann man natürlich nicht sagen.
Also ich glaube, dass diese Benutzungsart Laptop überleben wird. Was auch immer dann für ein Betriebssystem aktiv ist, aber so dieses Touch, diese Touch-Freiheit.
Also ich glaube auch, dass Tastaturen überleben werden, auch wenn Apple momentan scheinbar nicht der Ansicht ist.
Ja, One Key at a Time wollen sie uns wegnehmen.
Was ist als nächstes dran? Da waren da schon ein bisschen mehr Keys als nur einer. Eine ganze Reihe.
Eine Leiste.
Jaja, eine Zeit nur nach der anderen.
Ja, aber es war einer, der benutzt wurde und die anderen waren so zu ihr Rat. Geht so, ja, okay. Aber die Escape-Taste ist glaube ich die, die am meisten die Gemüter erregt hat, besonders hier.
Ich bin erst mal wieder aufgefallen.
Scheiß GI-User.
Auch beim Zocken jedes Mal schon kriegst du diese blöde Hand drauf. Jedes Mal kommt dieses, wollen sie sich ausloggen?
Also die Escape-Taste und die F-Tasten wegzunehmen, das war kein guter Mut. Das waren echt echter Fehler. Wenn sie diese dämliche Touchbar noch als Zusatzgimmick oben drüber gemacht hätten, da hätte sich niemand beschwert. Also zusammen mit einer brauchbaren Tastatur hätte sich niemand beschwert. Hätten alle super gefunden, aber so war es also echt ein Griff ganz tief ins Klo.
Und dass sie ja sagen, dass man die Touchbar, dass es ja ein Keyboard-Extension ist und dass man da nichts, das ist sozusagen kein Informationsdisplay, sondern soll halt eine Tastatur simulieren. Da könnte man so viele tausend geile Sachen anzeigen, die so Metainformation zu dem, was auf dem Schirm keinen Platz hat oder da nicht hingehört oder störend wäre, könnte alles in diese Touchbar, die dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen anders heißen sollte, weil dann ist es ja nicht nur eine Touchbar. Aber Apple sagte, nein, es sollen nur Sachen angezeigt werden, auf die man auch klicken kann. Das ist keine Informationsanzeige. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so schlau ist. Also ich hab das Gefühl, es ist es nicht.
Wie geil das wäre, die Statuskram zu haben, wie Temperatur von Grafikkarten und keine Ahnung.
Ja, an sowas denkt Apple, glaube ich, eher so weniger. Aber das könnten sie einfach den Drittanbietern überlassen, weil manchmal sind die Innovationen halt nicht von Apple, sondern von woanders. Also Apple bedient sich da ja auch ordentlich. So, jetzt kannst du das mal wieder zumachen, die Tüte.
Ich will da noch was zu sagen, weil ich hab jetzt eben mal die Pause drüber nachgedacht, was ich eigentlich wirklich erwarte, was in zehn Jahren ist. So, und bin einfach mal in mich gegangen und hab mich einfach gefragt, was mir eigentlich am meisten fehlt.
Kinderbilder von dir.
Ich dachte schon, ich hätte meine Hose offen oder so. Kinderbilder von mir, na toll.
Ja, rede weiter. Was ist in zehn Jahren?
Ich versuch gerade, über die Zukunft zu reden und ihr kommt mit...
Vergangenheit.
Vergangenheit. Ach du spielst heute auf Warcraft.
Nein, ich versuch jetzt zur Update.
Okay, ich fang noch mal an. Also ich hab mal drüber nachgedacht, was eigentlich so mir am meisten fehlt bzw. was eigentlich so die Stellen sind, von denen ich möchte, dass sie sich am meisten evolvieren. Mal abgesehen von den notwendigen Verbesserungen einer etablierten Technologie wie Laptop und Mousepointer, OS und so weiter, was ich halt haben will, weil das ist einfach immer mein Ort der maximalen Automatisierung und wenn man irgendwie Power-User ist, dann will man einfach einen Ort der maximalen Automatisierung haben und da werden diese iPads nie, nie, nie hinkommen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Heißt aber nicht, dass ich halt nicht auch mein iPhone als Go-To-Medium habe für bestimmte Sachen und auch die Apple Watch für mich schon ein Go-To-Medium geworden ist. Es gibt Dinge, die mache ich halt als erstes, wenn ich mich als erstes zur Watch, dann wird mir nicht im Traumeinfallen noch mein Telefon rauszudeben.
Zum Beispiel?
Was ist mein nächster Termin?
Uhrzeit.
Was ist mein nächster Termin? Ganz wichtig.
Notifications. Was kam in den letzten zehn Minuten ran? Arm hoch, Zack, Swipe irgendwie, ah hier, Zack, Bumm, Tweet, Bla, okay, Nachricht.
Man sieht nur die Notification und nicht...
Wenn der Typ es richtig gemacht hat, dann müsste man auch sagen, sehen können, was er geschrieben hat.
Schick mir mal was, ich weiß es grad nicht. Reamer ist für mich immer so eine Aberration.
T-Timer, also Eieruhr, benutze ich ständig.
Ey Jungs, wir sind bei 2028, da kommt jemand mit T-Timer?
Nee, ich nicht.
Nein, er hat ja gerade gesagt, was er heute auf der Watch...
Ja, lass mich mal ausführen. Also, es ist so, das heißt, Dinge verlagern sich, weil ich die Erwartung habe, dass sie dort friktionsloser stattfinden. So, und ich hab natürlich auch immer einen Wunsch, wenn ich jetzt selber Kommunikation mache, ja, das Rima kann ich auf der Watch lesen.
Mit Inhalt.
Und interessanterweise ist es halt gerade die Kommunikation mit anderen, die ja derzeit noch sehr gefühlt so ein bisschen in den Kinderschuhen steckt, so viel sich da getan hat, aber dieser ganze Wahnsinn mit, mit welcher App mache ich den jetzt und welche abkann denn was, wie, wo und Signal hier und WhatsApp da und Rima und Nein und Messages und so. Das ist natürlich ein Zustand, der sich irgendwie auflösen muss. Da bin ich mir nicht ganz so sicher, wie so die kapitalistischen Kräfte in den nächsten zehn Jahren so zuschlagen werden, aber irgendwo ab einem bestimmten Punkt muss es auch wieder eine Grand Unification geben. Also irgendwo müssen diese ganzen Kommunikationskanäle wieder zusammenlaufen und nicht unbedingt bei Facebook. Denen ist ja auch nicht gelingt, alle Bedürfnisse abzudecken, wenn sie noch...
Lieber gelingt das?
Ja gut so, weil das zwingt dann eben auch ab so einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt. Und vielleicht wird auch über Regularien und technische Entwicklungen das Ganze noch vorangetrieben werden, dass eben so eine Einigung auch wieder nötig ist. Weil wenn dann irgendwann mal Leute vielleicht auch mal so im politischen Prozess angekommen sind, die nicht irgendwie Mark Zuckerberg irgendwie irgendwas von E-Mails, die sie in WhatsApp verschicken, erzählen, dann könnte sich da ja vielleicht noch mal was tun. Was mich extrem stört, ist, wie schwierig das irgendwie alles noch ist. Also allein, wenn ich jetzt hier in einem Raum sitze mit jemandem zusammenarbeite und dann dieses, ich schick dir mal die Datei, dieses Genude, ja was nehmen wir denn? Schick ich dir per Mail schick ich dir das, mach mal Airdrop auf, warum taucht mein Scheiß Picture-Lany auf? Diese Zuverlässigkeit dieser ganzen Dinge.
Es ist immer noch so, wenn man es noch macht, und tatsächlich funktioniert es ja inzwischen, aber es ist immer noch so, dass man sich tierisch freut, dass es funktioniert hat so schnell.
Ja und es gibt immer fünf Sekunden, wo man denkt, oh heute funktioniert es nicht.
Man hat noch nicht das Gefühl, es funktioniert auf jeden Fall, sondern man guckt so, ah ja es klappt okay super.
Ja das funktioniert natürlich auch nur lokal und so weiter und irgendwie läuft das irgendwie nicht so zu. Und eigentlich möchte ich so Kommunikation haben, so als wenn ich mit zehn Leuten auf der Straße laufe und irgendwie mir permanent Tennisbälle zuwerfe. Also im Sinne von die Kommunikation ist das oder so wie man halt miteinander redet. Also ein Flow, instant, problemlos, unmittelbar. Die Auswahl eines Gesprächspartners, eines Kontaktes, einer Information und das Weiterleiten wird einfach flüssig sein.
Das wird es nur im goldenen Käfig geben, aber nicht in einem offenen Standard. Ich bin nicht voll von überzeugt.
Den haben wir ja nur im goldenen Käfig.
Es muss nicht unbedingt ein offener Standard sein. Ich meine, die meisten Dinge, die ich heute ganz toll finde, sind nicht unbedingt offene Standards. Aber es gibt ja interessante Anleitungen. Ich meine, habt ihr mal mit Pages, Numbers und so was, mal diese iCloud-Kollaborationsfunktion ausprobiert? Nö. Das habe ich nämlich heute das erste Mal gemacht und war ganz überrascht. Erstens, dass es funktioniert hat und zweitens, welchen Grad an Kollaborationswirrwittnis das Ganze hatte. Also ich habe es jetzt mit Numbers ausprobiert und so zwei Leute arbeiten auf demselben Spreadsheet. Und man kennt das ja von Google Books, denkt sich ja so, naja, das ist schon, ne? Kann man schon, dann änderst du da irgendwie einen Wert in der Zeit, dann ist der geändert, dann updatet sich das, fertig ist die Laube.
Und so war es aber nicht.
Doch.
Latenzen ohne Ende.
Nein.
Hat super funktioniert?
Hat super funktioniert.
War aber noch toller. War nämlich so, dass in dem Moment, wo andere Personen in das Dokument kamen, ich das sofort gesehen habe, dass die andere Person da war. Und dann habe ich halt nicht nur die Änderung gesehen, sondern ich habe halt auch gesehen, welche Zelle markiert war. In einer automatisch eingefärbten Umrahmung, wo über dieser Zelle dann der Name eingeblendet war.
Ja, also sag mal so, ich habe noch nie in Google Docs jetzt zusammen in einem Textdokument umgefummelt.
Seit wann ist das bei Google Docs?
Aber die Google Spreadsheets seit Jahren. Ich benutze die seit Jahren. Das ist das einzige Ding, was ich überhaupt von diesem Google Quatsch benutze mit anderen Kollaborativen. Ja, mit einer Farbe um das Kästchen rum, und dann an der Farbe kannst du erkennen, wer das gerade ist, der in deinem Sheet rumstochert und so. Das ist alles alter Hut.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, es funktioniert auch mit 30, 40 Leuten. Das fand ich erstaunlich.
An der Zelle ist der Name dran? Oder ist da nur die Zelle in einer Farbe?
Die Zelle ist in einer Farbe und da ist ein Tooltip. Oder wenn du da deine Maus in der Nähe hast, siehst du den Namen und so.
Ich war auf jeden Fall gut. Hab ich das jetzt noch nicht gesehen. Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass ich in meinen Google-Spreadsheets im Wesentlichen immer alleine rumdokter. Ich wollte auch auf was anderes hinaus. Das Ganze hatte so eine Leichtigkeit und so eine Flüssigkeit. Ansatzweise. Und ich denke, dass das so eine Normalität sein wird in den zehn Jahren. Dass wir halt sehen werden, dass dieses ganze Zusammenspiel von Dingen, nicht unbedingt jetzt nur in zwei Produkten eines Herstellers, sondern eben möglichst auch weiter überspannt, dass das flüssiger wird und dass wir dann auch an das anfangen zu kommunizieren, weil es einfach noch mal weniger Friktion hat im Establishment et cetera. Wo man sich denkt, dass es heute schon so einfach ist, aber dann ist es im Zweifel dann doch irgendwie schwierig.
Kann schon sein, dass mehr noch so Interaction zwischen den Leuten kommt.
Also, also was, was?
Schneller und besser auf jeden Fall.
Was ich mir noch vorstelle, ist erstens, dass Siri irgendwann mal geht, in den nächsten sieben bis acht Jahren. Das wäre mal ganz, ganz schick. Und was ich irgendwie auch ganz toll fände, wenn wir da in zehn Jahren nicht mehr drüber reden müssten, ist, dass irgendwie eigentlich alle Autos autonom fahren können und man keine Verkehrsunfälle mehr hat.
Es würde immer noch Klaviere geben, die aus dem Himmel fallen, aber ich hoffe, dass ich gar nicht mehr Auto fahren muss, sondern dass ich von irgendwas abgeholt werde, was mich einfach da hinbringt, wo ich hin will.
Wir haben ja nicht gesagt, dass du das Auto fährst, aber es wird so etwas, ähnlich wie ein Auto geben, das Leute durch die Gegend fährt.
Es könnte auch ein Bus sein.
Ja, ist ja egal.
Vorm Faktor ist es ja jetzt mal egal.
Also das mit den Autos, das glaube ich, das mit dem Siri, das glaube ich nicht.
Ich würde noch mal kurz zurückgrätschen zu dem kollaborativen Arbeiten. Ich denke auch, dass das irgendwie so für mich das meiste Potential hat und ich war ganz erfreut, als ich am Easter Egg jetzt noch an einem Paper geschrieben habe und das haben wir mit so einem kollaborativen Tool gemacht, wo man LaTeX dran schreiben kann. Ähnlich wie zu einem Google Doc, nur dass du halt im LaTeX arbeitest und aber Kommentarfunktion auch ein bisschen hattest. Und das war echt cool.
Brauchst du einen InvisiVic-Effekt, dass man dann auch gleich sieht, wie das kommentiert aussieht und so?
Nicht ganz, man muss das noch einmal so diesen Compiler anwerfen. Ich guck mal kurz, wie das hieß. Das war auf jeden Fall ganz praktisch. Und hat schon mal auf jeden Fall das Paper schreiben ein bisschen erleichtert.
So, ich glaube jetzt können wir mal den Televator sein.
Die sucht noch.
Nee, ich wollte noch den Link vielleicht, falls mal jemand etwas Ähnliches gebrauchen könnte, reinwerfen, wenn ich das auf die Schnelle finde.
Da schrieb jemand Sherla Tech, ist es das?
Mehr nicht, schneller weiß es. Aber hier mit den Autos, mit dem Siri, da will ich auch noch mal kurz meinen Senf zu abgeben, dafür sind wir ja da. Also, dass die Autos irgendwie mal besser fahren können als die Menschen oder, ja, glaube ich schon, fehlerfreier. Das, glaube ich schon, kommt demnächst an Siri, glaube ich, nicht so, weil ich glaube, mit dieser AI und mit diesem Zuhören und diesem ganzen Quatsch, dass das jetzt erst mal so ein bisschen vorwärts ging, aber es wird nicht mit der gleichen Geschwindigkeit sich weiter verbessern, sondern es wird sozusagen jetzt ins Stock geraten und deswegen glaube ich da nicht so dran.
Na ja, mir würde es ja mal reichen, wenn Siri auf den Stand der Konkurrenz käme. Ja. Also so ein Google, so ein OK Google, wie heißt die Funktion? Hier heißt es nur OK Google oder wie heißt die?
Oder Alexa.
Oder Alexa. Na gut, Alexa ist ja mehr oder weniger ein gesprochenes Command Line Interface.
Ist egal. Also ich hab's selber nicht, aber Leute, die sowas haben, sind da schon schwerstens begeistert. Darf ich ganz kurze Rückgrätsche machen, bevor ich sie vergesse? Nämlich weil jetzt gerade das Wort Chat gefallen ist. Ganz zurück die Rückgrätsche mit Mobile Macs. Und damals und so, seit wann gibt es denn Mobile Macs oder die Freak Show live inklusive Chat? Die ersten Dinger hast du ja nur aufgenommen. Da gab es halt kein Live und sowas, oder?
Obwohl, haben wir die Live?
Da gab es ja gar nicht die Technik dafür.
Aber relativ schnell war das, oder?
Das war relativ schnell.
Da gab es ja damals schon Xenim.
Ja, mit Xenim fing das an.
Also ich hab immer offline gehört. Oder fast immer.
Hm, warte mal.
Also Xenim hat hier 210 Sendungsbeiträge. Also seit der fünften Sendung.
Okay.
Weil das ist ja auch schon noch jetzt kein Alleinstellungsmerkmal, aber es ist doch schon ein herausragendes Merkmal, der Freak Show.
Haben das die anderen Sendungen nicht, die anderen Podcasts?
Es gibt auch andere, die das machen, aber es gibt ja wahnsinnig viele Podcasts, die ihr nicht vielleicht habt.
Es wird immer üblicher.
Also NSFW war immer live.
Ja, da sind dann auch alle live, sind das schon klar, aber wie die anderen?
Nee, bei mir sind nicht alle live. Bei mir ist eigentlich nur Freak Show und NSFW live.
Und Logbuch Netzpolitik?
Nee.
Schneidest du etwa raus? Oder rein?
Wenn sich Linus mal wieder verplappert.
Das...
Nein, das ist... Live heißt halt auch ein Commitment zur Startzeit machen. Und das ist manchmal sehr schwierig, weil es teilweise so ist, dass wir uns treffen, sagen, wir fangen richtig früh an. Das heißt, wir sitzen hier um 9 Uhr.
Und dann steht dabei erst mal draußen mit einem Bier für eine Stunde und dann...
Nein, wir machen ja immer... Es geht ja nicht nur um die Sendung, sondern das ist ja auch so ein sonstiger Lebensabgleich. Und mal gibt es das eine, mal das andere. Oft wird auch diskutiert, welche Themen nimmt man jetzt eigentlich rein? Wie behandelt man die sensitive Sachen, richtigen Ton finden?
Also wahrscheinlich sind auch die Termine an sich schon gar nicht so festgelegt wie unser Mittwoch.
Nein, also nicht mit dieser Regelmäßigkeit, mit man trifft sich immer um, sondern es ist eigentlich von Woche zu Woche immer wieder so ein wann bist du verreist, wann bin ich verreist Ding. Aber es ist halt vor allem diese Unvorhersehbarkeit, wann man eigentlich jetzt wirklich sendet. Und dann ist es auch so, dass du in so einer Sendung nicht groß irgendwie jetzt auf Community oder so eingehen kannst, wie wir das hier machen. Das gibt das Format einfach nicht hier. Und es ist halt auch ein anderer Mindset, wenn du erstmal in die Retorte sprichst und weißt, du kannst halt danach zur Not auch nochmal das Messer ansetzen und sagen so, den Spruch muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt so stehen lassen, weil den missverstehen dann Leute. Das kommt nicht oft vor ab und zu mal, aber das ist dann auch eine andere Sicherheit und bedeutet, dass man dann eben aber auch mehr erstmal so redet, wie man es für richtig hält und dann vielleicht auch das so lässt und den Ton auch trifft, den man sonst vielleicht einfach schon mal von vorne rein, einfach weil man weiß so, live, das wird dann so gebootlegged und so. All so Aspekte. Also das ist einfach aus vielen Gründen passt es da nicht. Bei den Interviewsendungen ist es bei mir ganz genauso, weil ich da auch Leute einfach zu sehr unter Druck setzen würde, bzw. auch überhaupt nicht klar ist. Und es gibt da auch keinen Gewinn. Also da ist jetzt durch live nichts zu gewinnen. Du machst da nur ein Commitment zu Leuten, wo du dann am Ende eh nichts daran ändern kannst. Und eigentlich sind solche Interviewsituationen viel zu intensiv, als dass man sich dann eben mit sowas noch parallel beschäftigen kann. Ich mach das halt noch ab und zu mal, wenn ich so onstage bin, wieder bei Raumzeit neulich. So eine Sachen, ja.
Hast du gehört, wir sind nicht so intensiv wie seine Interviewsendungen?
Ihr seid mega intensiv. Betreuungsintensiv.
Betreuungsintensiv, genau.
Gut, ich würd mal sagen, wir schließen mal diese ganze in zehn Jahren Ding ab. Ja, und überhaupt jetzt mal genug Freak Show Rückblick. Und kommen zu unserem tollen vorbereiteten Plan. Ja, kurzer Einwurf. Vor zehn Jahren hat ja auch GitHub angefangen, stellten wir heute so fest.
Ich zumindest.
Bemerkenswert, oder?
Seit wann seid ihr dabei?
Bei GitHub?
Ja.
Gar nicht.
Weiß ich nicht, kann man irgendwo sehen, wenn man seinen Account eröffnet hat?
Ja, sieht man.
Woran?
Wenn du auf jeden Fall, wenn du auf dein Profil gehst. Genau, hast du auf der rechten Seite unten auf jeden Fall das erste, die erste Jahreszahl stehen. 2001?
Die erste Jahreszahl, ist das dann 2009?
Das kommt hin, wenn du runterscrollst oder auf die Jahreszahl klickst, dann steht dann da, wann du dazugekommen bist.
Wieso gibt es hier 2001, wenn es das erste 10 Jahre gibt?
Das frage ich mich jetzt auch. Ein Stück runterscrollen. Und dann hast du da die ganzen Jahreszahlen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich seitdem es Git gibt.
Genau, 2011.
Der Joint GitHub, 13. Mai 2009.
Ich bin am 9., ach, am 3. November 2010 erst hinzugekommen.
Ich habe am gleichen Tag noch mein erstes Repository gemacht.
Ja, ich habe Repositories mittlerweile wieder gelöscht, weil das war aus der Uni-Zeit noch. Ich glaube, der war eigentlich gar nicht... Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das gelöscht habe. Das ärgert mich mittlerweile auch, weil ich habe GitHub durch die Fachhochschule mitbekommen, weil ich Softwarequalität hatte. In Softwarequalität gab es eben natürlich dann auch sowas wie Git als Versionskontroll.
Ich bin da 1.
Also ich weiß, dass ich zu spät war für das eine Private Repository, was man haben durfte ganz am Anfang. Also wenn du ganz am Anfang deinen Account gemacht hast, konntest du ein Private Repository machen. Aber nur eins. Und das kriegst du ja inzwischen gar nicht mehr, wenn du nicht bezahlst. Und dafür war ich dann doch noch zu spät. Oder ich habe es nicht gerafft, dass man das machen kann, dann habe ich es nie gemacht.
Ich habe die immer mal wieder gehabt durch die Uni-Hochschulen, E-Mail-Adressen. Die geben dir dann für so was wie Masterarbeit und so Private Accounts, das ist ganz praktisch.
Ja, aber meine Gesamtaktivität ist sehr überschaubar.
Es gibt immer so Phasen.
Ja, meine im Prinzip auch. Also wir haben halt in der Firma jetzt ein Corporate GitHub. Was halt so eine Installation ist, die sich im Wesentlichen genauso verhält wie das Public GitHub. Ich kenn GitLab jetzt nicht, aber ich nehm's mal an. GitLab ist auch so ein GitHub-Clone.
Was ich finde, wenn wir schon mal bei GitHub sind, womit sie echt mal noch einen großen Sprung machen könnten. Obwohl, wenn er dann wahrscheinlich nur aus vielen kleinen besteht am Ende. Aber wenn sie so Wikipedia-mäßig, wenn du so einen Sourcecode siehst von unserem Projekt, du gehst da rein, drückst auf den editieren Button. Nicht erst clone, auschecken, machen, tun, wieder hochladen, dann Pull-Request stellen, sondern du gehst auf das File, drückst editieren, änderst da was und sagst, hier guck mal, mein Vorschlag, das mal so zu machen.
Das geht mittlerweile, das haben sie eingeführt.
Auf der Seite direkt, es muss nicht auschecken, nicht clone und nicht irgendwie...
Ich glaube, der clone dir das wahrscheinlich.
Man immer alles so verpasst, wenn man aber auch nicht immer wieder mal nachcheckt.
Ich nutze halt GitHub echt so. Ich hab meine Vorlesung darüber organisiert. Also ich bin nicht so der Freund von PDF Folien. Markdown Flavour, also hier dieses GitHub flavoured Markdown ist ja eh ganz schick, so sehen dann meine Vorlesungen irgendwie immer aus. Und auch jetzt erst wieder, weil ich irgendwie einen Coding-Workshop und die jetzige Vorlesung organisiert hab, das mach ich irgendwie alles über GitHub, weil dann hab ich's auf allen Rechnern. Alle können drauf zugreifen und das sehen. Das ist irgendwie schon ganz cool.
Ja, ist erstaunlich, wie sehr sich das gehalten hat.
Und was ich super cool fand, was sie letztes Jahr im Oktober gemacht haben, hatten sie diese Aktion Hacktober, wo du, wenn du im Oktober vier Pull-Requests oder sowas an irgendeinen Open Source-Projekt gestellt hast und die durchgegangen sind, hast du ein T-Shirt von GitHub bekommen, wie das du am Hacktober teilgenommen hast. Diese typischen Community-Veranstaltungen gibt es ja irgendwie bei vielen Sachen, dass man sich mal einen Monat irgendetwas widmet. Ich fand es ganz cool, dass GitHub das auch so ein bisschen pushen will, um mehr Leute in Open-Source-Projekte reinzubekommen.
Gut, was auch vor zehn Jahren entstanden ist, aber seitdem irgendwie nicht unbedingt so den Weg nach vorne gefunden hat, ist Twitter. Also es ist zwar irgendwie zu dem geworden, was ich mal dachte, was es ist, aber es ist irgendwie alles schlimm. Ich will mal kurz darauf hinweisen, hier auf diese Hashtag breaking my Twitter, gibt es diese kleine Webseite apps of a feather.com. Das ist so ein bisschen die Vereinigung der unabhängigen Twitter-Klients, sprich Tweetbot, Twitterific und andere. Hintergrund ist der, dass Twitter demnächst wohl die Push-Notification-Versorgung, also dieses Stream-Interface für Third-Party-Klients abschalten will. Das wäre natürlich wirklich ein Drama. Also für mich zumindest, weil ich werde Teufel tun und diese offizielle Twitter-App benutzen.
Die habe ich schon sehr lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Ich habe die noch nie gesehen.
Also ich habe die mal kurz gesehen, aber als sie noch nie mehr anschaut. War das Tweety?
Ja, ich glaube.
Ist das die offizielle hier, die einfach Twitter heißt?
Da hatten sie doch den Typen eingekauft.
Und das ist seitdem irgendwie mal schlechter geworden.
Und da ist es dann relativ schnell den Bach runtergegangen.
Und dann haben sie irgendwie noch die Mac-App eingestellt. Und seitdem wird alles ganz schlimm. Und da sie halt auch nur in diesem ganzen Facebook-artigen Revenue-Stream-Wahnsinn sind, sind sie halt bereit, ihr Produkt da zu schlachten. Und es irgendwie immer noch schlimmer ist.
Na, die wissen halt nicht, wie sie da Geld rausziehen sollen, ne? Ja, was ist ja die andere Alternative? Sie machen den Laden dicht, wenn sie es nicht auf die Reihe kriegen, oder?
Ich zahl 10 Dollar im Monat und krieg meinen Abi-Zugang für meinen scheiß Client.
Die können nicht von 10 Dollar leben, weil du das machst und nicht die anderen. Die machen das nicht.
Alle anderen kriegen halt keinen APS-Zugang, sondern ein Verband.
Alle anderen fressen halt die Werbescheiße und Pipa-Po.
Fertig.
Die müssen nicht mal was technisch einführen. Sie müssen es nur nicht ausschalten. Will nicht irgendwas haben, was...
Aber das nutzt wahrscheinlich dann die anderen, die nicht die 10 Dollar zahlen.
Na, wenn sie nicht zahlen, kriegen sie das ja nicht.
Das können sie ja dann gerne einschränken. Aber ich will meinen Client da betreiben, mit einer zeitbasierten Timeline.
Oh ja, keine Vorschläge, keine Werbung, keine...
Da kriegen sie 10 Dollar von mir dafür.
Genau, so wie jetzt wird mit Geld. Nee, das ist ja schon lange nicht mehr so.
Doch, Tweetbot.
Ja, die APIs.
Und Tweetdeck.
Tweetdeck ist auch Twitter.
Ah, aber da ist es nicht unten. Da hast du eine Zeitchronologie.
Das ist richtig geil.
Eis.
Macadamia Nut Breadle.
Könnte man ja auch mal probieren, statt Strawberry Cheesecake.
Ja, ich hab Vanilla Caramel Brownie.
Deswegen machen wir diesen Podcast. Das sind nämlich die einzig wahren Gründe, hierher zu kommen. Und was ist nun weiter? Also du wolltest dich einfach mal über Twitter beschweren. Das ist irgendwie...
Nee, wir sagen jetzt alle, wenn die das zumachen, dann machen wir Twitter zu.
Also ich muss sagen, das wäre ja für mich schon ein garstiger Verlust, den ich irgendwie wirklich nur sehr schwersten Harzens machen würde. Ich habe halt wirklich so überhaupt keinen Bock, aber dann würde ich mich halt wieder nach Alternativen umschauen. Aber denkst du noch mal an die Lebenszeit, die du drückgewinnt hast? Ja, das mag sein. Andererseits muss ich mir dann das, was ich darüber finde, auf anderen Seiten zusammensuchen. Das wird eher anstrengend. Ich wollte auf etwas anderes hinaus. Es gab ja schon mal eine Alternative, die wollte ja dann keinen bezahlen.
Doch, wir haben alle mitgespielt hier.
Was für ein Ding?
Abdotnet.
Ich hab bezahlt.
Ja, also die hätten...
Du stehst nicht nur nicht auf Twitter, sondern bist auch nicht auf Twitter, oder?
Stimmt.
Und schon wieder haben wir einen Sendungstitel.
Ich hoffe, du schreibst sie auch alle auf. Hast du sie aufgeschrieben? Ich hab den anderen schon wieder vergessen.
Lottie sagt Dennis ganz gerne.
Ja, das ist mir egal.
Ja, dafür bin ich ja da. Hast ja von gehört.
Wo waren wir?
Du hast mir gerade gesagt, dass ich viele Follower habe.
Nutze es.
Aber warum? Ich will eben... Genau, wofür? Was soll ich denen erzählen? Also ich will hier nicht der x-te Fashion-Blogger, der x-te ich hab grad das zu Mittag gegessen und ich teile nicht ganz gerne private Dinge.
Wenn du dir meinen Account anschaust, ich twitter auch nicht viel.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber wenn ich twitter, mach ich mir Gedanken darum.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn du twitterst, was du isst, dann bist du deine Follower auch relativ schnell los.
Vielleicht könnt ihr Friedhofsfotos machen.
Wenn die gut genug sind.
Nee, das ist Instagram. Ja, Instagram find ich ja wiederum ganz lustig.
Also ich versuch zumindest immer halbwegs, naja, das stimmt auch nicht immer. Manchmal ist es unterhaltsam, manchmal ist es informativ. Manchmal beziehe ich auch einfach Stellung. Aber ich beziehe nicht Stellung jetzt unbedingt immer durch plakatives Zur-Schaustellen einer Meinung.
Ich find es echt immer wieder so geil, wie die Leute auch drauf einsteigen. Das ist wie so eine Triggertaste. Du weißt genau, wenn du das jetzt schreibst, da springen wieder 100 Socken drauf und versuchen dir das zu erklären. Das ist sehr lustig. Manchmal. Manchmal auch nicht. Toll.
Wenn man drauf steht?
Ja, ich will nur sagen, man kann ja auch Einfluss ausüben.
Vielleicht werde ich das mit diesem Sozialen irgendwann mal merken.
Influenza.
Ich glaube, so soziale Netzwerke sind, ich finde das irgendwie komisch.
Auf jeden Fall, Leute, wenn ihr euch an Twitter benutzt, was liegt und ihr irgendwie mit dem ganzen normalen Twitter-Kram auch nicht klarkommt, also mit diesen Twitter-Klans, dann bitte beteiligt euch in irgendeiner Form an dieser Initiative. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das viel bringt. Immerhin, der erste Backlash hat Twitter schon mal dazu gebracht, das Ganze nach hinzuschieben. Das hilft natürlich herzlich wenig. 19. Juni soll irgendwie vorbei sein mit Twitter. Und das finde ich irgendwie doof.
Das ist okay.
Ich prangere das an.
Ansonsten, lasst euch irgendwas Neues einfallen.
Na ja, aber mal ehrlich, die meisten werden davon gar nichts mitkriegen, weil wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viele mehr diese Third-Party-Apps nutzen und die, die Partys tun, denen ist es wahrscheinlich sogar egal. Und die wechseln dann zu den Alternativen von, also was heißt Alternativen, zu den originalen Twitter.
Es geht nicht um die meisten. Es geht um die meisten Follower. Und wenn Leute, die irgendwie viele Follower haben, da draufballern, dann ist das sicherlich schon mal ganz relevant.
Ich sag ja nur, es wird wahrscheinlich nichts ändern.
Das wollen wir ja mal sehen.
Sei nicht so defetistisch. Auch wenn du vielleicht Recht hast.
Oh, weiter.
Soll ich kurz?
Wir müssen jetzt ja ein bisschen...
Wir sind schon so unheimlich weit in dieser Sendung.
Nee, sind wir gar nicht.
Doch, weil ich muss noch einige Sachen abladen. Ja, eben, genau, drum.
Aber mit den Kleinigkeiten immer.
Ja, na ja, mit den Kleinigkeiten. Aber wir können ja mal, wenn wir es nicht so episch ausufern lassen, mal den Elektromobilitätsteil abspülen.
Okay, der ist auch... Wird nicht so episch. Also ich bin jetzt tatsächlich das alte Auto losgeworden. Und...
Den Haufen.
Den braunen Haufen Blech. Also den loszuwerden, war ja relativ einfach. Der stand ja dann bei Renault ohne Batterie. Und der Restwertaufkäufer hat sich das Ding also abgeholt. Und jetzt war es so, bei dem Auffahrunfall ist das vordere Nummernschild abgebrochen. Samt einigem anderen Plastik. Das hintere blieb natürlich dran, weil mir hinten keiner reingefahren ist. Und deswegen war das immer extra. Und der Renault-Stützpunkt hat also das Auto bekommen und hat extra zu dem Auto also noch ein Nummernschild und ein Sack Kleinteile und zwei Schlüssel bekommen. Was macht dieser Held vom Renault-Stützpunkt? Gibt dem Herrn, dem Spediteur von dem Aufkäufer das Auto mit und die beiden Schlüssel, aber nicht das Nummernschild. Das heißt, der hatte dann ein Auto mit nur einem Nummernschild. Ich hatte ja den Fehler begangen, es nicht selber abzumelden. Und da der nur ein Nummernschild hatte, konnte er das Auto nicht abmelden. Und dann ging die Suche nur los, wo denn das Nummernschild ist. Der Mann von Renault, der ging gar nicht mehr ans Telefon. Da musste ich irgendwie erst in der Zentrale anrufen. Die haben mich dann durchgestellt. Und dann hat der Kleinlaut zugegeben, ja, das hätte er vergessen und das wäre noch hier bei ihm im Schreibtisch. Das hat er dann also tatsächlich irgendwie zu dem Aufkäufer geschickt und der hat tatsächlich gestern das Auto abgemeldet, womit jetzt der letzte Rest an, wie soll ich sagen, Vorgang von dem alten Auto erledigt ist. Und ich bin jetzt wirklich alles los und alles ist gut mit dem alten Auto. Die Versicherung läuft nicht mehr, es ist abgemeldet. Es ist alles super. Und gleichzeitig ist es so, dass ich mich vor 2, 3 Wochen schon um einen Nachfolger gekümmert habe. Der ist inzwischen bezahlt und auch angemeldet. Und den werde ich nächste oder übernächste Woche bekommen. Wird der von irgendeinem Spediteur nach Berlin verbracht.
Das gleiche Auto?
Das gleiche Auto allerdings, naja, nicht ganz. Also die erste Zoe war ja eine Q210. Wer sich ein bisschen auskennt, weiß, 210 bedeutet kleine Akku mit 22 Kilowattstunden und Q bedeutet das, was Renault einen Schnelllader nennt. Und zwar ist es ein Drehstromlader, der aber 43 Kilowatt abkann. So, jetzt hat Renault in der darauf folgenden Modellgeneration zwei Dinge getan. Erstens die Größe des Akkus verdoppelt und zweitens die Ladegeschwindigkeit halbiert.
Was für ein genialer Zug!
Was für ein genialer Schachzug! Aber trotzdem wollte ich dann das Auto mit dem größeren Akku haben, was noch den Nebeneffekt hat, dass es Sitzheizung hat. Nein, er hat halt Sitzheizung. Und wenn du so eine Zoe mal im Winter gefahren bist bei Minusgraden, dann weißt du, dass Sitzheizung vielleicht gar keine so verdammt schlechte ist.
Aber sag mal, mit der heil zu schnell geladen, heil zu schnell von der Zeit bei der neuen Kapazität oder wirklich?
Nein, er kann statt mit 43 Kilowatt nur noch mit 22 Kilowatt laden.
Also ist er tatsächlich gesamt? Die Gesamtladung dauert jetzt viermal so lange. Ich dachte, du hast das vielleicht schon mit reingerechnet mit der...
Ja, naja, die reale, echte Ladezeit ist dann natürlich nicht ganz so lange, weil du hast ja diesen Effekt, dass so ein Akku bei ungefähr 80 Prozent nicht mehr wirklich schnell lädt. Insofern sind die Auswirkungen dann nicht ganz so schlimm. Aber man kommt halt schon von halbe Stunde, 40 Minuten, bis der Akku voll ist, auf halt über eine Stunde. Stunde 15, Stunde 20 oder so, was ich so gelesen habe, keine Ahnung. Ja, ist nicht so schlimm. Vor allen Dingen, weil du nur noch halb so oft laden musst. Aber im Prinzip, ja, es ist irgendwie...
Also hast du jetzt 40 kW oder was?
Warum? Warum? Ich weiß nicht. Warum? Warum? Wahrscheinlich ist es das Gleiche, was Nissan mit dem Leaf gemacht hat. Oder das Problem, das Nissan mit dem Leaf hatte, war, dass im alten Leaf die Akkus relativ schnell kaputtgegangen sind, weil die kein Thermalmanagement hatten. Aber schnell laden. Und deswegen sind denen immer wieder die Akkus zu heiß geworden. Im neuen Leaf ist es so, der hat zwar einen größeren Akku, der ist auch noch mal dichter gepackt. Aber, und sie haben immer noch kein aktives Thermalmanagement, also der Akku wird nicht gekühlt. Aber sie messen sehr genau die Temperatur von dem Akku. Und wenn der zu warm wird, dann lädt er halt einfach langsamer. Was dir passieren kann, dass der Akku halt selbst am CCS-Schnelllader halt dann nur noch mit 25 kW lädt? Ja, ist halt dann so, genau. Und ich glaube, dass das, dass Renault da so ein bisschen die andere Schiene läuft, so nach, da hat ach, diese 43 kW Ladetechnik ist doch alles nur teuer. Das macht doch nur Kosten und so weiter. Und gibt ihm, und dann haben wir jetzt Nebeneffekt, vielleicht auch noch, dass der Akku länger hält. Vielleicht ist der auch dichter gepackt und lässt sich nicht so gut kühlen. Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Was soll jetzt die Reichweite sein von diesen Themen?
250 relativ realistisch. Also sie sagen 400 nach Nefts, aber wir wissen ja alle, Nefts ist ein Hyper-Miling-Standard. Und 60% des Nefts-Wertes ist eine realistische Reichweite.
Insofern da ist es 240. Das ist doch immer eine Frage des Wetters. Weil beim Benziner, was du denkst, was du umsonst kriegst, was du aber immer normalerweise mitbezahlst und die Umwelt bläst, wie zum Beispiel Heizung, wo du halt einfach die Abwärme von deinem Verbrennungsmotor mit benutzt, um deine Bude zu heizen. Und wenn du halt nicht heizt, dann heizt du damit die Umwelt. Das musst du beim Elektro-Dinker extra erzeugen. Weil der Motor macht nicht so viel Abwärme, dass du damit irgendwas heizen könntest. Also musst du bei schlechten Wetter deine Kiste elektrisch heizen.
Und deswegen ist die Sitzheizung sehr gut, weil du nämlich weniger Strom verbrauchst, wenn du nur irgendwie den Arsch und den Rücken anwärmst, statt das ganze Auto. Lenkrad wäre noch gut. Lenkrad wäre noch gut. Haben sie aber nicht im Programm.
Da hab ich sehr von profitiert diesen Winter.
Das mag ich sehr gerne. Hier im Chat ist noch die allerwichtigste, aller Fragen ist, welche Farbe. Ja, gab leider nur schwarz. Also es nennt sich Black Pearl. Schwarz Metallic, was auch immer Schwarz Metallic Black Pearl wirklich bedeutet. Ja, so einen Braun gibt es halt nicht mehr. Das war ein echtes...
Von Cappuccino zu Espresso.
Wie insgesamt in dieser Automobilbranche. Es gibt keine Farben mehr.
Deswegen der Tweet nach Cappuccino, ein Espresso.
Na dann hoffen wir, dass du jetzt ausreichend koffiniert bist. Das Ding hast du jetzt schon?
Kommt nächste oder übernächste Woche. Je nachdem, wie sich der Spediteur da auskäst. Das Ding ist, dass Renault hatte eine Rückrufaktion, wo sie irgendwelche Getriebeteile austauschen. Bei den Autos, die sowieso in der Werkstatt sind. Und dann haben sie gesagt, na ja, dann ist es vielleicht ganz sinnvoll, wenn wir das machen, bevor wir das Auto abgeben. Und deswegen ist es jetzt irgendwie gestern, heute, morgen und und morgen für die Werkstatt vorgesehen. Und soll dann am Freitag, also übermorgen, dem Spediteur übergeben werden oder spätestens Montag. Und wie lange der dann braucht, um das nach Berlin zu schaffen, ist...
Hast du jetzt einen finanziellen Schaden aus der ganzen Affäre herausgezogen?
Also ich glaube, ich habe in Summe länger telefoniert, als ich das Teil tatsächlich gefahren bin. Dadurch, dass der Sachverständige den relativ positiv bewertet hat. Also der hat halt relativ wenig Kilometer drauf. Was aber auch so bei so einer Sohe mit einem kleinen Akku echt schwierig ist, da viele Kilometer drauf zu machen. Also der hatte halt, wie war das? In drei Jahren hatte der 35.000 draufgefahren. Also für so ein Auto, mit dem du nicht wirklich realistisch lang Strecke fahren kannst, sondern du hast halt, wenn du halt 50 Kilometer Arbeitsweg hast, also Roundtrip, und machst das an 200 Arbeitstagen, dann bist du halt bei 10.000 Kilometer, fährst noch ein paar mehr und dann bist du halt bei 12.000 im Jahr. Und das ist halt das, was dann so ein Auto hat. Aber wenn der Sachverständige in seine Liste guckt, wo halt auch Autos dabei sind, wo die Leute irgendwie im Sommer nach Italien und im Winter nach Schweden fahren, und dann hast du halt mehr auf dem Auto drauf.
Ja, ich hab jetzt fast 18.000 runter, nach fast einem Jahr. Mit 3.000 Kilometer Schweden rumfahren im Sommer. Ich hab jetzt nicht die 20.000... Ich hab so 20.000 geschätzt, aber war jetzt doch weniger unterwegs in Europa.
Weißt du, ich mach so zwischen 15 und 20 mit Motorrad.
Du bist aber auch ein Fernbeziehungskollege, oder? Also von daher...
Also ich hab für das von der Versicherung ungefähr 2.500 mehr bekommen, als ich bezahlt hab. Insofern hab ich keinen Verlust gemacht. Außer den ganzen Nerv.
Bitte das mitzulesen.
Das war ein Intensivkurs Verkehrsrecht, ja.
Murphy hat ganze Arbeit geleistet. Das Motto, was schief gehen kann, hat er ausprobiert.
Es ging im Prinzip alles schief, was schief gehen konnte. Das stimmt. Mir selber ist ja nichts passiert. Insofern will ich da jetzt auch nicht jammern. Aber es war schon sehr interessant, eine echte Journey. Schon allein das Auto von München hier hoch zu fahren, war ja schon eine interessante Erfahrung. Deswegen mach ich es auch nicht nochmal. Ich hab das jetzt durch.
Und der ist jetzt so richtig neu?
Neu?
Nein, also der Händler hatte das Ding angemeldet und hatte es ein Jahr lang als Vorführwagen. Insofern bin ich quasi der Erstbesitzer, aber es ist kein Neuwagen im Sinne des Gesetzes, sondern der war halt schon zugelassen.
Aber kriegt er einen neuen Akku, von daher ist er neu.
Ja, er hat schon ein paar Kilometer runter.
Ja, aber vor einem Jahr gab es doch diesen Akku noch.
Ja, das ist der mit dem neuen Akku, mit dem größeren Akku, mit der Sitzheizung.
Aktuelles Modell.
Nicht ganz, also es gibt jetzt das noch aktuellere Modell. Mit Lenkradheizung. Nein, sondern es gibt jetzt die Variante mit dem stärkeren Motor. Also statt, dass sie ein stärkeres Lade-Ding einbauen, haben sie jetzt den stärkeren Motor. Okay, ich meine, die alte Soi macht halt 12 Sekunden von 0 auf 100 und die neue glaube ich 8 oder so. Ob es das jetzt so gebracht hat?
Ich glaube schon.
Keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall. Ach ja, und die neue Variante gibt es in einem neuen Farbton, nämlich lila metallic. Da war ich dann schon auch versucht, weil das ist schon sehr abgefahren.
Das hätte gut zum Braun gepasst.
Aber die Lieferzeit ist halt irgendwie auch ein halbes Jahr. Also momentan kriegst du ja außer bei Tesla und bei BMW kein Auto unter drei Monate. Also Golf ist angeblich die ganze Produktion von 2018 schon abverkauft.
Für Model 3.
Die anderen Dinger kriegst du relativ zügig.
Ja, in sechs Wochen, zwei Monaten spätestens. Beim BMW i3 angeblich auch nur sechs Wochen. Merkst du, dass der vielleicht auch zu teuer ist? Und alle anderen, also Ioniq gibt es so gut wie gar nicht. E-Golf haben sie wie gesagt angeblich schon die gesamte Produktion von 2018 abverkauft. Den kannst du nicht bestellen.
Alle zehn.
Na ja, es sind schon ein paar mehr. Aber ja, weiß nicht. Also irgendwie werden alle überrascht. Kunde droht mit Auftrag. Also das ist irgendwie...
Ja, das möchten die auch nicht. Das merkst du auch irgendwie. Jetzt ich zum Thema E-Mobilität. Vor einiger Zeit habe ich mal Anfang des Jahres oder sowas einen von meinen provokanten Tweets rausgehauen, dass er sagte, ich will jetzt mal eine Änderung der Ladesäulenverordnung haben. Nämlich die Verordnung über technische Mindestanforderungen an den sicheren und interoperablen Aufbau und Betrieb von öffentlich zugänglichen Ladepunkten für Elektromobile. Was war das jetzt? Das ist die Ladesäulenverordnung. Das ist der offizielle Titel der Ladesäulenverordnung.
Wolltest du das nochmal sagen?
Verordnung über technische Mindestanforderungen an den sicheren und interoperablen Aufbau und Betrieb von öffentlich zugänglichen Ladepunkten für Elektromobile. Fantastisch. Ich hab das damals eher als Witz gesagt, weil mich das mal wieder geärgert hat, dass da so eine Ladesäule zwar voll bestrumpft war, aber wieder mal jemand an der Windows-Software von dem Server für dieses Ding rumgedaddelt hat oder was auch immer, jedenfalls diese Ladesäule, einfach mal wieder keinen Strom ausrücken wollte. Und ich hab mir jetzt überlegt, ich schreib jetzt dieses Wochenende echt eine Petition. Mir geht das so total auf die Eier. Weil diese Dinge haben in der Regel immer Strom. Du guckst da drauf, die leuchten nicht fröhlich an und das kommt nicht aus dem Akku, sondern das heißt, die haben Netz. Und die Anzeige sagte, nö, ich hab grad keinen Bock.
Hast du gerade gesagt, du hast da eine Petition geschrieben?
Nein, ich schreib eine. Ich schreib jetzt am Wochenende eine. Hab ich mir jetzt fest vorgenommen. Weil ich hab jetzt auch hier schon wieder, da vorne, das Ding steht schon wieder auf, ich kann nicht. Und dann ist da eine Hotline-Nummer angegeben, dann rufst du da an und dann sagt die Frau, ja, die ist ja auf, die Säule steht ja auf, ich kann grad nicht. Das heißt, ihr System hatte schon längst gesehen und sie dann so, ja, da muss ich mal jetzt der Technik-Bescheid sagen.
Und lass mich raten, du bist dahin, weil online angezeigt wird, dass es geht. Also aus ihrer Datenbank kommt...
Ach, da sind wir ja noch gar nicht. Dass es ein online Ding gibt, da hab ich auch schon, kann ich jetzt auch mal öffentlich sagen, ich hab jetzt mal so ein paar Googler da angeschoben, weil ich ein paar von diesen Google-Management-Freaks aus dem ITF-Umfeld kenne. Weil es gibt zwar jede Menge lustige Apps und Webseiten, die dir die Dinger machen, aber die zeigen dir immer nur einen Teil. Und der Einzige, der sozusagen richtig den Marktbumms hat, sowas weltweit zu machen, was sie ja übrigens auch schon für Benzintankstellen machen in manchen Ländern, dass sie dir live in den Google Maps anzeigen, was der Sprit gerade kostet und so. Also das heißt, da gibt's APIs. Und die einzige Bude, die sowas kann, kann sicher und eine geile API definieren und sagen, und auch den Marktbumms hat, das ist halt Google. So, deswegen versuch ich, die mal so anzuspitzen, dass sie damit jetzt mal aus dem Kniff kommen, dass man die mal sieht in Google Maps, ob die da sind oder nicht. Aber was mir, wie gesagt, auf den Sack geht, ist, dass diese Dinger, nur weil sie ihre IT kaputt spielen, nicht weil da etwa die Sicherung oder der Wattenfall da keinen Strom reingemacht hat unten oder so weit, sondern weil sie ihre Drecks-IT kaputt spielen oder ihre U2-Gebühren nicht bezahlen für die SIM-Karten, die in den Dingern drinstecken oder was weiß ich. Dass diese Dinger immer sagen, ich kapte hier zwar jede Menge Strom, aber ich gebe dir keinen.
Ich sehe das schon so richtig, wie der Techniker da kommt und seinen Bildschirm anschließt und dann steht das Ding so auf C-Größe und muss einfach nur Run eintippen.
Ja, ist es mir scheißegal. Ich schlage ernsthaft vor, C-Größe, Load, Load. Ich schlage ernsthaft eine Änderung dieser Ladesäulenverordnung vor, die da lauten soll, das Ding hat Strom abzugeben. Du darfst ihn gerne abrechnen, aber wenn dein Abrechnungsmechanismus gerade nicht funktioniert, dann ist der Strom umsonst.
Das ist so ein bisschen so wie wenn dein Telefon, dein Tarif leer ist, dann kannst du immer noch 110 anrufen. So sollten sie das machen. Wenn es nicht geht, dann Strom kommt immer. Vielleicht ein bisschen langsamer oder so, aber...
Da kommt, Punkt Ende aus, da kommt Strom raus.
Und wenn sie den abrechnen, dann sollen sie das tun. Sie können auch gerne, wenn ihre scheiße O2-Sim abgelaufen ist, oder was auch immer, ihr Sim, dann sollen sie das irgendwie abspeichern und mehr ein Monat später chargern. Ist mir scheißegal, aber da kommt Strom raus. Wir sind jetzt aus dieser Spielphase raus. Wir sind jetzt ernsthaft aus dieser Nummer raus. Wir stellen mal eine Säule hin und probieren mal so ein bisschen an der Software aus, ob man da was machen kann oder so was. Das ist jetzt öffentliche... Es ist jetzt öffentliche Ladeinfrastruktur. Deswegen eben auch der Bezug von öffentlich zugänglichen Ladepunkten. Wenn die gerne auf privaten Parkplätzen spielen wollen, mit Sonnenlocken, wie Tesla das zum Beispiel macht, mit ihren Superchargern, an denen nur Tesla das funktioniert, ist mir das alles recht. Aber wenn die Leute öffentliches Straßenland dafür gebrauchen, missbrauchen, um ihren IT-Dreck dahin zu stellen, dann wäre ich langsam fruchtig. Das heißt, die sollten wirklich hingehen und sagen, ernsthaft, da kommt immer... Weil das ist öffentliche Infrastruktur. Da kommt Strom raus und wer den abbrechen könnte, gut. Wer den nicht abbrechen könnte, hat da mit Zitronen gehandelt.
Jetzt muss ich dich aber bei deinem Rant mal einfangen, weil du nämlich, du unterstellst jetzt, dass diese Säule keinen Strom abgibt, weil die Abrechnungsinfrastruktur nicht funktioniert. Die Säule macht aber natürlich noch mehr als nur Abrechnen. Sondern die stellt ja auch eine elektrische Sicherheit im Sinne von Safety her. Und außerdem, sowohl die Plug-Surfing-App als auch die New-Motion-App zeigen beide die Ladesäule als nicht in Betrieb an. Ja gut, ich hab vorhin nicht geguckt, das ist natürlich richtig.
Was ich von außen sehe, ist, das Ding hat Strom. Und deswegen soll es mir den geben.
Ja, da ist Licht an.
Ja, das heißt, das hat Strom. Dieses Licht in dem Ding kommt nicht aus irgendeinem Akku. Sondern da kommt von unten, von Wattenfall, vom Stadtstrom, kommt da Strom in das Ding rein und den will ich haben.
Es kann aber durchaus sein, dass irgendeine Sicherung geflogen ist.
Auf beiden Seiten gleichzeitig?
Wie auf beiden Seiten?
Da sind ja zwei Seiten dran an dem Ding. Wenn da eine Sicherung geflogen wäre, wäre auch Licht aus in dem Ding. Nein, das ist ja da. Du redest ja mit mir. Ich kann auch meinen Plugsurfing-Dongel davor halten. Und dann dachte du so, denk, denk, denk. Nö, ich hab jetzt doch keine Lust. Und es sagt auch nicht im Display, oh, hier ist eine Sicherung geflogen. Oder sonst und was.
Deine Argumentation zieht, finde ich, nicht so richtig. Nur weil da Licht an ist, heißt noch lange nicht, dass die Säule tatsächlich in der Lage ist, technisch Strom abzugeben.
Dann soll sie das sagen. Was ich bloß erlebe, sehr, sehr häufig ist, dass diese Dinger dann nicht gehen. Dann rufst du da an und dann treten die dagegen. Das dauert dann zwar 10 Minuten oder sowas, weil das ist ja alles IT, nagelneue IT.
Ja, die booten die dann neu und dann geht's wieder, ne?
Ne, trotzdem, 10 Minuten. Im Jahre 2018, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Und dann geht das wieder. Deswegen kann mir ja keiner erzählen, oh, das ist jetzt eine von den drei Phasen, ist jetzt die Hauptsicherung geknallt oder sonst was. Das kann man übrigens auch hinschreiben im Display. Da muss man jetzt nicht irgendwelche dummen Sprüche machen. Und ich erlebe das halt sehr, sehr häufig, dass da irgendwelche Abrechnungssachen nicht funktionieren. Insbesondere zum Beispiel bei der Umstellung. Gab ja diese Dinger bei Tank und Rast, die da rumstehen, draußen, die waren ja so komplett ohne. Dann liefen sie ein paar Tage lang nicht in Vorbereitung auf, wir wollen jetzt dafür Geld haben. Dann haben sie endlich die Software in den Griff gekriegt, nehmen immer noch kein Geld. Darüber möchte ich mich jetzt nicht beschweren. Aber vom Prinzip diese Drumgewurstel an dem IT-Teil von diesen Dingern geht mir total auf den Keks. Das können sie auch gerne weitermachen, solange ich meinen Strom kriege. Und alle anderen auch. Das ist jetzt öffentliche Ladeinfrastruktur. Das steht auf öffentlichem Grund. Die sollen jetzt mit ihrem Windows gebastelt oder was auch immer die dafür scheiße machen, ist mir vollkommen wurscht. Damit sollen die aufhören. Die einzige Möglichkeit, sie dazu zu kriegen, ist nicht über, oh jetzt kriegst du aber vom Ordnungsamt ein Zettel, wenn das Ding nicht läuft, sondern ist dafür, dass es dir einfach Geld kostet. Das heißt, wenn der IT-Kram nicht funktioniert, tanken oder laden da Leute für umsonst. Du sollst mal glauben, wenn das so wäre, wie schnell die ihren IT-Quatsch auf die Reihe kriegen.
Also ich glaube, dass die für den Strom im Einkauf sowieso kaum was bezahlen. Ob die den Strom umsonst abgeben oder nicht, ist nicht entscheidend, sondern entscheidend ist, ob die ihre Investition, dieses Teil da aufzustellen, wieder rein kriegen.
Die kriegen sie dann rein, wenn sie ihre Abrechnungskiste in Ordnung halten.
Ich sehe das so ein bisschen wie S-Bahn. Wenn die S-Bahn hier nicht pünktlich fährt, dann kostet sie das richtig Geld.
Geld.
Wenn die S-Bahn in Berlin nicht pünktlich fährt, zahlt die Bahn dafür Strafe an die Stadt Berlin.
Tut sie das?
Ja, aber natürlich tut sie das. Deswegen hat Ostkreuz der Nahverkehrsbahnhof jetzt ein Dach. Das haben die daraus finanziert. Und nicht zu knapp. Während dieser ganzen Phase in den letzten Jahren, wo die S-Bahn so vollkommen eingebrochen ist, weil sie es so runtergewirtschaftet haben, weil Medorn die Bahn mal aktienfähig machen wollte, das hat die Millionen gekostet. Und genauso sehe ich das auch mit dieser öffentlichen Infrastruktur. Ich meine, was ist denn bitte, wenn die Straßenlaternen irgendwie zehn Tage lang nicht brennen? Was ist denn, wenn dann DSL-Anschluss dieselbe Zuverlässigkeit hat wie so eine Ladesäule?
In der Sache gebe ich dir natürlich recht.
Das wäre wohl auch noch schöner.
Es muss eine Möglichkeit geben...
Dann würdest du hier direkt rausfliegen.
Es muss eine Möglichkeit geben, denen auf die Finger zu klopfen, wenn die öffentliche Ladeinfrastruktur, die ja auch noch subventioniert wurde, ich glaube im Fall dieser Bi-E-Mobil-Säulen...
Die müssen beweisen, dass sie funktionieren. So rum wird alles gut.
Kann man auch machen, aber muss sie halt eben Geld kosten. Du kannst nicht sagen, wenn so ein Ding kaputt geht, du kannst darauf hoffen, dass ein ordentlicher Mitarbeiter vorbeikommt und denen ein Zettel an das Ding dran klebt.
Deswegen meine ich beweisen, wenn sie es nicht beweisen können, dann kannst du ihnen auch nicht beweisen, dass sie es nicht machen. Weißt ja nicht, dass es nicht geht und wie lange nicht.
Ich habe neulich einen i3 ausgeniehen und ich mache das ja so, dass ich mir gerne einen aussuche, der schon so nahe der 25% Ladezustand ist, damit wenn ich ihn dann abgebe, ihn an einer Säule abgeben kann und meine 30 Freiminuten bekomme.
Du bist einer dieser Penner, die diese Dinger dann da tagelang stehen lassen, ja?
Tagelang stehen lässt sie ja, lässt sie ja, ähm...
Muss er ja, er lädt ja so langsam.
Lässt er ja der Betreiber. Nee, so lange laden die nicht. Die laden zwei, drei Stunden vielleicht. Ja, und dann habe ich das Ding da angestöpselt und dann fing er an zu laden und brach nach drei oder vier Sekunden ab. Und ich so, oh nee, na gut, egal. Bin dann weg und habe natürlich auch keine 30 Freiminuten bekommen. Da habe ich irgendwie dreimal angemeckert. Und dann haben sie mir die dann doch gut geschrieben. Also irgendwie...
Ja, weil jetzt keine Ahnung, weißt man jetzt nicht, warum der abbricht. Aber mir geht das wie gesagt total auf den Sack. Die basteln an dieser Software rum. Du siehst das bei manchen Leuten bei den Tank- und Rastsohlen. Siehst du das, weil sie nämlich andere Bildschirme, Zeugs daran haben, aber die haben ja so einen Touch-Bildschirm, viele von den Dingern. Also gerade die fetten Dinger. Und da siehst du, da machen die andere Icons hin oder ganz andere User-Interfaces oder sonst irgendwas. Und jedes Mal im Umfeld von dieser Bastel und Fummelei gehen diese Dinger nicht. Aber eben nicht so, dass die jetzt keinen Strom hätten. Sondern der sagt mir vielleicht, ja, aber ich kann grad nicht mit meinem Abrechnungs-Server reden und deswegen geh weg mit deinem Dongle. Das war's jetzt. Und das find ich einfach zäh groß.
Vor allen Dingen, die müssen ja nicht online abrechnen.
Nee, müssen sie nicht.
Ich hab ja hier auch irgendwie so eine Abrechnung von so einer Ladesäule, die kam irgendwie einen Monat später. Okay, ein bisschen traurig, dass ich nicht sagen konnte, wo eigentlich die Säule ist.
Ist ohnehin schwierig rauszufinden, was du überhaupt geladen hast.
Standort nicht verfügbar.
Monat.
Ja, ungefähr.
Und es ist übrigens irre schwierig, rauszufinden, wie viel du eigentlich geladen hast. Lächerlich. Weil die Autos zeigen es dir nicht an, weil ich echt peinlich finde. So für Tesla, der zeigt mir alle Möche an, aber zeigt mir nicht, wie viel Kilowattstunde ich aus einer Ladesäule gezogen habe.
Also, meine PlugSurfing-App zeigt das aber an. Also hier 15 Kilowattstunden, 19 Kilowattstunden, 16 Kilowattstunden.
Aber die Säule zeigt es dir irgendwo an. Wenn du zum Beispiel an einer Wattenfall-Säule bist, ist das total toll. Die blinkt dann immer rum mit so einem Smiley und dann nach ein paar Sekunden steht kurz da, was gerade geladen wird. Aber wenn du auch nur irgendwie dein Auto oder dein Ladekabel anfasst, dann wird das beendet und diese Anzeige taucht die wieder auf. Das heißt, du siehst dann, wenn du nicht ganz bevor du überhaupt in die Nähe deines Autos gehst, dich mal hinstellst und wartest, bis der Smiley kurz weg blinkt, um dann drauf zu schauen, wie viel das Ding gerade schon geladen hat.
Wenn man telefoniert und man will dann mal in das Gespräch gucken, wie lange das Gespräch jetzt gedauert hat, dann ist es für so eine Sekunde ist noch diese Zeit da, wie lange es war, und dann klickt es weg, weil der andere aufgelegt hat.
Okay, das kannst du noch in der Anruf-Statistik nachschauen, wie lange das war. Und natürlich, wenn du eine Abrechnung kriegst, steht das doch irgendwann vielleicht drauf. Aber das ist diese ganze Geschichte, wir hatten ja schon ein paar Mal hier als Thema, das ist halt einfach die Ladeinfrastruktur. Was Otto Normalbürger zu dem Thema glaubt, ist, dass es nicht genug von den Säulen gibt. Derzeit gibt es noch genug von den Säulen. Also ich hab jetzt kein Problem damit, so ein Ding zu finden, oder auch eine Freie zu finden. Aber diese Gewurschteln mit der Abrechnung, die sind ja sowas auf die Ketten. Ja, da muss man jetzt einfach mal der Gesetzgeber reintreten, sonst wird das nix. Sonst wird das immer schlimmer.
Ich find halt auch, wie du das beschreibst, ist halt ganz klar, wo es hingehen soll. Man merkt halt, dass dieses Interesse irgendwie nicht da ist, dass es mit der Eben-Mobilität vorwärts geht. Also genau an solchen Sachen sieht man das ja irgendwie, da wird sich nicht rumgeschert, dass man zum Laden kommt. Weil ich mein, du hast im Zweifelsfall ein Auto, was da steht und du nicht mehr wegbekommst. Wenn es mal zu spät wäre.
Aufgrund meiner Erfahrung mach ich das halt nicht. Ich fahr halt das Ding nicht runter auf 10 Kilometer Batterie-Restlaufzeit. Ich fahre ein, so und die außen nach Hause. Oder Tesla Supercharger, die seh ich ja auch auf der Karte, ob die gehen oder nicht und wie voll die sind. Aber jetzt hier in der Stadt mich drauf zu verlassen, das ist ja, oh, jetzt mit den 10 Kilometer fährst du noch zu Rewe aufm Park. Da stehen wieder zwei i3s, die irgendjemand abgegeben hat vor zwei Tagen. Und die jetzt immer noch stehen, die Ladesäule blockieren. Da hab ich mir schon überlegt, ob ich mir einfach mal so ein Account hole, bei diesen Carsharing-Buden nur, damit ich die Scheiß-Stecker rausziehen kann. Nee, damit ich Scheiß-Stecker ziehen kann. Aber, ähm...
Das sollte sich eigentlich eh frei geben von alleine, wenn voll ist oder irgendwie so.
Nee, die Dinger sind ja verriegelt, damit dir keiner Kabel klaut. Selbst wenn er nicht mehr lädt.
Aber ich glaube, das kann sein, dass die Säule dann entriegelt.
Na so wär's aber eigentlich praktisch.
Wo postest du denn dann deine geile Petition hin?
Da gibt's doch hier so eine Online-Petition beim Bundestag.
Ja, wo postest du es hin? Wo gibst du es bekannt? Weil die Sendung hält ja nicht so lange, bis du fertig bist.
Keine Ahnung, schreiben wir hier oder schreibt ein Tweet oder irgendwas?
Wenn es Twitter dann noch gibt, dann schreiben wir ein Tweet.
Wir werden es auf Twitter verkünden.
Ansonsten schicken wir Brieftauben.
Ihr hier nicht die Hörer, aber ich bitte jetzt nicht um Retweets, aber meine Freak Show-Kollegen dürfen das dann retweeten.
Ich werde das retweeten.
Ja, ich auch. Dennis auch.
Ich werde mit dir noch ein paar Brenner kaufen, nur damit du das wirst, ja.
Ich habe noch ein Thema. Das ist jetzt kein Rent, sondern wieder mal was Interessantes. In den letzten Monaten sprießen ja öffentliche Resolver aus dem Boden, wenn man jetzt nicht weiß, wovon ich rede. DNS-Resolver sind so Systeme im Internet, wo man seinen Rechner drauf zeigen lassen kann, die aus einem Namen eine Adresse machen, was für Internetnutzung eine unglaublich wichtige Funktion ist. Leute, die sich darum nicht kümmern, die kriegen normalerweise von ihrer Fritzbox einen Resolver zugewiesen oder von ihrem auch immer wie gearteten Plastirouter. Das ist dann der selbige Plastirouter als Resolver. Also Resolver ist die Funktion, die jetzt krass aus einem Namen eine Adresse macht und aus einer Adresse einen Namen. Der Plastirouter benutzt in der Regel selber wieder die Nameserver des ISPs, den man hat. Also zum Beispiel einen Telekom-Anschluss, die von einer Telekom. Das hat diverse Nachteile. Diese Dinger werden sehr häufig stiefmütterlich gepflegt oder der ISP macht irgendeinen Blödsinn damit. Zum Beispiel die Telekom macht immer tolle Sachen mit ihrem Resolver. Wenn du da welche Domain-Namen einen tippst, die es nicht gibt, dann redirecten die dich auf eine Suchseite in ihrem tollen T-Online-Portal.
Ja und nicht ohne Werbung.
Das ist eine furchtbare Seite.
Das kann man im Übrigen auch abstellen, wenn man nur mal als Tipp, man kann dann hingehen und sich in seinen Telekom-Account, in seinen T-Online-Account einloggen und sagen, liebe Telekom, hör mal auf mit dem Dreck. Nichtsdestotrotz, also die ISPs machen da was mit. Es ist auch bekannt, dass diese Daten auch auswerten, wenn vielleicht auch nur statistisch. Andere gucken vielleicht je nach Land und Leute und was sie so dürfen oder wo sie sich nicht bei erwischt fühlen, auch darauf, welcher User nach welchen Domain-Namen fragt und so weiter und so fort. Und manchmal sind die auch einfach stur und dumm und langsam oder haben irgendwelche Filter drauf oder so. Deswegen gibt es schon seit etlichen Jahren öffentliche Resolver. Davon gibt es wahnsinnig bekannte. Nämlich zum Beispiel den von Google mit der leicht zu merkenden IPv4-Adresse 8.8.8.8 oder 8.8.4.4 als zweiten davon. Den kennen vielleicht viele Nerds und geben den auch manchmal ein. Hat aber auch wieder so ein bisschen Schmäckle bei manchen Leuten, weil sie sagen, ok, jetzt gebe ich nicht meinem ISP die Information, wo ich hin surfe. Also jedenfalls nicht so direkt wie mit meiner DNS-Abfrage, sondern jetzt drücke ich es auch nach dem Google in die Hand. Und wie dem auch sein. Es gab und gibt natürlich auch diverse andere Open Resolver, also sozusagen öffentlich nutzbare Resolver. Allen voran darf ich durch mal nennen, vielleicht nicht empfehlen, aber nennen, den von meinen Kollegen von Hurricane Electric, die ich ja sowieso immer gerne mal so mal feature. 74, 82, 42, 42. Es ist nicht so leicht zu merken wie 8.8.8.8. Aber es gibt auch ganze Listen davon. Vielleicht können wir die auch mal zusammenstellen. Oder ich stelle mal eine zusammen und poste die mal irgendwo hin. Und im letzten Herbst während der IETF in Singapur, im November gab es schon jemand, der hat angefangen 9.9.9.9 zu machen. Da steckt unter anderem IBM dahinter und ein paar andere Leute, ein paar andere ambitionierte Leute, dass man mal eine Alternative hat. 9.9.9.9 hat noch einen extra Feature, dass sie nämlich bei Benutzung dieser Reserveradresse Webseiten ausblenden, die bekannt sind, dass sie Malware ausliefern. Also so ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen Malware Schutz, aber so ein bisschen, naja, also wenn sie einen Adapth haben, der eine Webseite betreibt, wo halt nur Dreck drauf ist oder so, dann sieht man den nicht per 9.9.9.9. Für die Leute, die es nicht mögen, die das gerne ungefiltert haben wollen, empfehle ich dann 9.9.9.10 als Alternative.
Die haben das nämlich nicht mit dem, genau.
Wer da genaueres zu wissen will, wie der 9.9.9. funktioniert, die Webseite dazu heißt quad9.net. Da kann man mal drauf lesen, was die so machen. Übrigens, für all diese Dinger gibt es auch 4.6-Adressen. Die sind nicht ganz so leicht zu merken, weil es ist sehr, sehr schwer, in der 4.6-Welt so einfache Zahlen-Kombinationen zusammenzukriegen. Weil die Dinger sind eben eher auch länger. Und wie gesagt, auf quad9.net kann man gucken, die bieten so ein Set an von verschiedenen Nameservern unter verschiedenen Adressen oder Resolvern, die halt verschiedene Qualitäten haben. Und auch IPv6 übrigens. Google hat auch schon länger IPv6. Google hat sogar für Leute, die damit experimentieren wollen, einen DNS64-Resolver. Das heißt, der ist einer, den man benutzen kann, wenn man IPv6-Only-Netz hat oder betreibt, um mit DNS64, NAT64 auch IPv4-Seiten zu erreichen. Nur so als Tipp für die Nerds. Neuer heißer Scheiß, seit 1. April, und das war kein April-Scherz, 1.1.1.1 mit der alternativen Adresse, die ich viel cooler finde, 1.0.0.1.
Weil, die kann man natürlich abkürzen? Doch?
Nee, kannst du nicht im V4.
Er meint, hier kann man auch pingen, indem man ping 1.1 macht. Hab's hier getestet und es geht.
Ja, je nachdem, was du jetzt gerade für ein Ping und für eine Library hast. Aber was viel cooler ist... Die Webseite dazu heißt https://1.1.1.1 Find ich sehr lustig. Wenn du mal oben guckst da, Tim, deinem Browser da oben, das ist die. Das ist ein sehr interessantes Zertifikat. Hatte ich auch getwittert. Können wir vielleicht auch gerne nochmal drüber diskutieren. Egal. Ja, 1.0.0.1 ist die zweite mögliche legale IPv4 Unicast-Adresse. Die erste wäre 1.0.0.1. Also IP-Adresse, IPv4-Adresse, die mit 0 anfangen vorne, gibt es qua Definition nämlich nicht als Unicast-Adresse im Internet. Und die erste mögliche IP-Adresse, die es im Internet, im öffentlichen IPv4-Internet geben könnte, wäre 1.0.0.0. Das haben sie aus verschiedenen Gründen nicht genommen, weil da, nicht weil das nicht ginge, sondern weil halt, keine Ahnung, da irgendwelche düsseligen Filter überall drauf sitzen. Aber 1.0.0.1. Ja, was aber Blödsinn ist, weil du hast ja keine Ahnung, wie das Netz hinten aufgeteilt ist. Es gab auch Leute, die haben versucht, mit mir auf Twitter zu diskutieren, wie kommst du darauf, dass hinten das 0 die Netzadresse ist? Du weißt ja nicht, wie groß das Netz ist. Vielleicht ist es ja ein Slash 32 und dann kannst du diese Adresse benutzen. Oder ein Slash 31, die untere Hälfte vom Slash 31, kannst du das auch benutzen. Der interessante Teil dabei ist, da stecken jetzt wieder größere Organisationen dahinter. Nämlich dieses Mal Cloudflare. Cloudflare ist einer der größten Anbieter und auch einer der Institutionen im Internet, die am meisten peern mit all möglichen Leuten. Ich glaube wirklich der Peering-Weltmeister. Das ist eine Firma, die du normalerweise anheuerst, um deine eigene Webseite vor Leuten zu schützen, die dich zukacken wollen. Das ist immer das Problem, wenn du jetzt im Webshop klickst beim Hetzner, dann hast du eine VM da, vielleicht mit einem Gigabit, aber ein Gigabit ist ja nichts. Das hat in manchen Ländern jeder zu Hause. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt eine Mail kriegst, mit wie schönem Webshop haben sie da, wäre doch schade, wenn der morgen um 12 zugekackt wäre, dann hast du in der Regel irgendwie ein Problem. Und Cloudflare, ohne dass ich jetzt dafür Werbung machen möchte, ist einer von den Anbietern, an die du dich dann wenden kannst, um dich vor solchen Dingen zu schützen. Das heißt, der Verkehr läuft dann nicht direkt aus dem großen, bösen Internet, von den ganzen gehackten Windows-Maschinen auf deinen Server, sondern läuft einmal durch Cloudflare durch. Und die haben so viel Bandbreite. Ja, die haben verschiedene Sachen, diese anbieten. Aber in der Regel ist es halt eben so diese Performance-Optimierung, aber eben auch so den Schutz vor solchen Zeugs.
Und die Leute auch schützen wollen lassen, ihre Daten nicht einfach so wegscraped. Marine Traffic hat nämlich mittlerweile Cloudflare. Das hat es ein bisschen schwierig gemacht, da die Daten jetzt rauszuprökeln.
Ja, also Cloudflare ist wie gesagt, den man sich davor schaltet, vor seiner Webseite, damit er einen beschützt. Und die haben entsprechend Bums. Wie gesagt, sie sind der Peering-Weltmeister. Das heißt, die haben ihre Zeugs weltweit zu stehen, ihre Infrastruktur weltweit zu stehen. Mit ordentlichen Uplinks. Und wenn man jetzt auf dieser Infrastruktur, die sie eh schon haben, da so ein 1.1. hinbaut als Anycast-Adresse, dann hat der in der Regel eine relativ gute Konnektivität. Auch die bieten wieder ein Special-Feature an. Es gibt neuen heißen Scheiß aus der ITF-Richtung, nämlich auch von meinem liebten Kollegen Warren Kumari, der das mit angestoßen hat dort. Nämlich mal DNS-Verkehr auch zu verschlüsseln. Es gibt ja schon seit Jahren DNS-Geschichten, die sich so mit DNS-Sack befassen, dass also DNS nicht so verfälscht wird. Aber in der Regel findet DNS, gerade Reserver-Verkehr, offen statt, unverschlüsselt. Das heißt, jeder, der den Treffig sieht, insbesondere zum Beispiel dein ASP oder wie auch immer, kann sehen, auf welchen Seiten du rumklickst. Weil jede Webseite, jeden Namen, den du benutzt, egal ob für eine Webseite oder für einen anderen Dienst, der macht eine DNS-Auflösung und das heißt, man sieht die. Und der Cloudflare, jetzt mein mal verlagert, sagen wir so, jetzt gibt es halt DNS über TLS. Also man kann also verschlüsselt DNS-Abfragen machen, der 1.1.1.1 supportet das, ich glaube Google auch, der 9.9.9 glaube ich noch nicht.
Kann mein Rechner das denn?
Es gibt so Anleitungen, so Bastel-Anleitungen dafür. Es ist noch nicht native, dass der Apple dir das erlaubt, über Netzwerk-Control-Panel zu machen, aber es gibt so Bastel-Anleitungen.
Also ich muss mir so ein Manage-Mittel auf meinem Rechner installieren, der dann verschlüsselt mit denen redet und ich stelle meinen auf diesen Manage-Mittel rein, verstehe.
Aber die Leute von Apple sind ja auch auf den ITFs und ich kenne die auch. Wir hatten zum Beispiel Stuart Czesar ein paar Mal hier auch in der Sendung schon mal erwähnt. Die spielen da auch mittelfristig mit. Das heißt, das ist jetzt der neue heiße Scheiß, mal DNS über TLS zu machen.
Okay, aber hier in deren Werbespruch steht hier, da steht Quot jetzt, ehrlich gesagt, uns interessiert nicht, was sie im Internet tun, und es geht uns auch nichts an. Wir haben die technischen Schritte unternommen, um sicherzustellen, dass wir es nicht können. Ja, aber ich meine, die sind ja der Endpunkt. Die sehen noch immer, was ich von denen absage.
Das ist jetzt das Problem. Du verheimlichst das jetzt deinem ISP und dafür sagst du jetzt dem Cloudflare. Ist deswegen für uns Europäer oder gerade wir Sicherheitsfanatischen Deutschen ist das wieder so ein Thema?
Ich meine, ich finde es ja gut, aber es stimmt halt nicht ganz, weil ich meine, klar, das ist Transportverschlüsselung, aber es ist ja keine End-to-End, also weil es End-to-End-Verschlüsselung ist, aber...
Ja, aber wo ist das Ende?
Genau, wer ist das Ende?
Es ist halt wieder so ein Ding, es ist ein großer Konzern, auch US-Konzern, sie versprechen hochheilig, dass sie das und das nicht tun. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, wenn da einer, so ein FBI-Mann oder wer auch immer, mit einem National Security Letter da auftaucht bei denen, dann werden sie auch da irgendwie die Daten wieder rausrücken müssen oder so was. Aber es ist immerhin, es gibt jetzt mindestens immer mal Leute, die das mal anbringen. Du hast ja immer bei solchen neuen Technologien, wie sowas eben, DNS über TLS, hast ja immer dieses Schwanz beißt-Hund-Nummer. Die Betriebssystemhersteller implementieren es erst mal nicht, weil es gibt ja keine Server. Und die Serverbetreiber sagen, was sollen wir implementieren? Es gibt ja keine Clients dafür.
Wer muss mal den Anfang machen?
Ich finde es gut, dass jetzt nicht irgendeine Universität in Kleinen Quokka grode das macht, obwohl ich das auch sehr löblich finde, aber die haben halt einfach nicht den Bums, wie so ein Cloudflare, die das einfach mal weltweit ausrollt.
Na schön, dass ihr das mit dem TLS machen und wenn es dann Clients gibt auf meinem Rechner, die ich dann hier laufen lasse, wo ich mich dann dazwischen schalte, wenn es dann halt auch andere Endpunkte als den 1111 gibt, sondern irgendwas eigenes, wo man sich dann dahin connectet und dann ist es immer noch unterwegs verschlüsselt, aber nicht mehr zu denen, sondern vielleicht zu...
Es bringt die Sache voran, ja, und deswegen finde ich es gut. Und das Ding hat halt eben auch eine ganz gute Erreichbarkeit. Sehr spannend ist, ich habe gerade heute dazu mal einen Tweet weitergeleitet auf so einem Blog von Cloudflare, wo die Leute, die das gemacht haben, mal so beschrieben haben, wie aufwendig das war, 1111 oder 1001 an den Start zu kriegen. Doch, das war sehr aufwendig. Erst mal politisch klar, das 1.8 wurde irgendwann mal in Abnick, also die Kollegen vom Asia Pacific Nick weitergeben, die hatten das immer noch in ihrer Schublade zu liegen. Das da politisch zu kriegen für so ein Anycast Nameserver, für ein Open Nameserver, das war wohl okay noch. Aber da gab es ein paar Leute, die das abnicken mussten, aber das war okay. Was viel spannender war, als sie natürlich, bevor sie ihren Dienst öffentlich gemacht haben, erst mal das angeknipst haben und festgestellt haben, oh, das ist ja wieder mal so eine IP-Adresse, die hat ja Spacko und sein Bruder in ihren privaten Netz eingehabt. Da kommen schon tausende Pakete an. Also in ihr privaten Netz eingehabt. Da gab es zum Beispiel viele Leute, die, als das bekannt wurde, sagten, nee, kann ich nicht, weil mein Hotel benutzt eine Portalseite, die auf 1.1.1.1 läuft oder so was.
Ah ja, so Hotspot-Reader-Rack, genau.
Also alle möglichen Leute, die sich einfach gedacht haben, ach, da nehm ich mir mal die Adresse, die sieht schön aus, mir scheißegal, ob die jemandem gehört oder nicht, ich nehm die jetzt einfach mal. Da sind ja im Laufe der Jahre viele, viele Leute drauf eingefallen. Ich erinnere immer noch einen großen US-Provider, den ich schon vor Jahren, schon vor über zehn Jahren gesehen habe, dass der in seinem gesamten Netz 5 slash 8 benutzt. Zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo 5 draußen schon in Benutzung waren. Jetzt 5 ist komplett voll mit allen möglichen Leuten im Internet. Und ich hab denen damals schon gesagt, ihr könntet nicht hausintern benutzen, das ist kein Private-Adress-Space wie RFC 1918 oder so was.
War nicht 5 einer der ersten von den ersten 10 Zahlen, die verkauft wurden, die dann mal öffentlich benutzt wurden?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Müssen wir mal gucken, wem 5 mal gehört hat. Also 9 zum Beispiel war IBM. Deswegen hat IBM mitgespielt halt bei dem Quad9-Ding. Die 1 hat, weiß ich gar nicht, müsste man mal in der Historie nachwählen, ob jemand 1 slash 8 mal offiziell mal hatte oder nicht. Jedenfalls haben sich dort irre viele Leute gegriffen. Das heißt, man kam erst mal nicht dran, weil irgendwelche In-Firmen-Netzen, Hotel-Netzen und sonst und alle möglichen Leute das für ihren eigenen Scheiß benutzt haben. Und selbst wenn das nicht der Fall war, war es sehr lustig. Die Leute, die das jetzt angeknipst haben im Netz, haben erst mal ohne dass sie einen eigenen Server drauf annonciert hatten oder einen eigenen Server darauf betrieben hatten, hatten erst mal 10 Gigabit-Traffic-Dreck. Also wo halt einfach Leute das als Testadresse benutzen und dahin pingen oder sonst sowas. Es gibt eine schöne Auswertung dafür. Die haben halt einfach so ihr Zeug ins Internet gesteckt, haben gesagt, ich bin jetzt eins. Also eins, null, null, null oder eins, eins, eins, eins, eins oder so. Dann haben wir erst mal geguckt, was kommt denn so an? 10 Gigabit, 10 Gigabit-Dreck von draußen.
Aber immer noch Slash-Acht oder?
Hatte Apple nicht Slash-Acht?
Also 17, Slash-Acht.
17, Slash-Acht. Siehst du auch immer noch, dass Apple-Adressen 17 vorne dran sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie davon Teile schon zurückgegeben haben, glaube ich nicht. Ich habe zum Beispiel mal in den 90ern mal eine Verfügungskraft über 45 gehabt. Und ich habe jetzt neulich mir wieder einen virtuellen Host geklickt, mal bei Vulture. Der hatte eine 45er-Adresse und ich sagte ach guck mal an. Weil die haben wir schon vor x Jahren. Das war Interop nicht. Aber vor x Jahren haben wir die schon zurückgegeben an Apnic. Weil da fing das schon an, dass wir dachten, okay jetzt ein Slash-Acht für uns ist jetzt vielleicht doch eher ein bisschen albern. Und die sind jetzt so weit wieder rumverteilt, dass wir da irgendeinen ISP auf der Welt jetzt wieder vergibt. Deswegen fand ich das ganz lustig. Also mal eine 45er Adresse nach, keine Ahnung, 15, 20 Jahren oder so, was mal wieder auftauchte. Ja und lange Rede, gar keinen Sinn. Probiert es mal aus. Hier kam im Chat die Frage rum, welcher ist denn jetzt nur der Beste? Das kann man sich einfach mal selber zum Beispiel auspingen. Ihr könnt euch einfach mal hinsetzen, nach deinem Rechner und mal ping 8888 eingeben. Für Google. Oder ping 1.1. Man sollte immer den zweiten, jeder von diesen Leuten, hat immer noch einen zweiten dazu. Also 8888 von Google ist der Primäre, 8 8 4 4 ist der Sekundäre. Der hat manchmal andere Pinkzeiten, weil der anders geroutet wird. Dasselbe bei dem 1er, also 1111 ist der Primäre und 1001 ist der Sekundäre. Und den pingt man sich mal aus, welcher davon am schnellsten pingt. Und bei den 9ern, ich weiß gar nicht, also 9999 ist der Primäre. Und es gibt irgendwie da auch noch einen Sekundären mit so einer ähnlichen Adresse. Kann man auf der quad9.net Seite sehen. Und ihr sucht, pinkt euch den aus und den mit der kürzesten Laufzeit den hinter man. Ja, hier aus Telekom netzt ihr gerade. Das ist aber nicht immer so.
Alle 15-16 Millisekunden.
Und das sind die 15-16 Millisekunden, die du hier im DSL-Netz der Telekom verbringst. Aber ich hab ja auch so andere Sachen, die direkt an so Zixen dranhängen, da siehst du dann den Unterschied. Je nachdem, über welchen Transit du herangehst. Aber das ist mindestens mal eine interessante Sache, weil die alle mit verschiedenen Sachen von Privacy oder Quad9, wie ich sagte, die haben so ein bisschen diese Malware-Protection drin. Da müssen wir ein bisschen mit experimentieren. Auf jeden Fall sind die alle besser in der Regel als der DNS-Resolver von eures ISPs, wenn er jetzt nicht davon integriert ist.
Ich hatte noch so eine Erinnerung, dass wenn man jetzt so ein Public-DNS verwendet, dass man dann häufiger in Probleme rennt mit so CDNs, weil man dann irgendwie eben keine optimale IP-Adresse genannt bekommt.
Ja, wenn du irgendwelche Obsturenresolver irgendwo benutzt, dann schon. Bei den Dingern hier ist das nicht so. Weil der Problem mit den CDNs ist, dass die CDNs versuchen ja, den Verkehr von dir zu optimieren. Das tun sie in der Regel auch oder häufig primär erstmal über DNS. Die finden es dann später nochmal anders raus. Und es ist natürlich so, wenn du jetzt hier aus Deutschland so einen obskuren Resolver benutzt, der irgendwo in Korea steht, dann könnte das sein, dass die Anfragen, die der dann wieder an den CDN stellt, so beantwortet werden, dass die Seiten, die du aus dem CDN erreichen willst, auch irgendwo in Asien sind.
Also ich hatte das auch mit 8888 mal.
Das Problem haben jetzt alle erkannt und das ist eigentlich regelmäßig gelöst. Das hat aber mit DNS nix zu tun. Wir haben ja jetzt ein bisschen das Problem auch in dem ITF-Netz, weil das schleppen wir mit uns durch die Gegend, die Netze, die wir dort haben. Wir müssen jedes Mal dafür sorgen, dass die Spracheinstellungen bei Suchmaschinen wie zum Beispiel Google oder sowas sich anpassen, aber das wäre mal ein Thema für einen anderen Zeitpunkt, nicht heute. Aber mit dem CDN wäre mir jetzt nicht bekannt, dass das jetzt heutzutage noch ein Problem ist.
Ich hab noch ein Netzthema in Richtung Clemens auch. Hattest ja gefragt, wolltest du wissen. So hab ich ja hier von meiner Netzumstellung zuhause erzählt, dass sie mich jetzt vectorisieren und ich mir deswegen, was hatte ich mir geholt? Dieses Vigor-Ding ins irgendwas, hatte ich auch schon berichtet. Wollte das nochmal kurz korrigieren. Natürlich wurde ich überhaupt gar nicht auf Vectoring umgeschaltet, weil ich hab nämlich weiterhin noch...
Warte mal, kannst du nochmal ein bisschen klarer machen, worüber du redest? Du redest jetzt über deinen DSL-Anschluss.
Die Hörer wissen das alles.
Die Hörer hören immer alles.
Dann müsst ihr jederzeit davon ausgehen.
Das ist nur noch so ein kurzes Update für die Hörer, die das zum ersten Mal gehört haben. Also ich wurde ja irgendwann, hab ich berichtet, auf Vectoring umgestellt, weil das dann von der Telekom kommt und dir nicht mehr zwei Bitstreams erlauben, krieg ich nur noch einen PPPoE hin. Und einer ist normalerweise fürs... Das muss auf dem Gerät bleiben und deswegen kann ich keins mit meinem FreeBSD abgreifen. Und deswegen brauchte ich eine neue Box, nämlich diese Vigor 130, wie auch immer das Ding jetzt heißt. Hab ich vergessen? Und jetzt hab ich mich voll aus dem Konzept. Ja, selber Schuld. Jetzt hab ich nochmal geguckt und zwar ist es so, dass ich nicht vectorisiert wurde, weil ich hab weiterhin nur 14,5 MBit und mehr als 16 gibt's bei mir in der Straße auch nicht, also nichts mit Vectoring. Genau, ich hab jetzt auch immer noch ADSL. Ich wurde aber auf Annex J umgestellt. Das heißt, die nutzen jetzt die Frequenzen, die vorher für Telefon waren, nutzen sie jetzt für mein Uplink. Das heißt, ich hab jetzt anstatt 1 MBit Uplink hab ich jetzt 2,5. Aber wir leben 2018 in Berlin Mitte und ich hab weiterhin irgendwie ein Netz wie vor 15 Jahren, keine Ahnung, 10.
Das liegt vielleicht daran, dass in deiner Straße vielleicht vornehmlich auch Kommerz- und wenig Privatleute da sind. Also ich kenne das gerade aus Mitte. Ich kenne das gerade aus Mitte dort zum Beispiel. Friedrichstraße ist ein extrem scheiß Pflaster.
Ich wohne 2 Minuten von der Friedrichstraße.
Ja, weil halt diese Anschlussbereich, da sind halt wahnsinnig viele Kommerz-Dinger und die möchte ich nicht machen. Ich meine nur so die Ecke zum Beispiel. Friedrichstraße, Ecke Oranienburger. So, diese Ecke ist extrem lausig versorgt, weil Telekom sagt, da haben wir nicht genug Privatleute für VDSL und die Kommerzkunden. Aber das sind doch alles Privatleute. Die ganzen Kommerzkunden, die Arzt- und Anwaltspraxen und Apotheken, die da sind, sollen sich hier verliessen einen ordentlichen Glasfaser-Link für 600 Euro klicken.
Weiß nicht, ob das der Grund ist. Aber ich hab auch letztens gehört, dass an der Torstraße war wohl letztens wieder so eine Glasfasertruppe, der hatte schon morgens die gesehen, dachte, scheiße, ist ein Ladengeschäft irgendwie, geht in die Hose, werden jetzt hier alles aufreißen. Als er nachmittags wieder aus dem Fenster geguckt hat, waren die alles zu und waren die weg. Die schießen mit irgendwelchen komischen Geräten. Die buddeln nicht die Straße kaputt, sondern die schießen unter der Straße durch, damit es auf der anderen Seite wieder rauskommt und buddeln dann von da weiter. An einem Tag, also es geht schon schnell, wenn man will.
So viel zum Thema Glasfaser legen, ist unglaublich kompliziert. Wahnsinnig, deswegen müssen wir jahrelang diskutieren.
Hexe oder wie heißen die?
Es gab auch mal so ein Skandal um diese Firma, weil die nämlich auch so ein bisschen die Firma, wie so was erfunden oder hergestellt hat, also Flow, irgendwas mit Flow. Flow-Tech oder irgendwie sowas, da gab es Skandälchen drum, so wegen Börsenbetrug oder sonst irgendwas. Aber diese Technik ist ja so mit Spültechnik, mit so einer, die spülen den Sand einfach weg und schlängeln das Ding. Was ich viel faszinierender finde, ist, dass sie das navigieren können. Dass sie den Kopf von dem Ding auch hoch und runter und am Ecken und so können sie das steuern, wie sich der Kopf durch den Erdreich frisst. Und das geht auch relativ weit. Das geht nicht bloß einmal unter der Straße durch.
Horizontalbohrmaschinen.
Und die sind richtig cool.
Da gibt es einen Wikipedia-Entrag zu der Stammung.
Gibt es auch schöne Videos davon, wie sowas in Benutzung ist. Das finde ich Bodenverdrängungsverfahren.
Bis 25 Meter. 25 Meter ist schon nicht so wenig.
Die Höchstens 8 Meter ist schon eine sehr große Stammung. Du bist nicht vectorisiert bis jetzt immer noch im ADSL-Ledit.
Ich bin vorbereitet, das Gerät kann das alles. Wenn die dann irgendwann mal vectorisieren, dann schaltet mein Gerät automatisch um. Da merkt man ja wohl auch gar nichts. Bisher habe ich jetzt ein bisschen weniger Ambit als vorher, weil ich jetzt nur noch 14,5 habe.
Du wirst aber als ADSL-Kunde nicht zwangsvektorisiert, weil ADSL kann parallel bestehen mit VDSL-Vectoring.
Ich habe geklickt alle Anbieter durch. Bei mir in der Straße gibt es nur 16. Also alle sagen, es gibt auch nur 16.
Ja, aber ich sage selbst, wenn da andere Leute was ausbauen, musst du nicht weggehen. Diese Vectoring-Geschichte hat ja nur diesen Verdrängungseffekt. Wenn ihr euch erinnert, da war auch vor ein paar Wochen mal in der Twittersphäre so irgendwelche Leute was. Die sagen, die Telekom hat mir jetzt meinen VDSL-Anschluss gekündigt, weil sie den hier angeblich nicht mehr supporten können. Ja, so irgendwo in Norddeutschland.
Ah, diese Geschichte. Wäre ja kein Problem. Dann würde ich ja wechseln. Ich will ja ein bisschen mehr net. Das ist ja nicht das, was ich bestreube.
Diesen Verdrängungseffekt gibt es nicht zwischen ADSL und VDSL. ADSL und VDSL-Vectoring können parallel bestehen. Du kannst halt nur nicht mehr als einen VDSL-Vectoring-Provider auf einem Verteiler drauf haben. Aber du kannst noch ADSL weiter drauf haben. Das heißt, wenn du da nicht selber an deinen Provider rangehst und sagst, ich wäre interessiert an einem Upgrade, den es jetzt vielleicht noch nicht gibt bei dir, aber den es irgendwann noch mal gibt, dann bleibst du doch ewig auf deinem ADSL-Zeugs hängen. Übrigens gibt es auch dann wieder Provider, die einfach irgendwann sagen, jetzt habe ich auf meinem alten ADSL-D-Slam irgendwie noch drei Kunden drauf, muss aber trotzdem an Telekom oder sonst jemand monatliche Gebühren für den Betrieb von diesem Ding bezahlen oder weil sie sich halt einen Rack mieten müssen in einer Co-Location oder sonst irgendwas. Dass die Provider dann selber sagen, wir rollen jetzt ohne ADSL 1 ein, weil das lohnt sich nicht für uns, da vierte drei Kunden noch zu betreiben. Aber es gibt jedenfalls keinen technischen Hintergrund für die Verdrängung deines ADSL-Anschlusses durch VDSL-Vectoring.
Also von mir aus können die das gerne verdrängen. Ich würde gerne das eine schnelleren nehmen. Also ich habe ja gehofft, dass es jetzt mal so, weil es so 25 MBit wäre ja mal so ein erster Schritt so ins warme Wasser, aber ja nee.
Es kommt. Weil sie, der Witz ist, das ist ja das Interessante dabei. Als diese Vectoring-Geschichte losging, ist man ja hingegangen und hat gesagt, so jetzt schauen wir mal, was wir alle für Kästen haben, die so existieren, so Straßenkästen. In der ganzen Bundesrepublik haben die alle schöne Datenbank gekippt. Und dann durften sich Provider drauf bewerben, zu sagen, ich will diesen Kasten jetzt mit Vectoring ausbauen. Da hat natürlich die Telekom erst mal bei vielen Kästen drauf geklickt und hat gesagt, ja, das möchte ich gerne machen. Dann haben sie den vielleicht auch gekriegt. Bei manchen sind andere Leute drauf, aber ich glaube, so fliegweiß sind alle Kästen vergeben worden. An irgendjemanden. Und das bedeutet aber, da gibt es Ausbauzeiträume, bis wann die denn auch. Du kannst nicht nur sagen, ach, die Kunden möchten ihn haben. Sondern die müssen dann das auch machen. Wenn nicht, wird dieser Kasten neu ausgeschrieben und dann können sich wieder andere drum bewerben. Diese Fristen laufen jetzt dieser Tage Monate irgendwann jetzt mal aus, in der Regel, für viele dieser Dinger. Das heißt, wir werden jetzt, denke ich, mal im ersten Halbjahr, 2018 oder so, werden wir jetzt mal alles sehen, wann die mal alle durch sind. Und dann muss man halt eben neu bewerten. Das kann immer noch sein, dass du da so einen Arschprovider hast. Hab ich auch schon gehört, die jetzt sich zwar so einen Kasten geklickt haben und da auch Vectoring einbauen, aber zu obskuren Gebühren oder sonst noch was anbieten. Das ist ein bisschen schummerig, diese Geschichte. Aber der Staub setzt sich in diesem Thema jetzt. Ich hoffe, in den nächsten Monaten.
Weil ich kann mit meinem 4K sonst nicht in ordentlicher Qualität gucken.
Nee, das müssen wir offline diskutieren. Du kennst mein aktuelles Projekt, hast mal darüber gesprochen, hast du Sicht darauf? Das kann ich jetzt halt nicht öffentlich sagen.
Ja, das diskutiert ja später.
Nächstes Thema.
Darf ich mal mit meinem Werbeblock?
Nö, ich hätte nur zwei Empfehlungen vom Easter Hack. Wer sich vor allem jetzt, so wie ich, gerade erst so mit Konsolen anfängt zu beschäftigen oder auch so Tools einfach entdecken will, um Produktivität zu steigern, kann ich beim Easter Hack oder vom Easter Hack zwei Vorträge von Lyra empfehlen. Zum einen die so moderne Kommando-Zellentools, die ganz cool waren. Einfach so ein bisschen so ein Überblick, was geht, was man womit so machen kann. Das fand ich ganz hilfreich. Und zum anderen dieses T-Mux, was man nutzen kann, um, wenn man gerade auf dem Server eingeloggt ist, mehrere Screens zu haben in einer Konsole, ohne mehrere Sessions aufzuhaben. Das ist sehr hilfreich und hätte mir an gegebener Stelle schon eher viel geholfen. Oh, sorry, Tim, jetzt hab ich das auch reingepostet. Ach guck mal, wir waren super. Wir haben beide das Unterschiedliche reingepostet. Genau, also wer da sich mit beschäftigen will, die beiden Vorträge kann ich dir sehr empfehlen. Es gab auch noch einen, den hab ich aber noch nicht zu Ende geschaut. Irgendwie Linux-Oper, irgendwie der Linux-Oper erzählt oder so, wo es auch nochmal um verschiedene Command-Line-Befehle geht und wie man eben so schneller ans Ziel kommt als Clicky Bunti mit Oberfläche, was ich halt gerade sehr praktisch finde, wenn ich mich auf Servern umschaue, umschauen darf, muss. Genau, also da sind mal diese beiden Vorträge empfohlen, die ich da auch gesehen habe.
Alright, Command-Line-Tipps kann man ja nicht genug haben.
Nee, vor allem, es ist halt auch in einem ein der Vorträge so ein bisschen drin, so am Anfang ist es halt alles so ungewohnt, weil man doch dieses UI doch sehr mittlerweile drin hat und nicht davon wegkommen will, so ein bisschen. Aber irgendwie ist man doch viel schneller am Ziel, wenn man alles über die Konsole macht. Ich mach mittlerweile meinen ganzen Git-Kram auch nur noch über die Konsole. Ich kann da keine UI mehr sehen, weil ich es hässlich finde und unintuitiv.
Es gibt aber auch sehr wenig gute UI-Git-Tools.
Welches? Also ja, was ich sehr gerne nutze ist die Integration von WebStorm, also von IntelliJ, was sie da in ihre IDEs einbauen. Das finde ich ist ganz gut, aber was ich wirklich ein hammergeiles Feature finde, aber nicht weiß, ob es das noch aktuell in der native GitHub Desktop App da gibt, man konnte in einem Pfeil einzelne Zeilen markieren und comitten, was ich manchmal ganz praktisch finde, wenn du dann doch mal verpeilt hast irgendwie mit den dritten Comitten. Aber das weiß ich nicht, ob man das auch auf der Command Line kann, dass man sagt hier nur Zeile so und so.
Ja, kannst du, aber das ist schmerzhaft.
Aber das geht quasi immer noch über die Git, die Git-Testata.
Also ich benutze ja immer GitX, was ein so ein GNU Open Source Projekt ist, was, von dem gibt es irgendwie mehr Forks als, weiß ich nicht, Releases. Und ich habe da irgendwann mal einen gefunden, der halbwegs funktioniert und nicht ständig abstürzt. Und mit dem kann man ganz gut arbeiten. Aber so die üblichen Verdächtigen. Also ich habe jetzt von Git Tower, gibt es jetzt eine Beta für die 3er-Version. Und das geht halt gar nicht mehr. Also das Git Tower 2 war schon nicht so besonders toll, aber das Git Tower 3, das scheint mir ein totaler Rückschritt zu sein. Warum? Die haben keinen U-Bahn-Plan mehr. Also für mich ist das wichtigste an einem Git-Tool ist der U-Bahn-Plan.
Die Branches, oder?
Wo du alle Branches und alle Commits siehst. Und siehst, wo läuft was parallel und was kann ich wo reinmergen.
Und wodurch haben sie das ersetzt?
Es gibt nur so eine lineare Abfolge von von Commits und zwar nur für den Branch, den du aussuchst. SourceTree ist genauso. SourceTree geht einigermaßen, aber SourceTree ist auch so ein total überfrachtetes Tool, wo du hast relativ viele Buttons, dann drückst du auf den Button, dann geht so ein Dialog auf, wo du irgendwie tausend Dinge einstellen kannst. Also es ist auch ganz schlimm.
Wenn ich von früher und dann kommt so ein komisches Modus, dann tut das Tool gar nicht mehr. Und dann musst du doch wieder mit Command-Line ran und musst doch wieder lernen, was die Command-Line kann. Und dann bleibe ich lieber gleich bei der Command-Line.
Das Ding bei Git ist, es gibt ja im Prinzip nur zwei verschiedene Arten von Commandos. Das eine Commando ist, du arbeitest an dem Baum. Und das andere Commando ist, ich arbeite an der Working Copy. Also mit der Working Copy sage ich, ich mach jetzt ein Commit. Das heißt, du überträgst eine Änderung von der Working Copy in den Baum, den du lokal hast. Und dann kannst du die Änderung, die du im Baum lokal hast, kannst du in den Baum Remote pushen, zum Beispiel. Oder von Remote nach Lokal in den Baum holen. Und kannst dann von dem, was du im Baum hast, an deine Working Copy übertragen, indem du irgendwie auscheckst und so weiter. Das heißt, die meisten Kommandos beziehen sich entweder auf die Working Copy oder auf einen ganz bestimmten Commit. Und es hat keins dieser Tools daraus verstanden, dass du ein Commit auswählst und ein Kommando drauf ausführst. Also zum Beispiel, ich habe einen Branch ausgecheckt. Und dann klicke ich einen anderen Commit an und sage zum Beispiel Cherry Pick, was werde ich wohl machen wollen? Ja, ich will diesen einen Commit auf meinen gerade ausgecheckten Branch cherry picken. Da brauche ich keinen riesen Auswahldialog, wo ich alle möglichen Ziele und Dings auswähle, sondern ich will genau das machen. Diesen einen Commit will ich dahin checken, wo ich ausgecheckt habe. Und so ein Tool gibt es nicht, außer dieses GitX was. Aber in so ganz halb Zustand ist. Und leider irgendwie ab und zu dann doch nicht funktioniert. Also wenn es schwierigere Sachen sind, dann nehme ich auch immer die Kommandozeile. Weil da bin ich mir dann sicher, dass das auch funktioniert. Aber das ist irgendwie, naja, was soll man machen?
Ich habe letztens auch nach einem, um etwas noch kurz dazwischen zu grätschen, geguckt, ob es nicht irgendeinen schönen Editor gibt, für das einfach nur am Markdown-Dings zu schreiben im Terminal. Aber Sublime ist leider irgendwie dann doch die erste Wahl. Aber mittlerweile fange ich mich an, wirklich richtig wohlzufühlen im Terminal.
Programmiere eine Menge so remote. Programmieren würde ich es eigentlich gar nicht nennen, das ist ein bisschen übertrieben. Aber so rumfuschen, ich muss manchmal fuschen, wenn man so umhackt, so Zeug. Das ist schon remote, was ich dann im VI mache. Der hat ja auch immerhin jetzt Syntax-Coloring und so weiter, in Python oder C und so weiter. Aber ich bin schon auch froh, wenn ich direkt auf meinem Rechner was programmiere und dann ich nehme einfach immer Xcode und hab dann da alles so, wie ich es haben will.
Xcode oder Sublime.
Und ich nutze gar nicht mal richtig viele Features, also tausend Sachen, die Xcode da haben. Ich nutze auch keine Completion und so weiter, aber ich hab einfach, geht schneller, besser, leichter.
Nee, ich mein auch wirklich eher so kurz, um Sachen runterzuschreiben. Also ich hab eben eine Outline geschrieben für meine Vorlesung, einfach nur so was. Also dafür würde ich halt dann auch irgendwie, also ich nutze dann meistens eh nur den Nano, weil ich mit dem VI und den ganzen Befehlen werde ich irre. Beim Nano habe ich mich so kurz für kleine Sachen reingearbeitet, aber...
VI benutze ich nur, um irgendwie auf Freebase dir die Kiste wieder flott zu kriegen, wenn sie irgendwie nicht mehr geht. Also wirklich so...
Ich mach ja mein Remote-Kram jetzt immer auf Freebase...
.so Konfig-Dateien editieren, das ist für mich VI. Aber für nichts anderes benutze ich den. Bei Sublime nerven mich zwei Dinge. Erstens, es gibt keine ordentlich... Der installiert das Commando-Sign-Tool nicht ordentlich. Man muss da irgendwie per Hand rum mit LN-symbolische Links erstellen per Hand und so weiter. Das nervt total. Und das Zweite ist, es gibt keine ordentliche Art, das Ding zu konfigurieren. Du sagst Preferences und dann öffnet der seinen eigenen... Seine eigene... Seine Datei da, seine Yammel-Datei, indem du irgendwie die Sachen editierst und denkst du so, ah...
Ja, und vor allem, dass du bei Sublime zwei hast, zwei Felder, ne? Also du musst den... Du hast auf der einen Seite die Preferences, die das Default sind, in denen du nicht editieren darfst. Und du musst daneben eine Preferences haben, die für den User sind, die dann explizit die Änderungen enthalten. Eigentlich wollte ich nur diese zwei Vorträge empfehlen, weil ich sie wirklich gut fand.
Gut, dann komme ich halt zu dem Punkt, den ich unbedingt ganz am Anfang der Sendung stellen wollte, damit der nicht ans Ende gerät.
Voll gelungen.
Voll gelungen. Ja, und zwar ein bisschen Meta... Meta aus der Metaebene. Zunächst einmal gibt es eine Veranstaltung, auf die ich ja auch nochmal kurz hinweisen wollte, auch wenn das vielleicht nicht der richtige Kanal ist. Und zwar gibt es mal wieder eine Live-Podcasting-Geschichte Onstage in Berlin bei Lochbruch Netzpolitik, Nummer 256, dachten wir uns, wäre mal die richtige Zahl, um uns mal wieder rauszutrauen. Und das Ganze findet am 26. Mai statt. Und wer da vielleicht noch nichts gehört hat, hat da jetzt vielleicht was von gehört.
Ist das Pfingsten?
Ja, keine Ahnung, ob wir das nochmal machen.
Hex 100.
256.
Das ist der Samstag nach dem Pfingstwochenende.
Also eine Woche später.
Genau, ja, Babylon ist eine feine Location auf jeden Fall.
Ist Babylon Kino, oder was?
Ja, das Babylon ist ja eigentlich kein Kino, sondern das Babylon ist ja eigentlich mehr so ein kleines Theater.
Aber das da, so ein bisschen südlich vom Rosa-Luxemburg-Platz.
Also das heißt, Babylon, es gibt da auch Kino. Aber es gibt da auch viel Non-Kino.
Non-Kino.
Ja, und das ist wirklich super nice da. Anderes Problem ist, dass wir ja eigentlich an dem Wochenende die Subscribe, die Zehnte durchführen wollen.
Wer ist wir?
Wir sind das Sendezentrum.
An welchem Wochenende?
An dem Wochenende, an dem ich gerade eine andere Veranstaltung angekündigt hatte.
Aber?
Aber findet nicht statt.
Die Subscribe?
Genau, also nicht an dem Wochenende. Weil das Problem ist, dass wir zwar eine Location gefunden hatten, die aber nicht rechtzeitig geklärt werden konnte. Und dann unsere interne Deadline quasi dafür abgelaufen war. Und die sollte man dann auch mal ernst nehmen. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass es halt nicht wie ursprünglich geplant die Subscribe 10 im Frühjahr in Berlin geben wird. Und jetzt ist die große Frage, wird es sie im Herbst geben? Wir streben es eigentlich an. Das Ding ist nur, dass wir eigentlich immer noch keine richtige Location haben. Wir haben zwar eine Location Option gehabt. Und diese Option besteht im Prinzip auch immer noch. Aber die hat auch so ein bisschen so ihre Probleme. Und wir wären eigentlich ganz glücklich, mal was anderes zu finden. Und es ist so ein bisschen absurd, dass wenn man jetzt in Berlin wohnt und hier auch irgendwie am laufenden Meter auf irgendwelchen Veranstaltungen ist, dass wir da eigentlich nichts finden. Und da dachte ich mir, vielleicht hilft es ja mal, das Leid kurz hier in den Äther zu klagen. Denn ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass eine Menge Leute von euch auch schon mal irgendwo gewesen sind oder vielleicht Beziehungen haben, sogar zu irgendeinem Veranstaltungsort oder da arbeiten oder keine Ahnung, welche Beziehung auch immer. Ihr habt, wenn es auch nur Wissen ist, wir suchen eine Location und ich sag gleich mal dazu, was so unsere Rahmenbedingungen sind, weil die sind ein bisschen anspruchsvoll und das passt halt nicht unbedingt auf alles. Also wir suchen etwas in Berlin, möglichst nicht so am Arsch der Welt. Es gibt natürlich, es gab so ein paar Angebote, aber dann, was weiß ich, dann bist du irgendwo so in Buch oder so, wo du mal glücklich sein kannst, wenn alle 20 Minuten S-Bahnen hinfährten, bis halt dann nochmal.
Das ist ja kein Nicht-Berlin. Oder ist es noch Berlin?
Witzigerweise hinter der Autobahn, aber trotzdem.
Berliner ist nicht Berlin, ne?
Nee, ist viel spannender als Uni Berlin.
Es gibt Berlin, das ist schon ganz schön weit weg. Also am Ende entscheidet halt die, am Ende entscheidet natürlich die Anbindung ans öffentliche Verkehrssystem. Ich habe auch jetzt kein Problem damit, wenn die Location weit draußen ist, aber dann sollte sie nicht nochmal 20 Minuten von der nächsten S-Bahn-Station entfernt sein, sondern möglichst nebendran. Wir brauchen eine Kapazität für 150 Leute oder damit das Ganze vielleicht noch ein bisschen wachsen kann, 150 plus, also auch mal einen schönen Ort zu finden, der so ein bisschen Perspektive bietet. Das bedeutet vor allem, dass es einen Konferenzraum geben muss, der eben diese 150 Leute auch fassen kann.
Jetzt nur von Open Air, nichts.
Schade.
Da gäbe es ja noch was, da geht ja was.
Ja, aber wie ich schon sagte, ich halte da nichts von.
Was sind 150 Leute rein in so ein Ding, in der Regel?
In den Open Air Raum.
Nee, nicht Open Air Raum, sondern wenn du halt guckst, was ist das, nach Hasenheide gibt es so ein Ding, oder an der Wuhlheide, oder kannst du Olympiashal dann mieten, nicht die Waldbühne oder so was. Da passen 150 Leute rein.
Das scheitert gleich noch an den anderen Kriterien.
Die Bits kriegt er schon hin.
Wenn das mal das einzige Problem wäre. Naja, also wir wollen natürlich was haben, was man als ordentlichen Konferenzraum verwenden kann, und was im Idealfall eigentlich auch schon einer ist. Sprich, dann auch die entsprechende Technologie bereitstellt. Gab es schon wieder einen Bärwitz?
Ja, der Bär ist frei, der Bahn fährt auch schon. Und es hat auch genug Räume.
BCC ist zu groß oder wie?
Lass mich erst mal zu Ende erzählen. Dann brauchen wir noch drei Workshop-Räume, mindestens so für so 20, 30 plus Leute. Weil das Konzept ist ja nicht nur Vorträge, sondern das ist ein Teil davon. Das andere, viel wichtigere Rahmenprogramm ist halt diese Workshops. Sprich, wenn so der Vormittag gelaufen ist, wenn man sich eben auf verschiedene Workshop-Räume verteilen. Drei wäre so das Minimum. Vier wäre super. Wir nehmen auch mehr, weil das ist sozusagen alles ganz wichtig. Und außerdem wäre es gut, wenn man halt auch nicht zu zerrissen ist. Es gibt so Locations, die haben zwar so dieses und jenes und dann sind da aber fünf Etagen noch dazwischen und dann muss noch mal drei Flure irgendwo und so. Das bringt es natürlich auch nicht, weil wenn du ein Community-Event machen willst, dann willst du irgendwie auch mehr oder weniger alle Leute beisammen haben. Im Idealfall hast du noch so ein Get-Together-Bereich, wo man sich halt mehr oder weniger automatisch treffen kann. Ja, und dann gibt es noch so zwei, drei kleine Rahmenbedingungen, nämlich einerseits die Möglichkeit, eigenes Catering machen zu können. Also wo man nicht irgendwie gebunden ist an irgendein so ein vorherrschendes Catering-Ding. Das hat was damit zu tun, dass wir da so unsere eigenen Vorstellungen davon haben und so um den Community-Charakter da auch nochmal zu unterstützen, so unseren Modus gefunden haben, den wir gerne beibehalten würden. Internet muss es natürlich geben. Erreichbarkeit habe ich schon gesagt. Und es wäre natürlich auch ganz gut, an so einem Ort zu landen, wo man so mental auch andocken kann, wo jetzt nicht unbedingt Leute vorherrschen, die überhaupt nicht gehen. Ja, der große Haken ist, wir hätten eigentlich ganz gerne sowas wie günstige oder überhaupt gar keine Miete. Da wird es natürlich dann immer so ein bisschen knifflig. Was ist günstig, kann ich nicht sagen. Müssen man sich am Ende mal anschauen. Heißt nicht, dass ich jetzt überhaupt keine Bereitschaft hätte, da Aufwand zu treiben. Wäre allerdings sehr schön, wenn da zumindest jetzt keine Business-Miete fällig ist, man das halt sozusagen unter Community-Support-Aspekten regeln kann. Ja, also...
Heimathafen ist zu klein, ne?
Ich kenne das nicht. Aber ich habe...
Darf ich hier mal kurz brainstorming-mäßig Sachen auf den Tisch schmeißen und du kickst sie dann einfach wieder runter? Also, was mir jetzt spontan einfällt, für die Kriterien, die du gerade genannt hast. Also, man kann jetzt erstmal hingehen, könnt jetzt selbes Spiel wie in München machen. Beim RBB-Anfragen in Berlin und RBB in Potsdam, in Babelsberg, die liegen alle verkehrsgünstig beide. Du bist gleich dran. Dann kannst du gleich alle vom Tisch runterfegen. Ich sag das vielmehr jetzt so spontan ein. Dann was öffentliche Dinge angeht, also Bundeskultur sozusagen, wo Bundessteuermittel drin sind, wo man also mit diesem Community-Ding ankommen kann, das Haus der Kultur in der Welt. Unter Eingeweihten auch Schwangere Oster genannt. Die haben auch viele große Räume und kleine und nebeneinander und hin und her. Und haben auch Platz und Zeit für sowas. Kommerzielle Location, die du auch kennst, wäre das Cosmos. E-Mail Kino Cosmos in der, was ist das, Frankfurter heißt die da noch? Nee, kein Maxon, stimmt. Das war ich zu Your Icon, der letzte Your Icon war das. Die wollen aber ein Geld dafür haben. Da gibt es aber jedenfalls ordentliche Bits. Auch HKW, Haus der Kultur in der Welt, gibt es auch ordentliche Bits. Und ansonsten fällt mir ein Adlershof. Wenn man das in Semesterferien abfällt, da gibt es jede Menge Räumlichkeiten, die zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht für universitäre Sachen genutzt werden, respektive auch andere Forschungseinrichtungen in Berlin. Also TU zum Beispiel, weiß ich auch, habe ich auch schon andere Konferenzen gehabt, die nichts mit der Uni zu tun hatten. Auch da ist in der Regel kein Problem mit den Bits. Bzw. in Potsdam gibt es auch Sachen, die sind dann zwar auch verkehrsgünstig, aber das ist schon wieder so ein bisschen draus. Aber das fällt mir jetzt mal so spontan ein. Jetzt darfst du die alle vom Tisch wegen.
Ja gut, Haus der Kultur in der Welt ist nicht unbedingt so auf, der Hauptzahl nicht unbedingt so auf 150 Leute. Es gibt da noch diesen anderen, das ist sogar ganz interessant.
HKW hat große Räume vermehrt. Ja, hat große und kleine und Workshops.
Ja, bin ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher. Die Frage ist halt immer nur dieses Community-Wochenende, drei Tage, also wir reden hier wirklich Freitag, Samstag, Sonntag, zumindest den Teil des Freitags, müsste man mal klären. Die haben immer Veranstaltungen, die über das Wochenende gehen. Sowohl was die Räumlichkeiten als auch den Zugang dazu betrifft.
Inwiefern schwierig, weil der Hausmeister keine Sonderschicht schieben darf am Wochenende? Oder was meinst du jetzt damit?
Ja, vielleicht, keine Ahnung. Dazu muss ich halt jemand melden, der die Situation vor Ort kennt und mit dem man das klären kann. Ich kann mir jetzt auch viel ausdenken, was vielleicht unter Umständen vielleicht klappen könnte und ich kann natürlich jetzt auch die nächsten Wochen damit verbringen, quer durch Berlin zu laufen. Hab da aber keine Lust zu. Ich möchte gerne.
Du möchtest gerne, dass ihr jemand auf dem Silbertablett präsentiert. Ihr darf es am Wochenende Spaß haben.
Genau, ich hätte das ganz gerne auf dem Silbertablett. Beziehungsweise wir haben natürlich schon einiges selber auch gecheckt und haben da auch schon mal Zeit investiert. Und wir haben uns auch X-Locations angeschaut. Nur, dass halt immer irgendwie was war. Irgendetwas ist ja immer. Irgendetwas ist ja immer.
Was ist denn mit RBB? Da könnt ihr der Holgi mal die Nase reinstecken und mal sagen, ob da was geht.
Ja, ähm, weiß ich nicht.
Mindestens so kulturell. Ihr führt euch ja beim Bayerischen Rundfunk ganz wohl. Also so von der Kultur her. Wäre ja möglich, dass da vielleicht so ein anderer AMD-Sender da auch.
Also bei Bayerischen Rundfunk haben wir uns zwar wohl gefühlt, aber werden wir uns jetzt nicht mehr wohlfühlen, weil die nächste Subscribed im Herbst war ja ursprünglich gedacht für München, das wird auch nicht stattfinden. Das ist da auf einmal nicht mehr möglich. Und ja, es gab da schon andere Ideen. Will ich jetzt im Einzelnen gar nicht so sehr darauf eingehen. Also ihr habt die Kriterien gehört, wenn ihr irgendwie deine Idee habt in Berlin. Und wäre mir auch ganz lieb, wenn ihr nur dann auf uns zukommt, wenn ihr irgendwie wirklich das Gefühl habt, ihr kennt den Ort gut und ihr wisst auch, dass diese Anforderungen vermutlich oder auf jeden Fall zutreffen oder zumindest diskutierbar sind. Dann wäre das ganz gut. Also umso mehr Bezug ihr dazu habt, umso mehr möchte ich gerne von euch hören. Ist ganz schön, wenn man jetzt so eine lange, lange Liste von 20 Locations mit, da könnt ihr doch mal fragen. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, wie das da ist, aber ich hab gehört, das und so. Solche Listen hab ich schon alle gehabt. Kilometerlange Listen hab ich gehabt, die wir durchgeschaut haben. Jetzt probieren wir das erstmal mit einer konkreten Anfrage.
Was sprach jetzt gegen BCC?
Ich will jetzt nicht ausführlich darlegen, was jetzt gegen die eine oder andere Location sprach, aber das Hauptproblem ist halt Geld an der Stelle. Ich meine, das sind kommerzielle Konferenzveranstaltungsorte, wo du jetzt nicht immer irgendwie mit hey, lass uns doch mal deine Ressourcen kostenlos nutzen und so. Das ist halt meistens schwierig.
Ja, bei den ganz kommerziellen wahrscheinlich schon.
Ja, ich hab auch jetzt überhaupt nichts dagegen, so einen Berliner Jam zu finden, wo einfach auch so die sonstige Atmosphäre ganz gut ist. Es muss jetzt nicht unbedingt so eine professionelle Tagungsatmosphäre sein. Da steh ich jetzt gar nicht mal so drauf. Es kann auch ein bisschen freakiger sein, solange man da irgendwie seine Infrastruktur auf die Backe kriegt.
Auch so Schrottlocations in Kreuzberg gibt es ja auch reichlich. Siebel ist zu klein. Hinten da am Flutgraben diese Dinger da zum Beispiel.
Das geht nicht.
Siebel hat nur den Seminarraum.
Da ist der Platz nicht im Ansatz vorhanden, den wir bräuchten, geschweige denn die exklusive Nutzbarkeit. Also das funktioniert nicht. So, dann noch Medienhinweis. Ich war nach 35 Jahren oder 32 Jahren mal wieder beim Heiseverlag.
Ach ja, damals war's.
Damals war's, genau. Und jetzt jüngst war's.
War noch jemand da von damals?
Ja, eine Person.
Hat dich auch noch erkannt, oder?
Ja, ich hab mich schön zwei Stunden lang unterhalten. Die guten alten Zeiten und die guten neuen Zeiten. Ja, hat sich ein bisschen verändert. Mir war auch gar nicht klar, was für ein Apparat Heise irgendwie mittlerweile geworden ist. Also wie groß die eigentlich wirklich ist.
Ich erinnere mich doch da dran. Das war doch irgendwie so ein relativ kleiner Bau da hinten irgendwo in dem...
In der Nähe der Medizinischen Hochschule. Da sind sie ja auch immer noch ein bisschen näher rangerückt. Da haben sie jetzt vor einigen Jahren so ein Gebäude von der Versicherung übernommen. Du bist nicht klein und du hast auch ganz nette Facilities drin. Aber ich meinte, das ist ja eher die Gesamtausdehnung vom Heiseverlag, der irgendwie so 1000 Mitarbeiter hat. Schon ganz ordentlich, ne?
Ja, das war es damals nicht. Das war damals eher so eine Handvoll.
Ja, genau. Warum erzähl ich das? Weil ich bin eingeladen worden in die Heise-Show. Das ist so ihr YouTube-Podcast.
Deine Konkurrenz eigentlich.
Keine Konkurrenz. Wofür soll das eine Konkurrenz sein?
Ist das nicht auch so Podcast-mäßig? Aber die machen auch so Streaming und Live.
Ja, wir machten das nicht heutzutage.
Aber nicht selber.
Das denke ich mir schon die ganze Zeit. Ich habe mich mal eine Stunde zu Podcasting geäußert. Ich denke, das ist eigentlich ganz rund geworden. Vielleicht interessiert das jemanden. Eine zweite Sendung, auf die ich noch mal hinweisen wollte, weil ich festgestellt habe, als ich die veröffentlicht habe, dass es so ein bisschen rumging, dass dann doch so einige Leute mit sich ankamen. Ich dachte, das wusste ich ja noch gar nicht, dass du das machst. Das mache ich schon eine ganze Weile, nämlich den Podcast Forschergeist. Forschergeist ist ja so eine von meinen Auftragssachen. Die mache ich halt zusammen mit dem Stifterverband für die Deutsche Wissenschaft. Da geht es halt um Wissenschaft im Allgemeinen, beziehungsweise um die wissenschaftliche Arbeit. Wie arbeiten Leute und so weiter. So haben wir zumindest konzeptionell angefangen. Mittlerweile ist das ein ganz interessanter Reigen von Sendungen geworden. Also, wer zum Beispiel CRE mag, der wird auch Forschergeist mögen. Da ist eine Menge Gold zu finden. Supergeile Sendung über Düfte, eine supergeile Sendung über Moore. Und jetzt hatte ich die Gelegenheit in München, mich auch mal eine dreiviertel Stunde mit Harald Lesch zu unterhalten. Der sicherlich einigen von euch bekannt ist.
Wir haben als Club mal die DVDs gekauft, wenn du dich erinnern kannst.
Nee, kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern, aber...
Die Bayerner Alfa-Dinger oder was? Das ist doch echt cool, ich hab den gehört. Das hat einfach Spaß gemacht, weil das eben auch mal ein Wissenschaftler ist, der aber selber auch dadurch, dass er öffentlich auftritt, auch weiß, wie man redet. Ich genieße das ja sehr, wenn man halt jetzt mal Leute hat, die einfach mal einen zusammenhängenden Satz mit mehr als drei Vokabeln wie erzeugen können, ohne sich da dauernd immer irgendwo festzuklemmen oder irgendwie rumzuwurschteln. Das war einfach mal ein Fest für die Ohren, euch beiden da mal zuzuhören, muss ich mal sagen.
Ja, das freut mich natürlich sehr. Ich war auch ganz zufrieden am Ende und hoffe auch, so meine selbst gesteckten Ziele erreicht zu haben. Für diese Folge oder für den Podcast oder was? Es ist immer so ein bisschen was anderes, wenn man auf Leute trifft, von denen man weiß, dass sie sehr eloquent sind und irgendwie gefühlt auch schon mit jedem über alles geredet haben. Mit der Eloquenz an sich habe ich jetzt erst mal kein Problem. Das ist ja gut, weil schlimmer ist, wenn die Leute es nicht sind. Aber natürlich ist es auch so für mich ein Ansporn, dann auch was hinzulegen, was man vielleicht so in der Form noch nicht gehört hat, obwohl der Mensch die ganze Zeit alle Kanäle bespielt. Man kann ja Fernseher rauf und runter schalten. Irgendwo grins sich Harald Lesch an. Im Netz ist es nicht anders. Dann will ich eigentlich immer nur dann so mit den Leuten auch reden, wenn ich das Gefühl habe, dass ich auch selber da noch was Neues beizutragen habe. Dass ich jetzt nicht nur so ein MeToo-Ding da abliefer und mit sich unbedingt gesprochen, sondern möchte ich halt irgendwie das Gespräch auf eine Art und Weise leiten und gestalten, wo vielleicht mal ein paar Aspekte dabei rauskommen, wo so, ah, das ist ja mal eine gute Frage, weißt du?
Was mir gefallen hat, war erstens sprachlich, aber auch so ein bisschen, weil es halt ein zwieträchtiges Thema ist. Also ein zwiespältiges Thema ist sein Rant über irgendwelche Hobbyforscher, die zu ihm ankommen und ihm erklären wollen, wie das Universum funktioniert. Das hat so ein bisschen einen leichten Touch von Arroganz, halt zu sagen, du hast das nicht studiert, geh doch endlich mal kacken. Auf der anderen Seite kann ich das aber sehr wohl nachverziehen, dass es gewisse Dinge gibt, gewisse Annahmen oder gewisse Grundvoraussetzungen, die man haben muss, um sich mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen. Das heißt für mich nicht, für ihn glaube ich auch nicht, dass man jetzt unbedingt ein Diplom unter einer Uni davon getragen haben muss, aber schon, dass man sich mal mit so Grundlagen zwei, drei Jahre beschäftigt hat, bevor man irgendwie anfängt, die Welt sich neu zu erklären. Oder insbesondere hinzugehen und eben so einem renovierten Wissenschaftler wie ihm, der auch selber ja Lehre betreibt, hinzugehen ist zu sagen, was du da, deine komische Quantenphysik ist ja alle für den Fuß und ich habe mal hier in den Chemtrails gelesen und da, das geht eigentlich ganz anders. Das fand ich sehr interessant, auch wie das halt eben auch sprachlich rübergebracht wurde, mal darüber auch mal zu diskutieren. Der hat halt so ein anderes Fan-Problem. Ja, wenn halt irgendwelche Leute immer hinkommen wollen, ihnen die Welt erklären, das ist schon mal sehr lustig. Insbesondere auch, wie er so meinte, das sind halt eben alle irgendwelche älteren Männer, weißer Männer, irgendwelche Ingenieure, die vor 50 Jahren mal an der S-Bahn herumgeschraubt haben und jetzt, wie gesagt, das hat so einen ganz leichten Touch, so ein bisschen von so einer Arroganz, von so einer, ja, ich hab das studiert und mach das so, aber trotzdem kann ich das sehr gut nachempfinden, diese komischen Formen da von Begegnung.
Genau, also wenn ihr auch wissen wollt, was dabei rausgekommen ist, dann kann ich euch die Sendung empfehlen. Wie gesagt, es gibt da noch sehr viele andere Sachen, wenn euch Harald Leschny interessiert. Ich sag echt nochmal, die Sendung über Moore und die Sendung über Düfte ist mit das Beste, was hier aus der Meter-Ebene rausgeflossen ist.
Ist das eine Sendung?
Ne, zwei.
Weil du gerade gesagt hast, so Moore und Düfte, das hat ja auch eine gewisse olfaktorische Verbindung.
Forschergeist 50, das war halt zu Düften. Da hab ich mich mit einem der renommiertesten Duftforscher überhaupt, also nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern überhaupt unterhalten, super Typ, der, wo wir also wirklich mal in großer Ausführlichkeit das Wesen des Riechens und das Wesen der Düfte etc. durchdekliniert haben. Und die Moore-Folge ist echt ein totales Highlight in meinen Augen, weil die, zum Beispiel Hans-Josef, das ist ein Holländer, der hier in Deutschland an der Universität Greifswald Moore-Kunde unterrichtet. Und der Typ ist der Hammer. Der Typ ist der Hammer. Also erstmal ein netter und wirklich wohlwissender Mensch. Er ist aber auch international extrem bekannt geworden, weil er ist derjenige, der das Thema Moore in die Klimadiskussion gebracht hat, weil er mit seiner Forschung in den letzten Jahrzehnten Dinge entdeckt hat, die gar keiner für möglich gehalten hat. Also er hat zum Beispiel mal ausgerechnet, wie viel CO2 durch trockengelegte Moore freigesetzt wird. Und die Zahlen sind ex orbitant. Also die paar wenigen Prozent der gesamten Moorfläche, die trockengelegt wurden, sind halt irgendwie zu, ich weiß nicht mehr genau die Zahl, aber so zehnmal so viel wie andere Flächen zum CO2-Beibrig, also so einen Hektar Moor trockengelegt, haut so viel raus wie ein Auto, was 150.000 Kilometer fährt, so die Größenordnung. Also so richtige CO2-Schleudern. Und das ist so eins unserer großen Probleme, dass wir so viel trockengelegte Moore haben, weil die halt einfach jetzt noch über Jahrhunderte CO2 ausdüsen.
Machen sie immer noch. Passiert nicht nur bei der Trockenlegung, sondern nach der Trockenlegung von jemandem umzugasen.
Permanent pumpen die einfach CO2, die furzen die ganze Zeit CO2 raus. Und deswegen ist sozusagen nicht nur dieses, nicht noch mehr trockenlegen, sondern ihr müsst mal schnell mal wieder auch alles bewässern.
Dann kann man das wieder abstellen, da wenn man da wieder Wasser reinmacht in die Wanne, weil es dann wieder gebunden wird oder?
Zumindest dann diese Ausdünstung endet, weil das CO2, was raus ist, ist dann raus, das kriegst du ja nie wieder rein. Und noch viele andere wirklich interessante Erkenntnisse über die Welt der Moor.
Dünstet dann das CO2 in das Wasser rein, bis wieder eine Firma wie Nestlé kommt und das als VELTA verkauft oder? Also mit CO2 gefülltes Wasser.
So, das mal so als Podcast-Tipp. Und außerdem, und da wollte ich jetzt eine kleine Brücke schlagen, ist Forschergeist der erste deutsche Podcast. Soweit ich weiß. Der nicht nur komplett transkribiert vorliegt, sondern wo diese Transkripte auch im Web, im Webplayer live, während man die Sendung abspielt, mitzulesen sind.
Lustige Interfaces.
Und wo die Transkription auch durchsuchbar ist. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt irgendeinen Aspekt, den du vorhin bei Harald Lesch genannt hast, mal nachschlagen möchte. Was hattest du vorhin kurz erwähnt? Die alten Chemtrails irgendwie, suchen wir doch mal danach. Man kann jetzt hier den Webplayer öffnen und kriegt dann halt das komplette Transkript der Sendung so vor die Nase. Man kann dann halt darin auch suchen. Chemtrails, interessanterweise gab es keine.
Hatte das gesagt? Nee, nee, das war eher so, welche obskuren Hobbyforscher.
Forscher gibt es schon. So, dann kann man halt danach suchen. Und dann halt die...
Er hat so ein bisschen rumgelästert über Ingenieure. Tipp doch mal Ingenieur da ein.
So, erstmal wissen wir, wie man das schreibt. Genau, steht dann meistens ein älterer Herr vor mir, irgendein Diplom-Ingenieur oder sowas, und dann kriegt man da einen verpasst. Und sie sammeln sich eben durch das Internet inzwischen und schlagen sich gegenseitig auf die Schultern. Das war jetzt ein Zitat. So, weil kann man halt jetzt abspielen und...
Also da kann man jetzt auch, wenn man das da gesucht hat, könnte ich jetzt auf Play drücken und dann würde ich auch an der Stelle auch playen, oder wie?
Genau, ich kann jetzt hier einfach auf Play drücken und dann müsste das kommen.
Man muss ja erstmal da hinladen.
Meistens ein älterer Herr vor mir, irgendein Diplom-Ingenieur oder sowas und dann kriegt man da einen verpasst. Und die sammeln sich eben durch das Internet inzwischen und schlagen sich gegenseitig auf die Schultern. Und wenn ich das dann mal wirklich mache mit jemandem, und dann merke ich eben, der Physik nicht studiert hat und die entsprechende mathematische Kenntnis hat, der kann mit mir, also so einen Marathon nicht laufen.
Das ist schon geil jetzt, oder? Also deswegen ist das da, ne?
Weißt du, hast du ihm das geschrieben? Was geschrieben? Na, dass der Podcast, den du mit ihm aufgenommen hast, jetzt auch transkribiert und durch Super ist?
Ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher, ob ich das im Vorfeld nicht schon erwähnt habe.
Als die Folge rauskam, war sie ja noch nicht transkribiert.
Nee, aber...
Das kam ja nach.
Ja, aber wir machen das ja schon von... Also die Transkripte existierten schon länger. Wir hatten schon von Anfang an das gemacht, bloß die lagen bloß in so einem komischen Textformat vor. Das hatte ich zwar verlinkt, und das kann man sich runterladen, aber es entfaltet natürlich erst jetzt richtig sein ganzer Power in dem Moment, wo es halt wirklich im Player mit drin ist. Wir haben jetzt noch nicht alle angeschrieben. Haben wir noch mal vor, denen das zu sagen. Hier, Transkript von eurem Podcast ist verfügbar, et cetera. Das muss man sagen, das Ganze ist jetzt ein Beta-Feature von dem PodLav Publisher und von dem Webplayer. Da ist jetzt noch nicht ganz alles fertig. Während wir das jetzt hier eingebaut haben, fallen natürlich Dinge auf.
Manuelle Transkription.
Ja, in dem Fall ist es eine manuelle Transkription. Und jetzt kommen wir eigentlich auch genau. Das macht die Evita. Die ist ja professionelle Transkriptorin. Da werfe ich dann halt die fertig geschnittene Sendung in die Dropbox und dann kommt da hinten irgendwann ein fertiges Transkript raus. Wobei man eben sagen muss, manuelle Transkriptionen ist halt gegenüber einer automatischen Transkription immer noch ganz weit vorne. Also das ist natürlich teurer, weil mehr Zeit.
Die muss das ja in Realtime, sie muss ja die ganze Sendung hören, vielleicht sogar mehrfach. Und ich glaube, ist sie schneller als Realtime?
Nein.
Weißt du das, ob sie das jetzt mit höherer Geschwindigkeit hört?
Das hängt immer vom Sprecher ab. Es gibt Sprecher, die muss man eher runterdrehen. Es gibt welche, da kann man vielleicht noch ein bisschen das schneller machen.
Ich meine, dann sitzt halt eben auch mindestens zwei Stunden an dem Ding. Das ist ja auch so ein Punkt.
Ja, das hat ja dann auch mal ein bisschen was mit der Komplexität des Gesprochenen zu tun. Begriffe, Pipapo oder eben auch wie konfus die Leute reden. Weil das Transkript, was jetzt hier ist, ist ja kein Worttranskript. Also ist nicht mit jedem Äh und jedes Wort genauso, wie es gesagt wurde, sondern das ist ein, weiß nicht, gibt es jetzt keinen Fachbegriff dafür, aber das ist ein Transkript, in dem im Wesentlichen steht, was gesagt werden sollte.
Von so Zwischensachen quasi bereinigt.
Ja, also wenn ich jetzt sage, und der Satz war total verworren, dann steht da halt nur, der Satz war total verworren. Weil das R ist nicht wichtig, diese Wiederholung ist nicht wichtig. Oder wenn man halt irgendwie grammatikalisch was verdreht hat, oder der Satz so ein bisschen, manchmal denkt man ja in die eine Richtung in der ersten Hälfte. Also gesprochenes und geschriebenes sind schon immer noch zwei Sachen. Aber das Transkript ist halt, versucht das rüber zu bringen, was gesagt wurde, in einer Form, so wie man es lesen möchte. Das kann man auch anders machen. Es gibt ja auch andere Use-Cases geben, wo man wirklich so jedes Wort genau und jedes Äh, damit man die noch zählt und so, leg ich jetzt nicht so einen großen Wert drauf. Viel wichtiger ist halt, dass dieses Transkript die Person codiert. Das ist ja hier in dem Transkript-Viewer auch mit drin. Das heißt, du siehst halt immer genau, wer redet da. Und du siehst halt eben auch die einzelnen Textblöcke, die halt immer so eine eigene Zeitmarke haben. Deswegen kann ich jetzt so relativ genau zielgerichtet auf so einen Satz springen. Bei automatischem Transkriptionssystem hast du natürlich den Vorteil, dass du im Prinzip für jedes einzelne Wort das Timing hast oder im Idealfall bekommst. Kann man machen. Ist nicht ganz so wichtig, wie ich finde. Wenn die Zeitmarken an sich stimmen, reicht es vollkommen aus, wenn du am Anfang eines Satzes bist, weil du willst eigentlich selten mitten in den Satz reingehen. Und selbst wenn du dann am Anfang bist, dann ist egal, die paar Sekunden. Also, das soll ja kein DJ-Tool sein, sondern das soll uns in die Lage versetzen, was zu finden. Und das haben wir im Prinzip eben genauso demonstriert. Ja, also das ist ein Feature, was irgendwann in der nächsten Version vom PodLav Publisher dann auch noch mit dazu kommt. Und ich hoffe, dass wir dann bis dahin auch ein paar Antworten noch auf Fragen gefunden haben, die sich im Vorfeld schon gestellt haben, bzw. die es noch wichtiger werden, wenn man sich damit beschäftigt, weil dieser ganze Workflow von dem Einsammeln von Transkriptionen im richtigen Format und das Einspielen, da muss man doch einiges bedenken. Und außerdem bietet natürlich dieses Feature jetzt auch noch eine ganze Menge Sachen, die man natürlich unbedingt tun will. Also Transkripte allein sind schon mal ganz gut und helfen ja verschiedenen Leuten. Also stell mal vor, du lernst Deutsch. Und du möchtest dann ganz gerne dein Deutsch feilen anhand von echten Sprechern. Und da ist ein Podcast ja eigentlich super, weil interessante Themen und nicht so ein aufgesetztes Zeug, sondern normale Sprache, so wie du sie eben sonst auch hören würdest. Aber du hast halt die Möglichkeit, den Podcast zu hören und nebenbei kannst du halt mitlesen, was eigentlich gesagt wurde. Obwohl an der Stelle vielleicht ein Wortprotokoll dann wiederum interessanter wäre. Aber so oder so hilft es. Oder Leute, die halt in irgendeiner Form andere Einschränkungen haben, wo sowas ganz gut ist.
Es eröffnet dir jetzt den Zugang zu einer ganz anderen Nutzergruppe. Es gibt Leute, die sonst an Podcasts einfach vorbeigehen, nämlich Gehörlose. Podcasts sind komplett nutzlos für Gehörlose. Jetzt mit Transkriptionen sind sie eben nicht mehr nutzlos für Gehörlose.
Genau. Oder sagen wir mal überhaupt generell auch Schwerhörige, die vielleicht etwas Probleme haben, das zu hören. Leute mit Cochlearimplantaten, für die das Abhören so von elektronischen Sprachaufzeichnungen möglich, aber nicht unbedingt optimal ist. Klar, wo du vielleicht auch dein Hören trainieren kannst deswegen. Und was natürlich auch noch eine Riesenchance ist, wenn man jetzt, das ist jetzt für meine Podcastlandschaft jetzt noch nicht so das Ding, aber angenommen ich mache jetzt halt mal so den Podcast des Jahres, bei dem alle reden.
Diese Sendung jetzt hier.
Genau, und ich werde dann den Übersetzer ransetzen, unser Geschwurbel hier irgendwie in drei Sprachen übersetzen. Aber man kann sich ja durchaus vorstellen, dass ich halt, weil irgendwas Relevanz hat, das vielleicht auch mal übersetzen lassen möchte.
Hast du das mal spaßesweise, was da rausgekommen ist, das ist ja schön in so ein Format mal in so eine Google-Maschine reingeschmissen und geguckt, ob das, was da hinten rauskommt, noch irgendwie Sinn macht?
Nee, hab ich nicht. Ist sicherlich überarbeitungswürdig am Schluss. So mit DeepL, da haben wir ja schon mal drüber gesprochen, könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass da ganz brauchbare Ergebnisse dabei rauskommen.
Ist ja bei YouTube schon so, ne? Bei vielen Videos?
Naja, also das kommt, diese Übersetze rein, aber das hält man natürlich auch ganz gerne dann für diesen Player, diese Möglichkeit. Also wenn der Bedarf irgendwann besteht. Vorher allerdings ist natürlich noch viel interessanter, die Transkripte eben so maschinenlesbar zu haben, dass du sie dann eben auch auf der Webseite noch besser zum Einsatz bringen kannst. Sagen wir mal, dass du so eine Suche über alle Podcasts hast. Also stell dir mal vor, wir hätten jetzt alle Freak Shows transkribiert. Und wenn nicht perfekt in manueller Form, ist es durchaus vorstellbar, dass ich mir so in der nächsten Zeit mal die Sendung schnappe und die mal alle durch diese automatischen Transkriptionssysteme durchnudel. Das Ergebnis ist so, so naja, ja, ich würde sagen, du hast so in jedem Satz, ist mal irgendwie, also, ist noch zu schlecht. Man ist über, naja, also es ist sehr gut, um am Ende was zu bekommen, wo du dann nach Dingen suchen kannst. Es wird aber schwierig, wenn diese Dinge eigene Namen sind, so komische Produktnamen.
Wie wir dazwischen quatschen, so wie jetzt, wird das eh schwer. Das kann der ja gar nicht abbilden.
Das dazwischen quatschen ist noch das geringere Problem, weil ich natürlich keine Summe dadurch schicken würde, sondern die einzelnen Spuren. Ich nehme ja die Freak Show schon seit Jahr und Tag in Blutteig auf.
Ja, aber muss ja trotzdem irgendwie dargestellt werden. Weil es findet ja am Ende trotzdem gleichzeitig statt. Also zum Suchen ist natürlich okay, aber so zum Mitlesen irgendwie?
Das geht.
Das kann der jetzt schon, wenn was gleichzeitig ist, dann werden die auch beide gleichzeitig markiert. Stehen aber hintereinander. Ja, das ist das geringere Problem. Es geht halt nur darum, ob die automatischen Systeme was Sinnvolles rauswerfen und ob das dann sozusagen auch was bringt. Aber es wäre zumindest schon mal ein Start. Da müsste man sich halt überlegen, ob man das wirklich so in den Player bringt oder mit welchen... Das ist so ein Ding, über den man jetzt nochmal nachdenken muss. Automatische Systeme sind natürlich verlockend, weil sie natürlich potenziell die Kosten senken. Allerdings ist es mehr Aufwand, heutzutage ein automatisches Transkript zu nehmen und das in was Ordentliches zu überführen, als es von vornherein manuell transkribieren zu lassen. Ich glaube, da wird noch ein bisschen Zeit vergeben.
Ich habe jetzt Spaßes halber gerade eben mal irgendein Ding genommen und so einen größeren Textblock von Harald Lesch habe ich mal reingeschmissen in Google Translate und dem mal so ein, zwei Sprachen mal übersetzen lassen. Das ist durchaus lesbar. Das ist jetzt nicht sinnabweichend oder sonst irgendwas. Mal sitzt ein Komma falsch oder so, aber das ist durchaus brauchbar. Das ist ja der Vorteil, wenn du das jetzt satzweise machst, kannst du die Satzweise in die Google Translation mit reinmachen. Dann hast du immer noch diesen mitlaufenden Block dort, d.h. weißt du immer noch, wo du da bist. Und das macht durchaus Sinn. Also das könnte man durchaus mal weiter untersuchen. Diese Richtung zumindest. Man kann ja immer noch sagen, ich kann mir jetzt für bestimmte Sprachen, mach ich das halt manuell, weil ich da jemanden finde, weil ich da Volunteers für habe, die das schick machen. Und für den hinter Serbo-Kroatischen Dialekt, da lass ich halt Google den Job machen. Oder für Malay, weil ich hab grad nicht so viele Malayische.
Ja, also man muss natürlich schauen, was ist da die Zielgruppe. Macht das überhaupt Sinn? Weil wenn ich mich jetzt mit Harald Lesch irgendwie die Situation der Wissenschaftslandschaft in Deutschland unterhalte, weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie viele Leute das in Georgien hinter dem Ofen herholt. Das ist natürlich dann...
Georgisch vielleicht nicht, aber in anderen Sprachen gibt ja sehr viele Deutschland, sind ja sehr viele ausländische Forscher, die vielleicht jetzt nicht notwendigerweise...
Fokus Europa, das Ganze auch noch auf Französisch und Englisch, wenn man sich über europäische Themen unterhält. Und vielleicht ist das gerade für eine europäische Konversation mal ganz interessant. Klar. Steht aber jetzt erstmal nicht so im Vordergrund. Jetzt müssen wir erstmal das mit den Transkripten an sich erstmal hinkriegen. Weil da gibt es schon noch ein paar Herausforderungen. Wie man die schreibt, wie man die formatiert. Es gibt auch einen Format-Bedarf. Derzeit verwenden wir intern, das traue ich mich fast gar nicht zu sagen, dieses unsägliche Web VTT-Format, was von diesem noch unsäglicheren SRT-Format, was so, das musst du auch kennen, hier Subrib, irgendwie diese SRT-Files mit Subtitles für Videos. Lass dich doch mal mit Videos im Internet beschäftigt.
Ich hab jetzt Netflix.
Na dann, aber du weißt noch, SRT-Dateien und so.
Die, die man immer von Hand suchen muss.
Genau, diese Untertitel-Dateien, das sind halt Untertitel-Formate. Das ist irgendwie das, was derzeit bei automatischen Speech-Systemen wie auf Phonix, Phonix-Hand- und Frontend dafür rausfällt. Deswegen haben wir das irgendwie mal implementiert, aber das ist nicht optimal. Das Problem ist, es gibt halt auch sonst nichts Optimales. Und ist man am Grübeln über ein ordentliches XML-basiertes Transkriptionsformat, was dann halt auch alle Dinge abbildet, die man eben so gerne abbilden möchte, da gibt es halt meines Wissens nichts. Und diese Untertitel-Dinger sind halt nur begrenzt zu gebrauchen. Du kriegst ja einfach mehr als Sprecher, wer spricht, von wann bis wann Satz, kriegst du da halt nicht rein. Aber andere Informationen, die man eben auch noch gerne haben möchte, sind nicht so ohne weiteres zu machen. Also zum Beispiel alleine die Strukturierung in Sätzen ist schwierig. Jetzt kannst du natürlich sagen, okay, bei Default ist immer so ein Untertitel-Eintrag ist ein Satz, aber der kann ja auch mal über fünf Zeilen gehen. Das Untertitel kannst du eh nicht benutzen, aber es wäre dann auch eher so eine Konvention. Und vor allem, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, dass man diese Transkripte ja nicht nur unbedingt jetzt auf einem Bildschirm anzeigen möchte, sondern dass man diese Transkripte gegebenenfalls auch, das ist zum Beispiel etwas, was ich gerne machen möchte, ich möchte gerne diese Transkripte auch in einer ordentlichen gedruckten Fassung machen. Das ist natürlich der Reiz, dass wenn ich jetzt wirklich so einen interessanten Podcast habe, Das ist Freak Show Buch. Zum Nachlesen, oh Mann.
Freak Show Complete.
Stell dir mal vor, man macht jetzt wirklich so ein nettes Gespräch. Du hast eine Transkription, die im Wesentlichen wiedergibt, was gesagt werden sollte. Dann ist das ja schon lesbar. Und dann willst du es aber natürlich auch ordentlich formatieren und möchtest es aus diesem maschinenlesbaren Format, das möglichst auch in einer lesbaren Form übertragen, damit du dann eben automatisch so ein PDF erzeugen kannst. Und dann kommst du relativ schnell an so Stellen mit, ah ok, es muss irgendwie sichergestellt werden, dass alles in Sätzen aufgebaut ist und du möchtest eigentlich diese Sätze auch in Absätze machen, weil du hast halt unter Umständen längere Monologe, die aber dann mehrere Gedanken zusammenfassen und wenn du da halt nur so einen riesigen grauen Textblockbrei hin haust, dann ist das zwar technisch ok, aber funktioniert dann nicht.
Warum ist das in dem Interface so, dass zum Beispiel Harald Lesch, der ja gerne auch mal längere Monologe hält, der taucht aber dann sozusagen in mehreren Absätzen jetzt schon auf, wo immer unser Bildchen und der Name da dran steht?
Das ist, glaube ich, damit sich der Sprechername immer wiederholt, relativ zu der Fenstergröße.
Achso, das heißt selbst wenn ich oben scrollt, ich sehe immer mindestens einmal, wer da gerade am babbeln ist.
Genau, das ist auch noch eine Arbeit, da kann man das auch um so spät lassen.
Das macht die Software von alleine oder hat das Evita mit reinkodiert, diese Absatz-Aufteilung?
Evita macht es so, dass halt nach jedem Satz eine Zeitmarke ist. Das heißt im Format ist es quasi nach...
Sie macht keine Blöcke, keine Unterteilung?
Nein, aber sie macht keine Unterteilung. Die Unterteilungen sind automatisch aus dem Display-Bedarf herausgegeben. Und das ist halt genau das Problem. Es gibt halt derzeit noch kein Format, in dem ich halt auch so eine Absatzstruktur noch mit reinkodieren könnte. Auf Phonic hat so einen kleinen Hack in seinem XML-Format, wo es dann so, wenn eine längere Gedankenpause ist, also bestimmt ein Pausen-Threshold, dann gibt es dann noch mal so eine Markierung für, hier könnte ein Absatz stehen und so. Ja, das geht alles so ein bisschen in die richtige Richtung, muss man halt schauen. Ja, und dann ist halt auch die Frage, wie macht man das Timing, was ist jetzt, wenn irgendwie ein langer Satz gesagt wird, der aber dann irgendwie Pausen drin hat, will man dann noch eine feinere Zeitauflösung, will man nicht eigentlich eine Zeitmarke für jedes Wort haben, was ist mit Metadaten, wenn man so ein Datei nimmt und austauscht, dann willst du halt eigentlich auch die ganzen Metadatentitel der Sendung, wer spricht da eigentlich etc. reinhaben. Und Avatare und sowas. Und was natürlich dann auch irgendwann automatisch kommt, ist natürlich die Frage, meine Fresse, wenn ihr schon das Transkript habt, warum hängen dann nicht einfach auch noch die Links an den richtigen Stellen? So, ich sag Google und warum gehe ich nicht zu Google, wenn ich auf Google klicke? Und wenn ich von Webseite XY spreche, das ist genau der richtige Ort, wo man Show Notes haben. Und dann... Oder Tooltips.
Fährst halt rüber und dann sieht man halt irgendwie noch Inline Show Notes.
Wie auch immer, du kannst da halt blaue Unterstriche machen, aber du kannst halt irgendwie auch alles andere einfallen. Dann willst du halt Versionsnummern haben, du möchtest so Last Modified Timestamps haben, du willst vielleicht Kommentare und Autoren unterbringen und so weiter. Also das ist ein Rattenschwanz, den man da noch bedenken muss und das sind so Dinge, über die wir halt gerade nachdenken bei Pottlove. Juhu!
Bist du vor, dat huggelt nicht hier?
Letty kann nicht mehr.
Letty kann langsam auf diesem Stuhl nicht mehr sitzen.
Kannst du ja auch hinstellen. Man kann sich auch andersrum auf diesen Stuhl setzen.
Ich hab in jeder Position heute schon auf diesem Stuhl gelümpelt. Doch, hab ich heute auch schon.
Andersrum?
Ja, weil dann kann man nämlich hinten die Beine drauflegen.
Ist auch ganz praktisch. So soll man ja nach vorne. Aber gut, geht natürlich auch.
So ist das gedacht.
Dann trotzdem nicht mehr.
Also, seh ich das richtig, wenn wir reden heute nicht über Macs?
Doch.
Wollen wir das noch bearbeiten?
Nee, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich hab noch was ganz Kleines.
Ich will noch eine kleine Sache hinterherschmeißen. Und zwar, und ich hole jetzt auch bewusst nicht groß auf. Ich wollte nur auch noch mal kurz das mit den Transkripten auch noch mal klar machen, dass wir jetzt irgendwie bei PodLav denken wir über Dinge nach, die so in die Zukunft gehen. Und das ist nicht im Ansatz das Einzige, worüber wir diskutieren und wo wir überlegen, wie wir das Ganze machen können. Eine andere Sache, die wir auch überlegen ist, was heißt überlegen, wo wir uns eigentlich schon sehr sicher sind, dass das stattfinden wird, nur noch nicht so in welcher Geschwindigkeit. Das ist ja alles PHP-Kram, der PodLav Publisher zum Veröffentlichen und lebt in WordPress. Und was ist das Problem damit? Bist halt nicht zukunftskompatibel, wenn du irgendwie in PHP-Poamierst und schon gar nicht in WordPress bist.
Du bist schon nicht vergangenheitskompatibel.
Das ist eigentlich nicht kompatibel. Das auch noch. Weder zukunfts- noch vergangenheitskompatibel. Und die Transkripte und ShowNotes-Ideen und so Crowdsourcing und so eine Geschichten und noch einige andere, advancedere Ideen, die uns so vorschweben, wohin die Reise hier eigentlich mal gehen müsste, ist halt einfach auf der Plattform nicht zu machen. Und wir haben jetzt in letzter Zeit einige, ist schon einige Zeit geflossen in Prototypen und auch in laufende Systeme, die in einem komplett neuen Environment entstanden sind, nämlich in Alexia und Phönix. Haben wir ja schon öfter darüber gesprochen. Kurze Erinnerung, Alexia ist quasi so der neue Syntax-Ansatz für die Erlang-Welt. Wer Erlang programmiert, kann auch genauso gut Alexia machen, das hat dieselbe Mächtigkeit. Und man kann in Alexia alles machen, was man in Erlang macht und umgekehrt. Man kann sich gegenseitig callen und es lebt in derselben Welt und denkt dieselben Konzepte, schreibt sich bloß anders. Und dadurch, dass es aus dieser Ruby-Welt kam, also der Typ dieser Ruby-Welt entflohen ist, aber quasi eine andere Vorstellung von Syntax hatte, ist dann halt eben Alexia entstanden und relativ schnell ist damit dann eben auch dieses Phönix-Framework noch mit dazu gekommen. Und das Phönix-Framework gehört halt zu Alexia sowie Rails zu Ruby. Und es ist erstaunlich, was da entsteht. Und das ist auf jeden Fall eine Plattform, mit der man super in die Sonne gehen kann.
Mit dem Phönix?
Ja, das performt einfach wie Hölle. Und das bietet einfach alle Freiheiten und Zuverlässigkeiten. Und ich bin da hoffnungsfroh, dass wir auf der Basis viel von dem machen können, was halt derzeit in so einer PHP-Welt noch nicht mal vorstellbar ist. Wo das einfach nicht geht. Wo du das einfach komplett vergessen kannst. Und deswegen was anderes machen. Und ich frage mich, ob da draußen unter euch Leute sind, die vielleicht in dieser Umgebung schon Erfahrung haben oder sich da zumindest gerade reinarbeiten und da sozusagen auch schon so ein bisschen das Licht gesehen haben und vielleicht noch nicht so 100 Prozent für irgendein Startup ausgeschlachtet werden. Dann würde ich mich freuen, wenn ihr euch bei uns meldet, denn wir können da etwas Verstärkung vertragen. Wir haben, glaube ich, ein paar ganz heiße Ideen, wohin die Reise hier gehen kann. Da sind Transkripte noch das kleinste Ding. Und es sind wirklich sexy Anwendungen, die wir da in Angriff nehmen wollen. Und da können wir dann Verstärkung gebrauchen. Nicht nur von Alexion, Phoenix Leuten, sondern gegebenenfalls auch Leuten, die im Bereich UI, UX unterwegs sind, also die so Web-Frontend-Kram-Erfahrungen haben und da bereit sind mitzumachen. Wir haben ja durch den Alex im Webplayer-Bereich riesige Fortschritte gemacht. Also noch vor einem anderthalb Jahr dachte ich, wir kommen nirgendswann irgendwo noch hin. Mittlerweile haben wir eigentlich alle Ziele erreicht, die wir uns so gesteckt haben für ein Jahr. Und weitere Dinge für den Webplayer sind in Arbeit. Und werden sicherlich auch in naher Zukunft noch mit dazukommen. Der Player wird noch ein paar richtig geile Tänze machen. Ein paar coole Features und Tricks lernen. Ja, und jetzt wird es mal wieder Zeit, sich mal wieder so ein bisschen zu verstärken. Und da der Ralf ja hier so erfolgreich für sein Ultraschall-Team geworben hat, dachte ich mir, das müssten wir ja hier eigentlich auch mal für Potluff hinbekommen. Also, tummelt euch und klopft an, auf das wir gemeinsam in die Zukunft schreiten.
Wir müssen ja ein bisschen über Macs reden. Ich mach mal den Anfang, damit alle warm werden. Also sozusagen ich mach jetzt so das kleine Strohfeuer, das dann das große Feuer anzündet, wenn das immer noch klappt. Und zwar hab ich vor schon vielen Wochen von irgendeinem Hörer, ich weiß den Namen leider nicht mehr, wieder mal was von der Wunschliste bekommen. Und zwar hab ich da drauf gesetzt ein Thunderbolt 3 Kabel. Aber nicht halt eben ein Ladekabel wie das, was bei so einem MacBook Pro, bei so einem aktuellen dabei liegt, womit man tatsächlich wirklich nur laden kann. Also vielleicht kann man auch USB 3 Sachen damit machen, weiß ich nicht, so USB C-mäßig, aber auf jeden Fall ist das nicht Thunderbolt-tauglich. Deswegen hab ich da mal ein Thunderbolt-taugliches Kabel auf die Amazon-Liste gesetzt. Das kam dann irgendwann und dann bin ich in den Club gegangen oder hab das mal beigehabt und hab gewartet, bis mal einer kommt, auch mit so einem neuen MacBook Pro. Da gibt's ja noch nicht so viele von. Und dann haben wir den Trans... Heißt der Transport-Modus? Das, was man früher mit dem Firewire-Kabel zwischen zwei Macs machen konnte.
Target-Disc-Modus.
Target-Disc-Modus, so hieß er genau. Nicht Transport-Target-Disc-Modus, genau. Den haben wir gecheckt. Funktioniert 1A Sahne, aber mit 10 Gigabit.
Mit welchem Kabel?
Mit einem Thunderbolt 3-Kabel.
Ja.
Also es hat auch USB-C-Stecker, aber es ist halt Thunderbolt-tauglich. Das ist halt das normale Ladekabel, das große weiße lange, was bei Apple dabei ist, ist halt nicht Thunderbolt 3-tauglich. Das ist halt wirklich nur ein USB oder vielleicht sogar nur ein Ladekabel. Also da kann man diese Thunderbolt-Geschichten nicht mitfahren. Wahrscheinlich könnte damit man auch kein externes GPU-Ding ins Betreiben. Da braucht man auch ein Thunderbolt 3-Kabel, richtig? Genau. Jedenfalls habe ich das genommen. Target-Disk-Modus und schwupp. Nach so ein paar Sekunden kommt das andere Laufwerk. 10 Gigabit. So und dann haben wir...
Warum eigentlich nur 10? Thunderbolt 3 sollte doch 20 oder 40G sein oder so was.
Ja, aber die machen da... Beim Target-Disk-Modus habe ich den Speed gar nicht gecheckt. Deswegen kann ich jetzt mal nur annehmen, dass es 10 sind. Aber wir haben noch die einfach mal während der Rechner läuft, dass er dann keinen Target-Disk-Modus, sondern so reingesteckt. Und dann kriegt man halt ein Netzwerk-Interface und da drüber kommen nur 10.
Weil es als 10 Gigabit Internet-Interface agiert.
Warum?
Na, weil sie vielleicht ja doch nochmal wirklich einen Stein haben, der da das Ethernet machen muss.
Na, weil das nächste wäre ja 100.
Es gibt auch 25, äh 25G und 40.
Leitung ist doch Leitung.
Leitung ist Leitung. Niemand sagt, dass ein Ethernet nicht auch mit 42,23 Gigabit laufen.
Aber trotzdem muss ja da noch ein Chip sein, der das macht, oder? Nja, ist ja nicht so ganz...
Du hast ja eh schon deinen Thunderbolt 3-Grassel da drin. Das ist ja der Chip, der die Bits durch die Gegend... Ob der jetzt noch ein Ethernet-Käfer emuliert drum herum, würde das eher für aufwändiger halten zu sagen, wir bauen hier eine lustige Hardware, die da 20G macht und jetzt stricken wir noch eine Software drum rum, die mir das wieder aus irgendwelchen wahnwitzigen Gründen wieder auf 10 Gigabit limitiert.
Eigentlich schon. Ist mir auch nicht klar, aber es ist wohl auch offiziell so, wenn du das als Internet, also als... Ich sage das Kabelersatz, wie auch immer man das nennt, nutzt, dann sind das nur 10 Gigabit. Von den möglichen 40, weil Thunderbolt 3 kann ja 40.
Mindestens 20, aber 40...
Mindestens 20.
Ist glaube ich 2 mal 20, oder?
Keine Ahnung.
So, jetzt ist aber der Witz.
Vielleicht macht er ja 10 in jede Richtung, sind ja auch 20.
Also, wie hast du denn gemessen?
Iperf 3.
Und du hast, der ist doch auch an den Anschlag geraten, oder fing denn eher... Fingend erdet, Iperf 3 anzuschließen.
Ne, 10,0, irgendwas.
Mit einer Parallel-Session.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das Ding das selber misst, aber ich hab nur einen so einen Iperf gestartet.
Ja, du kannst aber mit Minus P, Groß P, glaube ich, anziehen sagen oder wenn nicht.
Ja, ich hab also nur mit den Defaults gestartet. So, jetzt kommt der eigentliche, weil ich mach das ja nicht aus Langeweile alles, ne? Ich hab natürlich, weil, wenn man mal guckt, und ich glaub, die Interfaces auf Macs sind auch schon per Default alle vorne, auch wenn man so ein Kabel nicht benutzt, man hat ein Interface, das Bridge 0 heißt. Und wenn man da guckt, dann werden dort vier weitere Interfaces zu diesem Bridge zusammengefasst. Und das sind genau die vier Anschlüsse. Das heißt, wenn du ein Kabel reinsteckst, wo auch immer, dann landet das sozusagen in dein Bridge 0 Interface. Wenn das jetzt Bridge 0 heißt, irgendwas mit Bridge, müsst ihr mal gucken.
Software Bridge, das heißt, du willst mir sagen, du hast jetzt eine Hardware Bridge. 4-Port-10G-Switch auf dem Tisch.
Genau, jetzt ist die Frage, was passiert, wenn ich zwei so eine Kabel nehme? Und weil wir ja ein Gemeinschaftsunternehmen sind, habe ich noch so ein Kabel auf meiner Wunschliste gesetzt. Und der Erste, der mir das halt zukommen lässt, ich werde das natürlich gleich sofort austesten, nur für euch. Ich habe die Vermutung, dass wenn man zwei nimmt, dass diese Bridge dann zwei zusammenfasst. Ich bin mir halt nicht ganz so sicher. Ich habe auch so ein bisschen die Vermutung, dass sie das nicht machen, sondern dass das nur dafür da ist, dass es egal ist, welchen Port du nimmst, dein Interface immer gleiche.
Aber was du jetzt gerade machen willst, das ist so genannte Link Aggregation von der 2.3 AD.
Kann ja senden, dass das da gleich mit drin ist.
Nee, wenn das da gleich mit drin wäre, müsste das auch LACP sprechen. LACP ist der Mechanismus, der dafür sorgt, dass die Dinger sich automatisch verbinden.
Dann guck dir mal rein in dieses Bridge-Interface.
Ich habe das Bridge-Interface nicht. Nein?
Ich kann schwören, ich habe das bei mir auch vorher schon mal gesehen, bevor ich so ein Kabel da reingesteckt habe.
Du kannst das aber von Hand konfigurieren. Da kann man gerne drüber unterhalten, wenn du sagst, du hast jetzt zwei Rechner und zwei so eine Kabel.
Hab das unterfrieden, hast du dich schon gewartet, ich weiß, wie das geht.
Jetzt kommen wir aber wieder zu dem Thema.
Bridge 0 hier. Members EN1, EN2, EN3 und EN4. Das ist alles Thunderbolt.
Ja, das heißt aber nicht, dass du die automatisch... Das kann höchstens sein, dass wenn da kein LRCP oder irgendwas drauf ist, dass du dir mal eine schöne Schleife baust, wenn du jetzt zwei Rechner mit zwei Kabeln zusammensteckst. Das wirst du dann schon merken.
Was macht die Bridge, wenn zwei Member aktiv sind?
Die bridge die zusammen. Und wenn die andere Seite das auch macht, hast du dann eine schöne Schleife gebaut. Aber ich sage dir, das merkst du. Das merkst du an der Performance deines Rechners, wenn der plötzlich mit 10G eine Loop mit 10G macht, das merkst du.
Ist egal, ich wünsche dir gerne mal mit um-experimentieren.
Du kannst sie bündeln.
Und gucken, was passiert. Also bei mir ist das Interface. Ich könnte schwören, dass das auch schon vorher immer da war, dieses Bridge 0.
Ich hab's auch.
Okay, du hast nicht so einen neuen, ne?
Nee, ich hab hier vor allen Dingen auch nicht.
Dann hast du das ja auch nicht.
10, 13 oder?
Ja, aber ich hab auch nicht den neuen. Ich hab ja nur das Thunderbolt 2.
Ich verstehe.
Aber man kann die bündeln, was ich verrate dir oder ich mutmaße, wenn du die Dinger zusammen steckst, doch, dass du eine schöne Schleife baust, dass deine CPU an den Anschlag geht und deine Kiste plötzlich anfängt zu lüften.
Nee, dann zieh's wieder raus.
Ja, klar. Aber dann kübelst du halt 20G in der Loop durch die Gegend.
Also die Load bei den 10G-Tests, ich glaub, da war jetzt nicht so viel zu sehen, so ein bisschen, aber das reicht nicht.
Das macht er in der Software. Der hat ja dafür keinen Switch-Chip drin. Das heißt, er macht die Geschichte dann in der Software und das merkst du dann schon.
Na gut.
Wir werden es sehen, würde mich auch interessieren.
Ja, ich fand's auf jeden Fall mal nett, irgendwann mal was ein bisschen schneller zu sehen als ein Gigabit, weil die SSDs da drin und so weiter, der Flash, die können ja schon deutlich länger mehr schreiben als 100 Megabyte die Sekunde. Deswegen bräuchte man mal auch irgendwas, was ein bisschen schneller ist als ein Gigabit, um das mal annähernd zu saturieren.
Wenn du mal ein bisschen Zeit in Singapur verbringst, hab ich dir erzählt, kannst du ja für 120 Singapur-Dollar kannst du dir 10G Internet blicken.
Ja genau, und wenn ich dann Kaugummi kauer, kann ich das restliche Geld an Strafe zahlen. Nee, lass mal.
Du darfst Kaugummi kauen, darfst du bloß nicht auf die Straße spucken.
Wann hast du letztes Mal Kaugummi auf die Straße gespuckt?
Dieses Jahr noch nicht, glaube ich.
Das sollte man auch nicht tun.
Ich verfluche auch immer die Leute, wenn ich so was unter meinem Schuh habe.
Das ist ja gar nicht das Problem.
Sondern?
Na die schwarzen Flecken.
Ach die?
Sind dir schon mal die schwarzen Flecken auf Gehwegen aufgefallen? Das ist alles ausgespucktes Kaugummi.
Ja, hat mich schon mal aufgespuckt.
Die Scharzen, die man vor 30 Jahren mal hingespuckt hat.
Sind alles deine?
Nee, du machst da eigentlich gar keinen Kaugummi. Von daher, würde ich es auch in Singapur aushalten. Zumindest am Wochenende.
Geht schon.
Das war mein kurzer Einwurf zum Warmwerden mit Apple-Themen. Ich hoffe, es war nerdy genug.
Letty sieht schon so aus, als ob sie irgendwie gleich...
Aber Letty, gerade wir könnten das machen. Du mit deinem neuen Laptop. Wir könnten jetzt 10 Gigabit hin und her schieben.
Der steht oben. Der steht da gut.
Ich hatte schon Leute, die wollten von mir...
Aber warum haben wir das nicht ausprobiert, als ich letztens bei dir zocken war?
Was wollten wir aber skopieren?
Was weiß ich.
Nee, das war ja schon längst vorher, wo ich das getestet hab.
Warst du jetzt auch noch... Je schneller der Anschluss, desto geringer ist deine Latenz. Es hilft dir jetzt natürlich nix über einen lahmen 16-Megabit-Anschluss zum WoW-Server, aber zwischen den Maschinen habt ihr dann ziemlich geile Latenz.
Da hatten die schon mal jemanden da, also ich hatte schon jemanden, der wollte mal die Blockchain von mir haben. Da hab ich gesagt, ja hier so und so 150 GHz, ah nee, das dauert mir zu lange, lasst mal. Also mit so einem Kabel hättest du gedrückt und wutt wutt wutt wutt, fertig.
Na ja, die SSD hat natürlich auch nur eine begrenzte Geschwindigkeit.
Aber sie können mehr als einen Gigabit.
Ich stell mir gerade Dennis vor, mit so einem dicken, fetten, schweren Goldkette um den Hals, wo dann irgendwie so ein Thunderbolt bestückter Stein drauf ist, wo dann so eine Terabyte Kapazität immer so die aktuelle Blockchain.
Alter, wie willst du meine Blockchain sehen?
Ey, Joey, mein Block, mein Blockchain. Mein Block, mein Chain.
Mein Block, mein Chain. Willst du haben Blockchain, ich tu dir das sofort rein in Thunderbolt.
In schnell.
Irgendwann sehe ich dich auf der Waschmauerbrücke damit stehen.
Kriegst du geladen, Lan?
Brauchst du Block? Ich hab schon mal im Room 77 die Blockchain kopiert. Der hatte eine Samsung SSD, so eine externe bei, mit USB C3 irgendwas, weiß schon. Bei 10, 20, 30 Gigabyte Menge rüberkopiert ist sein SSD abgeraucht, wurde zu heiß. War eben zu viel. Und es war jetzt nicht im Sommer, es war letzten Winter zur High Time, November oder Oktober. Ich glaub November so.
Ich hab angeblich recht behalten, ich weiß noch nicht, ob es jetzt schon ein Beleg ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein weiteres Indiz, hat Twitter gesagt, also Leute auf Twitter. Ich dachte so, okay, was kommt jetzt? Und dann gab es so eine Meldung bei Bloomberg, dass wohl tatsächlich Apple plant, Arm-Prozessoren in ihre Macs reinzuhauen und zwar ab 2020.
Komm, ja, ein bisschen spät vor, aber ich hab ja bisher auch...
Woraufhin ist mal der Intel-Kurs erst mal...
Ich hab ja bisher auch unrecht gehabt, weil ich hab ja gesagt 2017, aber es war ja nix.
Ich find das jetzt nicht so unrealistisch.
Doch, viel zu spät.
Zu spät für was?
Für nix. Was heißt denn spät? Also umso früher, umso besser, würde ich ja sagen. Und ich finde, das ist schon ganz schön spät. Ich könnte mir das früher vorstellen.
Naja, die Frage ist, was hängt da noch alles dran?
Und wollen sie das gleich mit einem riesengroßen Schlag machen oder Stückchen für Stückchen? Und ich würde sagen, wenn das dann überhaupt alles stimmt, weil ich meine, können ja viele erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ja, also ob das jetzt stimmt, wissen wir nicht. So, das ist nur ein weiteres Indiz. Gerüchte gab es schon länger. Aber hier, Bloomberg hat ja an der Stelle einen relativ guten Track-Rekord. Also da ist ja dieser Mark Gurman dahinter. Das ist ja so das Trüffelschwein eigentlich so aus dieser ganzen...
Du fängst an zu gehen und alle anderen fangen halt auch an zu gehen.
Er ist halt schon spät.
Ich muss kurz einwerfen, das ist wichtig. Wissenschaftlicher Beitrag, das kannst du mit Cats machen. Du kannst die angehen und dann gehen die auch. Teste das mal aus. Oder die Hörer, die Katzen haben. Gehnt mal eure Katze an oder beobachte selber, wenn die Katze gint, müsst ihr auch gehen.
Oder stellt ihr einen gähnenden Dackel vor, dann müsst ihr selber gähnen.
Guck mal, unser Chat-Hörer Alex Zahlex gähnt auch schon.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob es da viel drüber zu reden gibt. So, die Frage ist natürlich, stimmt das jetzt? Und wenn ja, was bedeutet das so?
Also die Chips aus dem letzten Jahr waren schon scheiße krass schnell. Dann kommen die von diesem Jahr noch mal dazu. Dann die von 2019, also dann sind noch mal zwei neue Generationen dazwischen bis 2020. Dann die kommen, mit der sie dann sozusagen auf den Markt kommen wollen. Die Dinger fliegen bis dahin.
Vielleicht ist die Intel-Architektur halt auch wirklich ausgereizt. Und die arme Architektur bringt mehr. Vielleicht doch nicht. Ich habe immer noch das Gefühl, dass die mehr Push in Richtung neuronale Netze machen. Und deswegen wahrscheinlich auch einen stärkeren neuronalen Netze-Kram in ihre Chips einbauen werden. Und das werden sie von Intel nicht so schnell kriegen.
Sie können aber auch die normalen Bits mehr erhöhen, gerade in den Laptops, weil die Armzeugs deutlich weniger Strom verbrauchen. Da kannst du einfach mehr CPEQs einbauen, ohne dass der Akku gleich leer geht.
Ja, das bringt aber nichts, weil die Software von Apple das nicht hergibt.
Das ist ja ein anderes Thema.
Nach 2020 vielleicht schon.
Und ist das eigentlich auch eine andere Architektur? Oder trittst du dir damit auch genau so dieses Melter?
Das haben die auch. Aber das können die ja auch fixen. Das werden ja alle fixen.
Ob die das noch haben, die müssen das eh jetzt irgendwie fixen, oder andere Optimierungsstrategien.
Die müssen es eh fixen, ja.
Das halte ich jetzt aber auch für einen Randaspekt.
Es war ja auch ein Problem, was wirklich alle betroffen hat. Selbst ältere Power-PCs hatten das gehabt.
Also wenn sie da jetzt noch so zwei, drei Generationen, also wissen die, ob es drei oder zwei Generationen sind, die wir da jetzt noch abwarten müssen, weil 2020 kann ja Ende 2020 und Anfang 2020 sein. Also das ist so ein Nöse ums Spiel. Auf jeden Fall brauchen sie halt gute Antwort darauf, wie effizient kriegen sie halt die ganzen Apps mitgezogen. Und wir wissen, dass ja so auf dem Mac dann doch so die Zahl der Developer langsam über etwas überschaubar wird. Das heißt, auch die Pflege von alter Software geht nicht mehr so gut voran, sprich, der Verlust alter Software könnte halt signifikant sein. Das ist ein Problem. Während so bei iOS, du zwar jetzt mit jedem Technologiewechsel immer was abschneidest, aber eigentlich auch was abschneidest, was an sich auch schon irgendwie gestorben ist. Während alles, was irgendwie aktiv genutzte Software ist, halt relativ easy den Schritt gegangen ist auf 64-Bit etc. und Cutoffs mit anderen Betriebssystemen etc.
Wenn einer CPU wechseln kann, dann ist das doch echt Apple. Also so oft wie die das schon durchgezogen haben.
Ja gut, aber damals war ja, bei meinem letzten Wechsel, der Mac war ja das Business von Apple. Das heißt, alle, die irgendwie mit Apple-Kram gearbeitet haben, waren halt auf dem Mac, weil es gab halt gar nichts anderes. Jetzt ist es halt ganz anders. Jetzt ist das nur noch 10% des Business. Und man merkt ja, wie Developer halt weggegangen sind, um auf iOS zu reüssieren. Und das muss jetzt erstmal wieder zurückgewonnen werden. Da passt natürlich diese andere Gerüchtegeschichte dazu mit diesem Marzipan, oder wie sie es genannt haben. Also was auch immer da jetzt auf der WWDC vorgestellt werden soll, das werden wir wahrscheinlich relativ bald dann wissen. Wann ist das? Im Juni?
Oder?
So, also bald. Ich vermute mal, sie werden halt irgendeine Art Initiative machen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie umfangreich die sein wird, aber es geht halt so in die Richtung von, das Programmieren einer Mac App wird einfacher, wenn alles, was du bisher kanntest, iOS war. Ob es bedeutet, dass sie quasi dieses AppKit...
Na wahrscheinlich werden sie ein paar Frameworks unifine, oder?
Also AppKit hat so ein paar Altlasten, die müssen mal weg.
Na, werden nicht.
War ansonsten, keine Ahnung.
Also sie haben da sicherlich viele Hebel, an denen sie das machen könnten. Und ob sie irgendwie jetzt vielleicht auch ein Ding gefunden haben, wo sie in irgendeiner Form auch vom User-Interface-Appeal her so eine Unification von iOS, so iPad-Fullscreen-Apps und Mac-Fullscreen-Apps irgendwie zusammengefunden haben, so simple iTunes-mäßig, I don't know. Aber es würde ja schon ausreichen, wenn überhaupt dieses Lernen und wie rede ich mit meinem Betriebssystem, wenn sich das mehr anpassen würde. Und ich denke, da haben sie alle Möglichkeiten.
Ja, der Unterschied ist aber auch gar nicht so riesig.
Der ist nicht riesig, aber er ist halt noch da. Also ich weiß nicht, wie umfangreich das sein wird, aber ich vermute mal, da gehen sie in diese Richtung. Sodass wenn sie dann sagen, naja, holla, wir passen jetzt aber auch mal irgendwie alle Prozessoren an, dass sie was haben, wo sie sagen können, okay, aber seit zwei Jahren sind jetzt hier alle schon dabei, quasi zurück zu marschieren von iOS auf dem Mac, weil jetzt wird hier Development für euch einfacher, dass sie dann eben auch den entsprechenden Druck wieder haben. Man guckt den Mac App Store an, das ist halt alles fortgeschrittenes Elend.
Crickets and Tumbleweed im Wesentlichen.
Es gibt immer mal wieder ein paar Ausreißer, aber dass da jetzt gerade richtig viel Musik drin ist in dem Spiel, kann man halt nicht sagen.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich muss jetzt noch mal ganz kurz aus sehr aktuellem Anlass noch mal ganz zurückgerätchen an den Anfang der Saison, nämlich die 10 Jahre Freak Show. Ich habe eine akute Frage, nämlich seit wann sind wir eigentlich nicht mehr in unserer Aufnahmezeit begrenzt? Und ist das eine gute Entwicklung? Nee, er hat ja früher immer, da ist ihm sein komisches, wie hieße diese...
Was meinst du?
Die immer irgendwie dann...
Seitdem ich Ultraschall verwende und Ableton Live.
Ja, nicht mehr Ableton Live, genau.
Die Dateigröße, die zwei Gigabyte, meinst du?
Ja, das hörst du einfach auf.
Hältst du das für eine gute Entwicklung?
Auf gut Deutsch, Clemens will weg.
Nee, nee, ich möchte das nur gerne jetzt auch mal diskutiert haben, ob 5-Stunden-Sendungen eigentlich immer noch sinnvoll sind.
Wir haben gerade bei 4 Stunden, wir haben so spät angefangen.
Wir sind nicht bei 4 Stunden. Bei 4 Stunden hätten wir um halb 10 angefangen.
Holz-Jugend-Liobens-Sendung.
Ja, ist schon okay. Ich frage jetzt nochmal, ob das grundsätzlich erstrebenswert ist. Oder ob diese Ableton-Live-Funktion nicht doch sinnvoll war.
Es ist alles grundsätzlich möglich. Aber wir haben das ja jetzt im Prinzip schon ausreichend ausdiskutiert. Zweiter Aspekt, den wir vielleicht noch...
Eine Kleinigkeit, das ist auch so ein halbes Zurückgrätschen. Sagt euch der Name Chris Lettner noch etwas? Wisst ihr, wo der jetzt ist?
Na, nicht mehr bei Tesla.
Der ist jetzt bei Google.
Genau, macht da iKram.
Und macht da TensorFlow. Und ich bin über einen Vortrag gestolpert. Swift for TensorFlow. Die wollen tatsächlich Swift so weit anpassen, dass man damit auch Compute Kernels für Machine Learning Hardware bauen kann. Fand ich auch sehr, sehr spannend.
Haben sie sich die Lösung eingekauft und dann das Problem gesucht oder hatten sie ein Problem und haben sich die Lösung gesorgt? Ist mir da nicht ganz so klar.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so. Machine Learning besteht ja immer aus sehr viel C++ und ganz viel dreckigen Python-Code, um das irgendwie zusammenzukleben. Und diverse Leute finden das halt nicht so toll. Ich hab mir das ja auch angeguckt und wenn du dir dann anschaust, du machst so was wie Cafe-Framework auf und sagst dir, Tutorial, da sollst du erstmal irgendwas, was sowieso im Example-Tree ist, sollst du irgendwelche Sachen rumkopieren, hier ein paar Pfade ändern, dann hast du Shell-Skripte, dann hast du irgendwie komische Python-Hilfs-Skripte. Das ist alles ganz gruselig. Also, dass da mal jemand aufräumt, das wird Zeit, glaube ich.
Hört sich aber auch nicht nach so einem spannenden Top-Up an.
Ich würde dir auch bezeichnen, dass jetzt Leute den Tipp von Dennis, nämlich mal seine Katze anzugehen, live versucht haben auszuwählen und das nicht ging, weil die Katzen alle schliefen.
An dieser Stelle nochmal vielen Dank an Tim für die Aufkleber, die er geschickt hat, schon vor geraumer Zeit. Und an Christoph, der mir einen Hammer von der Wunschliste geschickt hat. Ja, die Kollegen waren auch alle sehr verwirrt, als ich mit dem Hammer durch die Firma gelaufen bin. Der war schon ein bisschen größer. Allerdings, ich hatte mir so Schlagbuchstaben, also so Prägebuchstaben. Und da gab es irgendwie auch den Hammer dazu. Aber den habe ich nicht mitgekauft, sondern auf die Wunschliste gesetzt. Und dann habe ich dann den Hammer noch dazu bekommen. Ein sehr schöner Hammer. Schlagen.
Was prägst du damit, ist die Frage.
Der Plan war ursprünglich mal Markierungen. Also ich habe ja so einen großen Wecktopf, um viel wasserheiß zu machen für allerlei Brautätigkeiten. Und der Plan war mal eine Skala innen an diesem Topf anzubringen. Mit Markierungen und Zahlen. Wie viel Wasser ist denn jetzt drin?
Aber hast du dann die Positiv- Für den Hammer?
Du kennst ja von innen positiv rein. Du guckst ja von innen rein in der Ding.
Ja genau.
Von draußen auf einen nicht durchsichtigen Topf zu gucken, ist ein bisschen albern.
Das geht allerdings, ist dieses Edelstahl dann auch härter, als ich erwartet hatte. Insofern, ich muss da noch ein bisschen üben, glaube ich.
Sie haben das Wort.
Nächstes Thema.
Du bist ja hier schon fast im Sendungsausklang. Ich wollte ja gerade noch irgendwie die Mac-Schiene fortführen.
Jetzt schicken uns Leute Bilder von ihren schlafenden Katzen. Okay.
Also ein paar Sachen nach hinten. Vielleicht noch als letztes. Die wollen den Mac Pro erst 2019 bringen, die Schweine.
Ich bin ja eh nicht so überzeugt, dass das, was auch immer da kommt, dass das so für uns Nerds so spannend ist. Zumindest erst mal nicht am Anfang, weil dann kannst du sowieso, das kann man sich ja wieder nicht leisten, was die da rausbringen. Dass der Mac Pro jetzt so einen Hype erlebt, ist ja eigentlich in seiner, ja, wie sagt man, wie nennt man so Geräte, die so wie so ein Jahreswagen, also nicht Jahreswagen, aber so, die schon so gebraucht sind, die für günstig auf Markt gekommen sind, weil die richtigen Pros wollen das anscheinend nicht mehr, was meiner Meinung nach ja fast eine Fehleinschätzung ist und haben die wahrscheinlich später dann auch gemerkt, weil der Ersatz dann doch nicht so toll war. Aber ich glaube als Original, also hätte sich Hucke jetzt auch keinen Mac Pro gekauft und ich mir auch nicht. Deswegen wird der, wenn er rauskommt, wird auch jetzt nicht so hochgelobt werden wie der Mac Pro, den wir gerade so hochleben.
Vor allen Dingen auch, weil die Leute, die dann den kaufen wollen, würden sich inzwischen längst was angekauft haben. Die sind halt einfach pissed oder haben geglaubt, dass Apple das eh nicht weiterspielt, das Spiel.
Von 2013 die Runde Tonne mit dem letzten Update, obwohl ein kleiner Speed-Bump, den gab's wohl zwischendurch schon noch, oder? Aber was die so lange machen, und ob die das brauchen.
Vielleicht gibt es ja mittlerweile auch eine Video-Editing-Soft, die auch unter Windows läuft. Ist ja vorstellbar.
Ich weiß ja auch nicht, ob Apples Strategie ist. Na ja, da sind zwar so ein paar Pros und so. Es war schade, aber die Konsumer sind halt die sehr viel größeren Markten. Wir scheißen auf die paar Prozente an Pros. Kann man machen, finde ich aber nicht so gut.
Tim hat ja noch auch dieses HomePod-Video. Stand da nicht in dem Artikel dazu, dass der halt auch mit irgendwie fancy Computer-Grafik generiert wurde? Nee, gerade nicht. Ach so, gerade nicht. Ach so, ich wollte gerade sagen, weil wenn sie das gemacht hätten, irgendwie ein Produkt oder ein Werbevideo mit aufwändiger Grafik, sollte ihnen ja aufgefallen sein, dass das Gerät etwas schwach ist.
Also, ist es jetzt nicht so, dass Apple keinen Bezug zum Pro-Markt hätte?
Also, je nachdem wie so, was ist denn eigentlich mit diesem schwarzen iMac, der heißt ja auch irgendwie Pro oder wie? Und was ist mit dem?
Der ist toll.
5K und das ist deiner.
Die Tastatur gibt es ja jetzt auch einzeln, 20 Euro extra.
Ja, also trotzdem, für das ganze Set kannst du erstmal 150 Dollar einblättern.
Der iMac Pro ist, also das wäre, sagen wir mal, für mich vielleicht eine Option.
Das ist der, der iMac Pro, der wäre eine Option für das Problem, was ich gerade habe. Aber ich hab ja immer noch die Ahnung, dass ich demnächst mein Problem auch ein bisschen ändert und ich mich anpassen muss und der iMac Pro finde ich kann sich nicht mit anpassen.
Aber in den Tischmüll-Eimer kannst du auch keine PCI Karten reinstecken.
Du kannst aber eine externe Thunderbolt 3-Gehäuse reinstecken.
Ja, nur allein diese Gehäuse.
Zahlt seit 400 Euro fürs Gehäuse.
Da hast du ja auch wieder so einen riesen Kasten, dann brauch ich die Tonne auch nicht.
Wenn du das falsche kaufst, dann ist das so laut, dass du es gar nicht erst anmachen möchtest. Aber ging ja. Ja, das letzte Mal, als ich geguckt hab, war so 400 Euro.
Aber noch ohne Karten, das ist nur das Gehäuse.
Ja, 300 oder 400 Euro für so ein Gehäuse.
Die letzten 100 Euro für das Thunderbolt-Kabel.
Nee, das ist dann schon dabei, glaube ich, bei dem Preis.
Für 20 Zentimeter wahrscheinlich.
Also bei meinem war tatsächlich so eine richtige Spanne mit der Hand.
Ich hab das auch nur so lange. War auch 25 Euro oder 30? 30 Zentimeter.
Ja, meinst du, ist glaube ich 20. Wenn es gut läuft, 20.
Dennis, du müsstest eigentlich so einen YouTube-Channel aufmachen.
Nee, vielleicht machen wir irgendwann mal wirklich dieses Kamerading. Aber zeigen nicht uns mit Kopfhörern auf, sondern stellen die Kamera hier so her. Nur so auf den Tisch. Dass man unsere Hände von oben sieht, aber unten nicht mehr. Nee, dass man dann, oh guck mal, ich hab hier ein neues iPhone. Das legst du dann unter die Kamera. Oder wenn er seine komischen Hände zeigen will, dann macht er das unter der Kamera und dann ist gut. Deine 30 Zentimeter Hände. Deine 30 Zentimeter Finger. Oder was auch immer. Ich sag nur, aber so. Keiner will alte weiße Männer.
Also ich bin kein alter weißer Mann.
Genau. Du kannst eine Exklusiv-Kamera kriegen, aber uns wollt ich gerade sagen, will keiner sehen.
Haben wir uns nicht gerade über MacPros in deinen? Ich warte jetzt mal ab. Der iMac Pro ist ganz interessant. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob der mir jetzt den Speedbump bringen würde, den ich hab.
Auf jeden Fall würde er den Speedbump bringen.
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist das. Ich hab Software, die jetzt schon meine CPUs nicht ausnutzt. Und ich weiß nicht, warum. Und der dann auf einen noch schnelleren Computer dabei zuzuschauen, wie sie die CPUs nicht ausnutzt.
Wer nutzt deine CPUs nicht? Alle deine CPUs nicht? Also auch Single-Core-Speed nutzt ihr nicht. Weil das haben die schon ordentlich deutlich reichlich.
Ja, aber das einzige, was jetzt bei so einem Pro ja zählt, ist Multi-Core. Also nur welche.
Nein, deine Applikation. Wenn du hast eine Applikation, die bloß Single-Core benutzt, dann gibt es natürlich ein schnelleres Single-Core.
Ja, aber die Gewinne, die du in Single-Core machst, die sind für mich vollkommen unerheblich. Also ich meine, die 10-20% mehr, das ist nicht das, was mich interessiert.
Das sind wahrscheinlich deutlich mehr als 10-20%.
Das sind eher so 80% wahrscheinlich.
Aber was machst du denn jetzt damit, dass du da mehr als einen Core brauchst? Oder überhaupt, meinst du jetzt dieses Audio-Rendering?
Ja, ja, Audio-Rendering.
Aber was renderst du? Denn macht auch Phonik für dich. Du spielst die rohe Scheiße da ein und hinten kommt ein super Podcast.
Wenn ihr hier dann alle rausmarschiert und ein schönes Bettchen legt und ich hier irgendwie am Arbeiten bin, dann wird erstmal hier so fünf Stunden, fünf, sechs Tracks rausgerendert. Das dauert schon mal ein bisschen.
Wie lange?
Was heißt denn jetzt rausgerendert?
Wo ist eigentlich dein Bottleneck, Timme? Ich wollte gerade sagen, was heißt denn jetzt rausgerendert?
Weiß.
Die Platte, ja.
Ich glaub auch, das ist bestimmt IO.
Nee, das ist nicht die Platte. Das hab ich schon. Ja.
Aber was rechnet der denn daran? Der hat ja Rohdaten.
Ich habe doch keine Ahnung. Ich steck doch nicht drin in dieser Software.
Nee, du bist ja der Audio-Master.
Ja, das soll ich vielleicht mal machen. Dann schalt mit euch.
Wir hinterfragen jetzt einfach mal, was du da tust. Schöne Bitte, Herr Audio-Master. Aber das ist ja nur keine Rocket-Surgery, was du da machst.
Ich bin doch nicht diese Software. Was weiß ich, warum diese Software nicht in der Lage ist, die CPUs vollkommen auszukosten.
Nee, was machst du überhaupt mit dem Audio-Signal? Du nimmst einfach RoVid und schmeißt dem auf Phonik vor die Füße. Nächste Frage.
Ja, ich hab auch auf Phonik hier lokal auf dem Rechner und so weiter und wie auch immer. Also alles, was ich tue, soll halt dann auch irgendwie... Also ich hab schon Interesse daran, dass das irgendwie stromsparender ist und so. Das ist so eine Gesamtrechnung. Aber bevor ich jetzt von diesem Setup abweiche, will ich was haben, was mir mindestens das Gleiche bietet, was ich jetzt hab.
Das ist immer ein komischer Anspruch. Ist die Industrie einfach nicht mehr bereit zu erfüllen, wenn du das noch nicht gemerkt hast? Die sagt, ich will alles haben, was ich jetzt habe, nur besser. Das ist... nee.
Doch, das will ich aber.
Das ist aber der Niedergang der PC-Industrie, wenn sie es nicht mal mehr schaffen, den Status Quo zu halten.
Ich will eine SK.
Aber da sind wir doch schon längst. Ja, ich bin auch noch kein Kaste.
Deswegen ist es ja der Niedergang. Wenn es nicht die CPU ist und nicht das IO der Platten, dann bleibt ja nur noch schlechtes Software übrig, dann bist du ja am Arsch.
Ja, aber ich weiß es nicht. Ich bin kein Experte.
Aber auch schlechtes Software müsste ja mit einer schnelleren CPU besser werden, außer er hat da Pausen drin geboten.
Ja, besser wird es schon. Die Frage ist nur, wird es so viel besser, dass sich für mich eine Investition im vierstelligen 1.000 Euro bereiten würde?
Dann mach doch mal so ein Mini-Bench-Setup, was man mal hier auf so einer Kiste zum Beispiel fahren kann, wo ein relativ flotter Chip drin ist. Und dann messen wir das einmal hier durch.
Nimmst du da so ein Projekt mit in Apple Store und renderst mal?
Ja, so weit war ich auch schon, aber du darfst bei Apple da nichts anschließen.
Aber das Ding hier, also mindestens...
Das Ding hier halt...
Das Ding hier ist aktuell... Die Hörer wissen noch, was ich für ein Rechner bin.
Die wissen aber nicht, dass du gerade deinen Rechner in der Hand hast.
Macbook Pro 2016 rechts unten plus plus.
2016 ist ja schon fast zwei Jahre alt.
Ist egal, ist aber rechts unten plus plus. Und das Ding ist schneller beim Film-Encoden als mein Hexakor zu Hause, der auch rechts unten plus plus ist. Mit der 3,46 Gigahertz hat. Wo der hier nur, weiß ich nicht, was hat.
Film-Encoden. In 2018.
Mach ich auch mal.
Und dauert richtig lange, weil X265, der braucht da ein paar Stunden. Weil der Codec halt, ist halt der heiße Scheiß, der braucht halt ein bisschen.
So, wir haben Sendungslängenrekord erreicht, dann können wir eigentlich auch aufwerfen.
Hat man nicht auch schon mal fünf Stunden zwanzig? Nee, das ist nicht fünf, acht war nicht die längste Sendung.
Wenn wir schon bei Macs sind.
Glaub ich.
Ja, jetzt.
Es gibt die rote Linie für die achte Macs.
Du musst das einfach auf deine Wunschliste setzen.
Ja, bestimmt.
Und Letty wird dann sehr glücklich, wenn da jetzt jemand klickt.
Genau, irgendwann wird mir bestimmt ein iPhone 8 schenken. In rot. Nee, aber das hat mich sehr gefreut, weil ich letztens gedacht habe, so ein rotes iPhone würde ich mir schon noch mal kaufen. Dann war aber so die Ansage, die achte gibt es gerade eh nicht in rot. Warum also?
Das iPhone X aber nicht, nur das achte iPhone und was noch für ein Ding.
Na die Siemer gab es, die haben sie etwa vor einem Jahr schon mal rausgebracht.
Ja, aber die Siemer haben sie jetzt ja rausgenommen. Dafür gibt es jetzt das achte, aber das war das iPhone 8 und noch irgendwas. War es das Plus oder ein anderes Gerät?
Genau, einfach ein iPhone 8 und das 8 Plus. Die beiden gibt es jetzt in der Redline. Und die sehen halt echt schick aus, nachdem sie das Gold so verkackt haben.
Ich finde es nur so schade, dass sie diese Product-Red-Produkte immer so hinterher schieben. Immer so scheiße Gold sind.
Egal, du hast da eh ein Cover drum, das ist doch rot.
Ja, das ist auch ein Product-Red Cover.
Nicht mehr, weil das Leder ist jetzt schon schwarz.
Nimmst du halt so ein Cover, das ist rot.
Ich liebe diese Product-Red-Cover, weil sie Apple dazu zwingen, eine ordentliche Farbe zu machen. Nicht dieser ganze hellblaue, hellgrün.
Das ist ein iPhone-Red-Rotcover-Ding.
Ja, das ist ein iPhone-Red-Cover.
Ja, aber Leder hatte ich und Leder wird irgendwann wirklich schmierig und schwarz, vor allem egal, welche Farbe es vorher war.
Es fässt sich schöner an gegenüber dem Gummikram.
Ich hatte vorher auch Leder.
Nur noch schwarz hat Leder.
Wie kann so eine Jubiläums-Sendung besser ausfallen über die Cover-Farben von iPhones? Herr Moderator?
Als ob wir da noch nie drüber geredet hätten.
Tim hat aufgegeben.
Nee, ich finde, wir sollten jetzt noch Themen abhaken. Wir machen jetzt das Workflow weg. Because we can. Zum Beispiel Formatproblem. HomePod, genau.
Das HomePod-Video.
Ist ein bisschen wie der Jeopardy, welches Fällt ist noch frei.
Trotzdem, wer hat jetzt HomePod-Video da reingesteckt?
HomePod für 400.
Ich hab das da reingetan.
Mach mal jetzt die Audio-Beschreibung zu einem Video.
Du hast das nicht gesehen.
Ich hab das gesehen.
Ja, ich hab's gesehen.
Letty ist aufgrund der Musik halt so sehr abgeschreckt.
Sagst du mir jetzt mal eigentlich, was ist das?
Ich glaub auch, dass das bei mir die Musik war, die mich da nicht weiterverführt hat.
Das Video selber ist ganz geil, man muss es ohne Ton sehen.
Was ist das für ein Video? Ist es ein Werbevideo?
Ist es ein Failvideo?
Ist es.
Ein Raum mit Audio-Space? Nichts anderes haben sie ja gesagt. Sie reden da nicht groß über Siri und es ist irgendwie auch kein Talking-Cylinder, obwohl es einer ist. Macht Sound. Und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie kriegst du das rüber? So, und ihre Szenerie ist, junge Frau kämpft sich durch den Regen, viele Leute nass, Arbeit hinter ihr, schnell nach. Hause, fahrstuhl, viele Leute, lassen sie mich mal durch, kommt dann endlich in ihre Wohnung rein, ich bin alle, ich bin fertig, was weiß ich, wird ja nicht gezeigt, was sie für einen Tag gehabt hat, aber bestimmt kein Spaß auf jeden Fall, fertig, und dann endlich zu Hause. Und dann steht sie da irgendwie noch mal so 20 Sekunden, so völlig gerädert, so überhaupt nicht mehr kommunikationsfähig, irgendwie so mit dem Glas Wasser in der Hand, so äh, äh, und sagt dann nur noch zu ihrem HomePod, so ja, hier Siri, spiel doch mal was, was sie irgendwie leiden könnte. Und dann fängt halt so ein bisschen die Musik an zu dudeln und sitzt da irgendwie auf dem Sofa, auch noch so vollkommen getiltet. Und dann wird's einfach interessant. Ich find einfach, wie sie, wie dieses Video und die Musik vor allem mit dieser Szene dann spielt, ist einfach fantastisch. Dann sitzt sie da und dann kriegt sie die Musik auch für so einen ganz kurzen Moment so ein Echo, was dann gleich wieder weggeht. So einen ganz kurzen Moment, wo das alles so eingeleitet wird, auf einmal kriegt alles so Raum, Macs so, geht dann aber gleich wieder zurück auf den normalen Sound.
Das heißt, man muss das auch mit guten Kopfhörern hören, das Video?
Ja.
Oder mit einem HomePod.
Also jetzt nicht, dass das jetzt irgendwie stereophonisch so ausgebildet ist, dass...
Nee, aber sollte das jetzt nicht so nebenbei, sondern der Sound ist schon wichtig.
Ich finde ja, aber...
Mach doch mal den Sound mal an.
Wenn du sagst, da kommt kurz Echo und dann ist wieder weg und so muss man ja schon ein bisschen genauer hinhören.
Ja gut, ich kann es jetzt mal anspielen, aber ich kann es auch erst mal erzählen. So, und dann sitzt sie da noch so ein bisschen, hat so ihr Glas an der Hand, kippt dieses Glas so ein bisschen zur Seite und in dem Moment extrudiert der Tisch, dieser Wohnzimmertisch auf so eine skurrile Art und Weise. Also er schiebt sich es aus, aber es ist nicht nur so, dass da ein Holz rausfährt, sondern der ganze Tisch an der Stelle, wo er sich verlängert, zieht dann zum Beispiel so ein auf der Schräge liegendes Magazin genau an der Stelle so in die Länge, sodass alle Farben auch mit in die Länge gezogen werden. Und auf einmal wird das alles total surreal. Und sie greift das dann irgendwie auf und die Musik geht weiter und dann beginnt sie halt zu tanzen und mit diesem Tanz zerrt sie diesen ganzen kleinen Minivohnraum in so einen riesigen Space rein, bis das alles total spacig wird und sie in so einem langen Tunnel steht und tanzt und mit sich selber tanzt und sich verdoppelt und...
Man jederzeit darauf wartet, dass irgendjemand im Tunnel die Tür zuklappt und sie dann weg ist oder so. Weiß ich nicht, aber...
Sie verschwindet ja dann im Schwarzen und dann liegt sie wieder irgendwie auf ihrem Sofa und dann ist irgendwie vorbei. Und ich war total perplex, als ich das Ding gesehen hab. Ich hab mir gleich drei, vier, fünf Mal angeschaut. Irgendwie hab ich den Ohrwurm gar nicht mehr rausbekommen.
Also das Extrodieren ist ein extrem krasses Ding, weil man sieht, dass es keine Computergrafik ist und man fragt sich sofort, wie haben die denn das gemacht? Was geht denn da und was haben die geraucht?
Es gibt schon ein Making-of dafür, oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Es gibt ein Making-of-Video und das ist auch wirklich sehr interessant.
Kannst du das mal kurz anspielen, das Video? Weil ich hab vielleicht das doch schon gesehen. Mit dem Auseinanderziehen hab ich auf jeden Fall irgendwie komm mir bekannt vor.
Na, hier so Regen und so. Wir laufen durch den Regen. Fahrstuhl. Und dann so dieses Nach Hause kommen.
Keiner hat die Wohnung aufgeräumt.
Ja, ist aber doch so relativ ordentlich.
Und hat die Hausaufgaben gefressen.
Aber der Spot ist vier Minuten lang.
Das ist auch krass amerikanisch. Kommt nach Hause und überall bei ihr zu Hause ist Licht an.
Die Serie vielleicht schon angemacht. Jetzt steht sie erst mal so paralysiert in dieser Wohnung rum.
Erst mal erholen.
Jetzt kommt kurz Echo. So und jetzt fangen halt diese Veränderungen an irgendwie und es ist halt alles mechanisch. Das ist alles ohne Computertrick, was aber wie bemerkenswert ist. Und diese Making-of kannst du halt auch sehen. Was sie da für einen Tischlereiaufwand getrieben haben, mechanisch diese ganze Wohnung zu verzerren und zu kippen und zu drehen.
Den Teil habe ich glaube ich schon mal als Ausschnittkurs gesehen.
Und vor allem diese Tänzerin. Habt ihr die schon mal gesehen?
Nee, war die neu?
Das ist eine sehr bekannte Künstlerin, die ich auch noch nicht so auf dem Zeiger hatte. Und zwar läuft die unter dem Namen FKA Twigs. Die Tanzen sind nicht nur irre, sondern die singt auch... Richtig Chartplatzierung hat und Pipapo. Also eigentlich heißt sie Talia Barnett, aber läuft halt irgendwie unter FKA Twigs und ist aber auch eine extreme Fashion-Ikone. Allein ihre Webseite fand ich schon irgendwie total irre. Mal gucken, wo die ist.
Das haben sie jetzt nicht mit nur im Tischler gemacht. Wo sie mit sich selber tanzt.
Nö, das ist natürlich Schnitt und keine Ahnung, aber ist jetzt nicht so 3D oder so.
Zum Thema mit sich selber interagieren und so. Und jetzt nicht einfach nur Schnitt oder so was machen. Es gibt ein ziemlich geiles Video von vor, keine Ahnung, 10, 15 Jahren, wo Kylie Minogue, ich glaube in Paris oder so was, mit sich selber auftaucht und zwar n Mal. Sie kommt halt aus dem Laden, die. Also wenn du jetzt gerade auf so eine Dinger stehst, das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur dumme Computer-Grafik, sondern das ist wirklich echt spannend, weil sehe ich auch andere Leute in diesem Film, die man denn sieht, so vorbeifahrende Rollerfahrer, die multiplizieren sich auch, aber eben ziemlich aufwendig gemacht.
Genau, es gibt da so ein Making-of, das ist auch sehr interessant.
Hier zum Thema Verdoppeln, da gibt es einen YouTuber, Dan, Dan and Dan nennt der sich, der spricht immer mit sich selber. Der ist immer doppelt im Bild und der eine ärgert immer den anderen. Es ist so geil. Ich weiß nicht, wie der das hinkriegt, vom Timing sich so gut zu synchronisieren, dass der eine den anderen auch immer unterbricht und so weiter. Dann und dann, den muss man mal gesehen haben.
Was mir dazu wieder einfällt, es gibt Leute, die haben sich selber mal aufgenommen, ein Video von so vor zehn Jahren oder 15 Jahren, also jedenfalls von einer deutlich längeren Zeit. Und interagieren jetzt als älteres Selbst mit ihrer Aufnahme von damals. Das ist auch ziemlich gut gemacht, eben gerade so mit sich selber diskutieren. Also es gibt eine ganze Welt von Dingen, die es dort zu entdecken gibt. Genau, das kam ja vielleicht in der Postseason, weil der Song ist halt so typisch Kylie Minogue, blabla. Aber das Video ist wirklich sehr sophisticated, vor allem für die Zeit. Das ist, wie gesagt, bestimmt 10, 15 Jahre alte Ding. Und das finde ich auch sehr faszinierend.
Ja, Kylie ist ja auch eine Geile.
Schön.
Allein schon, weil sie irgendwie zeitgleich mit mir Blinkenlides gemacht hat.
Was hat sie gemacht?
Naja, wir kamen mit Blinkenlides raus 2001 und genau in der Wochezeit, können sie auf dem Tag nicht so genau taxieren, kamen sie ja mit ihrem Welthit raus. Das unvergessliche, wie hieß es noch gleich?
Das unvergessliche, wie hieß es noch gleich?
Ja genau, das ist es.
Weiß keiner, wie das heißt, aber das ist auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Na, wie heißt es denn, verdammte Axt?
Warten wir auf die drei Leute, die im Chat noch sind?
Sie hören uns ja ein paar Sekunden verzögert. Die haben sozusagen einen kleinen Nachteil.
Ja, Entschuldigung. Geili, na wie heißt es denn das? Tralala, mein Gott. Studioalbum, bla bla bla.
Nur noch drei?
Gott, was sind das hier für eine? Ja, Fever war das Album und das Lied ist Can't get you out of my head.
Fünf sind noch.
So Blinkenlights-illuminierten Häusern. Das war damals für uns der totale Flash. Und da war Carly dann einfach The Queen of Blinkenlights, wie du dir vorstellen kannst. Und hat seitdem einen Platz in meinem Herzen. Aber ich hab ja eh ein gutes Verhältnis zu Top Pop Prinzessinnen. Also wenn der Pop richtig gut ist.
Bist du sicher, dass er am Pop liegt?
Na ich find ja Pop okay. Pop im Sinne von, also in seinem einigen Sinne nämlich Musik, die es schafft, viele Leute mitzunehmen, weil sie populär sind.
Aber Prinzessin muss es schon auch sein.
Nee, muss nicht.
Ich hab nur bei den Damen jetzt besondere Affinitäten entwickelt. Also ich hab da auch größte Verehrung für Madonna zum Beispiel. Und mir geht das halt bei den Männern meist nicht so.
Aber Kate Bush ist kein Pop, ne?
Kate Bush ist Kate Bush.
Aber irgendwas ist es ja auch eigentlich.
Bei Tims Herzen eine eigene Verleumdung.
Nein, nein, nein, Kate Bush macht keinen Pop. Aber Kate Bush entzieht sich halt eigentlich auch der Genre-Definition. Das machen nicht viele, aber sie schafft das. Also es ist schwer zu sagen, als sie anfangen, ja, Song-Wereiterin oder so was, bringt es irgendwie alles nicht zusammen.
Was eigentlich immer gut ist, wenn man das nicht mehr so benennen kann. Meistens.
Ja.
Würde ich schon sagen.
Genau.
Guck mal, im Chat haben sie echt diese Durchzähl-... Kennt ihr dieses Durchzähl-Spiel, wenn man so als Gruppen macht? Weiß ja nicht, das kennt nicht jeder. Wenn die Reihenfolge nicht stimmt, muss man ja von vorne anfangen.
Wie, wenn die Reihenfolge nicht stimmt? Reihenfolge gibt es auch?
Nein. Nein, dass du sozusagen in einer Gruppe einfach diese Durchzähl-Spielst. Und du musst halt hinkriegen, dass wirklich eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf kommen. Wenn zwei Leute sich sozusagen reinreden oder sonst was.
Ach so, wenn die Leute in so einem seriellen Chat da machen.
Genau.
Wo das sozusagen...
Ja, nee, aber wenn zwei Leute sich sozusagen überschneiden, musst du ja von vorne anfangen.
Jetzt hast du ja was gesagt.
Jetzt ist ein lustiges Spiel. Aber die schaffen es halt im Chat, ohne sich zu koordinieren. Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf und keine Überschneidung. Bis dann wieder in welche Spielverdauer kommen, mit keine Ahnung oder so was.
Ohne sich zu koordinieren.
Da, sieben, acht, super.
Das ist eine Vermutung von dir, dass sie sich nicht koordinieren.
Klar, die rufen sich jetzt separat noch an, um halb zwei oder zwei Uhr nachts, um sie diese Zahlen dazu zu synchronisieren.
Die haben ja einen privaten Channel.
Meinst du? Und wie ist das Protokoll? Guck mal, sie sind schon bis neun gekommen, ohne sich zu verhaspen.
Das ist ganz einfach. Jeder geht in einen Kanal, jeder drückt einmal auf Underscore und dann hast du die Reihenfolge, in der sie danach die Zahlen eintippen. Ganz einfach.
Underscore?
Pass auf, du hast einen Chat. In dem einen willst du diesen Zahlen-Stunt machen. So, und du hast einen zweiten Chat, wo auch dieselbe Anzahl Leute ist. Jetzt gehen alle erstmal in den einen Kanal, wo nicht gezählt wird, und drücken einfach auf Underscore Return. Daraus ergibt sich eine Reihenfolge.
Glaubst du, die haben jetzt einen separaten Kanal?
Ich hab nur gesagt, du behauptest, sie würden es nicht tun. Ich sage, du hast dafür keinen Beleg.
Ich hab dafür keinen Beleg, dass sich da Leute um zwei Uhr nach zusammenfinden, die Reihenfolge nicht hinzukriegen.
Ja, die Leute sind offensichtlich das Böse.
Die tippen alle Dollar-Count++ und dann macht das Chat-Tool das automatisch.
Das hat jemand in Slack eingebaut als Plugin.
Stimmt, Slack ist ja auch noch.
Slack ist ja auch noch. Leute.
War das schon Schluss? Ja. Jetzt schon? Ist ja noch nicht mal zwei.
Wir haben noch gar nicht über Macs geredet.
Nein, machen wir jetzt auch nicht mehr. Das war es, die große 10-Jahres-Gala. Und nächste Sendung dann auch wieder mit Hucke. Der hat dann sicherlich auch noch einiges zu erzählen. Aber wir sind jetzt am Ende.
Ist denn die nächste Sendung in einer Woche oder in zwei Wochen?
Das werden wir dann sehen. Wahrscheinlich in zwei.